>> JUST THREE GAMES A SEPARATE
FIRST THROUGH FIFTH AND THAT IS
WHEN THIS GAME IS IMPORTANT.
I LOVE THE LOOK.
>> I THINK IT HAS BEEN THE STORY
OF THE 2021 SEASON.
YOU ARE WAKING UP.
LAST YEAR, YOU WOKE UP EVERY DAY
WEARING ABOUT GETTING THROUGH
COVID.
AS A MANAGER MGM THIS YEAR, YOU
ALMOST CAN'T GET THROUGH A GAME
ANYMORE WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
INJURIES TO DEAL WITH.
>> IT IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
PROBLEMATIC.
FOR SIMPLE REASONS, THE PHILLIES
HAVE A TOP LOADED PAYROLL.
MOST OF THOSE PLAYERS, TWO OF
THEM ARE FOUR OF THE HIGHEST
PAID PLAYERS ON THE TEAM.
WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR PAYROLL GOING
TO SUCH A FEW AMOUNT OF GUYS,
THEY REPRESENT SOME MUCH OF YOUR
WAR VALUE.
WHEN YOU LOSE THEM FOR INJURIES,
THE FALLOUT IS PRETTY DRAMATIC.
>> AWFULLY BIG NAMES IN THERE.
IN CASE YOU MISSED THE
HIGHLIGHTS FROM LAST NIGHT,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> DIAZ WILL BE THE HITTER.
CENTER FIELD, WELL HIT.
HERRERA IS GOING BACK AND HE IS
THERE!
PULLED IT RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF
THE FENCE!
WHAT A PLAY!
HERRERA JUST ROBBED ISAN DIAZ OF
A HOME RUN.
>> BASE HIT SHOULD SCORE TWO.
>> BASE HIT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
ONE RUN IS IN.
HERE COMES THE SECOND.
BERTI COMES THROUGH.
MARLINS TAKE THE LEAD IN THE
EIGHTH.
>> MARLINS WIN THIS GAME, 4-2.
THE PHILLIES DEFENSE IS AWFULLY
IMPORTANT.
>> A MICROCOSM OF THEIR SEASON
IN WATCHING THEM PLAY IS WHAT
TOOK PLACE IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
FROM A, IT IS A ROUTINE DOUBLE
PLAY BALL AT A BIG-LEAGUE PLAYER
NEEDS TO MAKE.
IT IS THAT LITTLE TIME OF THE
SHORT PICK THAT COST THEM THE
DOUBLE PLAY.
FOR ME, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE PHILLIES SEASON, THEY
HAVE BEEN BRUTAL DEFENSIVELY.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO PUT IT.
AS A G.M., MANY THINGS DROVE ME
CRAZY, BUT THE ONE THING THAT
REALLY DROVE ME CRAZY IS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE A TEAM THAT DOES
NOT MAKE THE ROUTINE PLAY,
FORGET ABOUT THE EXTENDED PLAYS.
I WANT THE 6-3 TO BE A 6-3.
THEY JUST HAVE NOT MADE THE
ROUTINE PLAYS.
THE LEFT SIDE OF THEIR INFIELD
REPRESENTED 14 ERRORS.
.
AS GOOD AS THEIR STARTING
PITCHER IS, IF THEY DON'T CLEAN
THAT UP, THEY HAVE NO CHANCE TO
WIN THIS DIVISION.
>> ALEC BOHM IS A YOUNG PLAYER,
BUT --
>> AT SOME POINT IN TIME, THEY
ARE GOING TO BE FACED WITH A
DECISION OF GETTING HIM OUT OF
HERE SO THE GAME SLOWS DOWN A
LITTLE BIT, MAYBE SLIDE SEGURA
OVER TO THIRD BASE.
THEY HAVE GOT TO START CATCHING
THE BALL AND PUTTING OUT MORE.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT RUN
PREVENTION, THERE IS A REASON
WHY YOU ARE AT THE BEGINNING OF
>> THEIR VICTORY.
>>VICTORY, CAN TARA, ROGERS AND
THE KID PITCHING TODAY, LOPEZ.
.
THEY HAVE OTHER YOUNG GUYS
BEHIND THEM ON THE WAY IN
SANCHEZ, CABRERA COMING BACK
FROM INJURY.
BASICALLY, SO EXCITED ABOUT
THEIR FUTURE.
THESE THREE GUYS HAVE DOMINATED
THIS YEAR.
THEY ALL HAVE IMPROVED FROM LAST
YEAR AND HAVE MORE TALENT COMING
BEHIND THEM.
IT IS REALLY THE FOUNDATIONAL
PIECE OF THIS FRANCHISE TO MOVE
FORWARD IF THEY CAN FIGURE THEIR
POSITIONAL PLAYER THING OUT A
LITTLE BIT.
THE MARLINS HAVE A CHANCE TO BE
DOMINANT.
>> AS YOU TOLD ME ALL ALONG,
CONTRARILY ITHE BIG QUESTION, WN
TODAY'S GAME?
SPENCER HOWARD AGAINST PABLO
LOPEZ.
HOWARD, 0-1.
LOPEZ IS 1-3 WITH A 2.73
E.R.A..
WE CONTINUE HERE TODAY, MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PRESENTED BY GLAD
YOU ASKED.
UNDER 25 MINUTES AWAY FROM THE
PHILLIES AND THE MARLINS
INCLUDING AARON NOLA.
WE WILL ASK IN THE PIVOTAL
QUESTION, WHAT IS HE BETTER AT
THAN HIS BROTHER?
NOT BASEBALL.
>> DIVING STOP BALL.
TO HIS FEET.
THROWS TO FIRST.
EXCELLENT PLAY BY THE 6'5" ALEC
BOHM.
SMOKES ONE AND WHAT A PLAY BY
RHYS HOSKINS.
ROGERS WAS LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST
HIT AND RHYS HOSKINS ROBBED HIM
OF IT.
SWING AND A GROUND BALL.
DIVING, TO REYES HAS IT.
--TORREYES HAS IT.
>> I DIDN'T THINK HE WAS GOING
TO HAVE A CHANCE TO CATCH
IT.
>> HERE IS A SWING AND DRIVE
DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD LINE.
THAT ONE IS GOING TO BE A FAIR
BALL AND GONE.
FINALLY, NUMBER 100 FOR RHYS
HOSKINS.
THAT HAS GOT TO FEEL GOOD TO GET
THAT MONKEY OFF HIS BACK.
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> HE LINES INTO RIGHT FIELD.
THAT IS IT FOR A BASE HIT.
ONE IS IN.
HERE COMES MCCUTCHEN.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE BY
CHISHOLM, NOT IN TIME!
TWO RUN SINGLE FOR HARPER.
THE PHILLIES LEAVE IT 8-3.
-- LEAD IT 8-3.
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE, VICTIM
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY "GLAD YOU ASKED," A
YOUTUBE ORIGINAL SERIES THAT
LOOKS AT TIMELY QUESTIONS.
ALL EPISODES ARE AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW TO WATCH ON YOUTUBE FOR
FREE.
NO SUBSCRIPTION REQUIRED.
HEAD OVER TO YOUTUBE AND SEARCH
"GLAD YOU ASKED."
A PLEASURE BRINGING AARON NOLA
RIGHT NOW OF THE PHILADELPHIA
PHILLIES.
BIG PITCHER, HOW HAS THE SEASON
GONE SO FAR FOR YOU?
AARON: FOR MYSELF, UP AND DOWN,
NOT TOO GOOD OF A MAY FOR ME.
KIND OF GLAD IT IS OVER.
I WILL START FRESH IN JUNE, BUT
WE ARE COMPETING OUT THERE AS A
TEAM.
HAD SOME UPS AND DOWNS, SOME
GUYS HURT, HOPEFULLY, GET THOSE
GUYS BACK SOON, BUT WE ARE
LOOKING TO SPLIT THE SERIES
RIGHT HERE AGAINST MIAMI.
DANNY: I'M GOING TO LIGHTEN THE
MOMENT FOR YOU.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE SEC
TOURNAMENT RIGHT NOW.
REGIONALS. COMING UP
CHANCE TO SEE A PITCH AS A
TIGER.
I WANT YOU TO WALK US THROUGH
GROWING UP A TIGER FAN, GETTING
TO PITCH TO PACKED CROWDS.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THAT
EXPERIENCE WAS LIKE TO YOU AND
WHAT IT HAS MEANT TO YOU IN YOUR
PROFESSIONAL CAREER?
AARON: I GREW UP RIGHT DOWN THE
ROAD FROM LSU.
I WENT TO A LOT OF THE GAMES.
MY BROTHER WENT OVER THERE, SO I
WENT TO A LOT OF GAMES AND GOT
TO PLAY WITH THEM.
I WAS BLESSED TO DO THAT FOR ONE
YEAR.
WE WENT TO REGIONALS EVERY YEAR
AND SUPER REGIONALS A COUPLE OF
TIMES AND WORLD SERIES ONE TIME.
ONE OF THE MOST FUN TOURNAMENTS
IS THE SEC TOURNAMENT.
YOU ARE OUT OF SCHOOL AND YOU
GET TO PLAY BASEBALL.
IT IS KIND OF LIKE WHAT WE ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW.
IT IS JUST A GOOD ATMOSPHERE
OVER THERE IN HOOVER.
IT IS A FUN TIME AND TO PLAY IN
ALEX BUCK STADIUM IS PRETTY
AMAZING.
YOU GET 10,000 TO 12,000 FANS
PRETTY MUCH EVERY GAME.
ONCE SUPER REGIONALS COME IT IS
PRETTY LIVE.
KYLE: CONTINUING THE LIGHTER
THEME, THE STRIKE YOU HAD
AGAINST MARTIN PEREZ, TAKE US
THROUGH THAT.
AARON: I DID NOT MEAN TO HIT THE
BACK FOOT.
I TRIED TO GO FOR BRETT FOOT
BAKING -- BREAKING BALL.
WHEN HE SLUNG, HIS BACK LEG FLEW
OUT TOWARDS THE PLAY.
DAN: THE EVOLUTION OF YOUR
CHANGEUP, I THOUGHT YOU HAD AN
ABOVE AVERAGE CHANGEUP IN
COLLEGE, YOU GOT AWAY FROM AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE PRO-CAREER
AND REALLY FOCUS ON YOUR
BREAKING BALL.
BUT NOW, IT IS BACK AND IT IS A
DEVASTATING PITCH.
DID YOU CHANGE HER GRIP ON THAT?
DID YOU DO SOMETHING TO THAT TO
GIVE IT THE EFFECTIVENESS IT HAS
RIGHT NOW?
AARON: I CHANGE THE GRIP UP A
LITTLE BIT.
COLLEGE AND FIRST COUPLE YEARS
OF PRO BALL, I HAD A FOUR SEAM
GRIP.
NOW, I HAVE A TWO-SEAM GRIP.
I'M NOT ON ANY OF THE SCENES
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I CAN GET
SLOWER THAN THAT AND TRY TO COME
I BACKSIDE, MY BACK LEG.
IT HAS BEEN A WORK IN PROGRESS,
BUT I FEEL LIKE EVERY YEAR, I'VE
GOT TO TRY TO BE MORE CONSISTENT
WITH IT AND ERROR IT A LOT IN
SPRING TRAINING.
IT IS JUST A FIELD PITCH.
DAN: I THINK IT IS GREAT,
UNBELIEVABLE THAT YOU THINK YOU
HAVE TO KEEP WORKING ON IT.
GOOD FOR YOU.
EVERY DAY, YOU READ ABOUT VELO
AND SPIN RATES AND TECHNOLOGY
THAT HELPS.
WHEN I WATCH YOU, I THINK I GUY
ON THE MOUND THAT IS PREPARED TO
COMPETE AGAINST HIS OPPONENT,
BUT MAKES ADJUSTMENTS BASED UPON
FEEL AS THE GAME GOES ALONG.
WHICH KIND OF BOX DO YOU FALL IN
IN TODAY'S GAME?
AARON: JUST LIKE YOU SAID, I
FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO PREPARE A
LOT.
I'M NOT A GUY WHO IS GOING TO
BLOW FASTBALLS BY YOU.
I CAN'T GO OUT THERE AND THROW
95 TO HUNDRED -- 100.I
HAVE TO TRY TO COMMAND ALL MY
PITCHES, ALL THREE OF THEM AND
MAKE BIG PITCHES WHEN I NEED TO.
I FEEL LIKE IT IS ALWAYS A GRIND
OUT THERE AND I REALLY TRY TO
TAKE MY DURING SESSIONS IN A
GAME LIKE.
I WAS BELIEVE CREATING GOOD
HABITS OFF THE MOUND CREATES
THEM ON THE MOUND.
KYLE: WELL SAID.
A GUY WHO ALSO HAS GREAT HABITS
IS JOE GIRARDI.
HE IS OBVIOUS TO A NO-NONSENSE
GUY AND LOVE IN THE GAME.
WHAT HAS BEEN LIKE PITCHING FOR
A GUY LIKE JOE?
AARON: AWESOME.
I LOVE PLAYING FOR JOE, WE ALL
DO.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HE HAS
ACCOMPLISHED IN HIS CAREER.
PLAYED A WHILE.
JUST AN INTENSE PERSON, INTENSE
MANAGER.
I THINK PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES
NEED THAT.
IT IS GOOD WORKING UNDER HIM.
KYLE: I KNOW THIS HAS BEEN A
FRUSTRATING SEASON.
INJURIES HAVE BEEN DECIMATING
ACROSS THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY.
I HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO ASK A
PLAYER THIS QUESTION YET, WHY DO
YOU THINK WE ARE SEEING SO MANY
SOFT TISSUE INJURIES THIS YEAR?
AARON: MAYBE IT IS BECAUSE OF
LAST YEAR.
ONLY 60 GAMES.
I KNOW LAST YEAR WAS KIND OF
LIKE A SPRINT.
DAN: IT IS REALLY CLOSE TO SEE
TWO BROTHERS MAKE THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
WHAT ARE YOU BETTER THAN AUSTIN
AT?
AARON: TO BE HONEST, I'M NOT
REALLY BETTER AT HIM THEN -- IN
MUCH.
WE GO BACK AND FORTH IN A LOT OF
THINGS.
PING-PONG IS ONE OF THEM.
HE WILL SAY HE IS BETTER THAN
ME, BUT OVER THE YEARS, I HAVE
IMPROVED MY GAME AGAINST HIM.
KYLE: JOHN SMOLTZ SAYS HE IS A
BETTER PING-PONG PLAYER THAN
PITCHER.
WE WILL GET SOME PING-PONG
TOGETHER.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME.
HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE SEASON
AND THANKS AGAIN.
AARON: THANK YOU GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
KYLE: IT IS TIME NOW FOR CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT.
A GUY WHO IS A HUGE FAN
FAVORITE, JOLLY OLIVE.
HE HAS GOT EIGHT TO 10 MINUTES
OF VIDEOS FOCUSING ON CURRENT,
BE NEWS AS WELL AS PLAYER
SPECIFIC CONTENT CONSIDERED
FORGOTTEN IN THE SPORT.
HIS FAVORITE TEAM IS THE METS
AND HIS FAVORITE MOMENT, I'M
GOING TO ASK HIM ABOUT.
NOW, JOLLY OLIVE KIND ENOUGH TO
JOIN US.
I SEE METS FAN AND I FEEL
TERRIBLE.
WHAT IS IT LIKE, A METS FAN THIS
YEAR IN PARTICULAR.
IT IS THE WALKING WOUNDED OUT
THERE.
JOLLY: IT IS TOTAL WHIPLASH
BECAUSE YOU GET INTO A WHOLE NEW
ERA OF METS BASEBALL, BUT IT IS
VERY REMINISCENT OF THE FIRST
TIME I WATCHED IN 2009 WHEN
EVERYBODY GOT INJURED.
IT IS DEFINITELY JARRING.
IT WAS THE FIRST PLAYOFF GAME I
EVER ATTENDED.
IT WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF DANIEL
MURPHY'S HOME RUN BARRAGE WHERE
HE HIT A HOME RUN SEVEN GAMES
AND AROUND.
IT WAS ALSO A SURPRISE GAME FOR
ME BECAUSE I WAS AT SCHOOL, HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR THAT DAY.
MY DAD TEXTED ME AND WAS LIKE,
HOPE YOU DON'T HAVE PLANS
TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO THE
GAME.
IT WAS COMPLETELY OUT OF
NOWHERE.
THE ATMOSPHERE OF PLAYOFF
BASEBALL AT CITI FIELD WAS
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE AND
SOMETHING I WILL REMEMBER FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE.
KYLE: THERE IS MURPHY.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION THERE?
JOLLY: SCREAMING AT THE TOP OF
MY LUNGS.
I LOST MY VOICE FOR AT LEAST TWO
DAYS BECAUSE OF ALL THE
SCREAMING AT THAT GAME.
KYLE: I DON'T BLAME YOU.
FORGOTTEN PLAYERS.
THIS IS SUCH AN INTERESTING
CONCEPT.
HOW DID YOU COME UPON THIS?
JOLLY: IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
I WAS REALLY INTO BASEBALL CARDS
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER.
I'M STILL YOUNG, BUT I BASICALLY
BECAME VERY IN TUNE WITH A LOT
OF THE GUYS THAT WERE NOT
CONSIDERED STARS OF THE GAME BY
ANY MEANS.
BETWEEN BASEBALL CARDS AND VIDEO
GAMES, I WAS HAD A HUGE SPACE IN
MY BRAIN FULL OF USELESS BASED
ON KNOWLEDGE UNTIL I TRIED TO
MAKE IT USEFUL.
MY BIG PHILOSOPHY WAS TRYING TO
FIND SOMETHING NOBODY ELSE WAS
DOING.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE PERFECT
BECAUSE THESE WERE A LOT OF GUYS
NOBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT AND A
LOT OF THEM DID COOL THINGS IN
THE GAME EVEN IF THEY ARE
CONSIDERED MINOR ON AGREEMENT
SCALE.
KYLE: WHO WAS THE ONE YOU SAID
HONESTLY, THIS NEEDS TO BE KNOWN
ABOUT THIS FORGOTTEN PLAYER?
I WANT TO KNOW THAT A MEGAPHONE
AND TELL EVERYBODY ABOUT THIS
PLAYER.
JOLLY: THE BIGGEST ONE FOR ME,
AND I'M GLAD THE VIDEO DID WELL
WAS THE FORGOTTEN BATTING
CHAMPION, FREDDY SANCHEZ.
FREDDY SANCHEZ WAS ONE OF MY
FAVORITE PLAYERS GROWING UP.
HE PLAYED FOR SOME PRETTY BAD
PIRATES TEAMS BUT WAS ALWAYS A
GREAT PLAYER.
HE PLAYED SECOND BASE.
HE ACTUALLY SAW THE VIDEO I MADE
ABOUT HIM THROUGH HIS KID, I
BELIEVE.
HE WAS NICE ENOUGH TO SEND ME A
SIGNED BALL FROM THE WORLD
SERIES AND ASSIGNED BALL FROM
THE ALL-STAR GAME HE WAS IN.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
KYLE: THAT IS EPIC.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO GET
SOMETHING FROM THE DEAD BALL
ERA.
DAN: NOT TOO FAR BACK.
-- JOLLY: NOT TOO FAR BACK.
I MADE THIS TOWARDS THE
BEGINNING OF MY CHANNEL, BUT IT
IS A SHORT-LIVED RIVALRY BETWEEN
RONALD ACUNA JR. AND THE MARLINS
THAT SEEMED VERY ONE-SIDED FOR A
LONG TIME.
I THINK IT HAPPENED WHEN RONALD
WAS SITTING ALL THE LEADOFF HOME
RUN'S AND MAKING A NAME FOR
HIMSELF IN THE LEAGUE.
THE TEAM HE WAS TATTOOING THE
MOST WAS THE MIAMI MARLINS.
I DECIDED TO MAKE A VIDEO AND
ANALYZE ALL OF THE MINOR
IDIOSYNCRASIES GOING ON AND THE
BEES, AS ONE-SIDED AS IT WAS.
PEOPLE REALLY TOOK TO IT AND
REALLY ENJOYED THAT VIDEO.
I THINK THE BEES HAS COOLED DOWN
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO SEE
ACUNA GETTING HIT FOR JUST
HITTING HOME RUNS, BUT PEOPLE
ARE STILL WATCHING THAT VIDEO.
IF THEY DID NOT KNOW ABOUT THE
BEEF BEFORE, THEY KNOW ABOUT IT
NOW.
KYLE: TRADE DEADLINES.
YOU PUT A VIDEO OUT ABOUT THE
MOST RECENT TRADE DEADLINES.
SMART OF YOU TO GET OUT IN FRONT
OF IT NOW.
JOLLY: IT IS DEFINITELY A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE I AM A METS FAN AND
ALREADY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
TRADES BECAUSE EVERYONE IS
INJURED.
[LAUGHTER]
IT KIND OF FED INTO THAT A
LITTLE BIT.
THE TRADE DEADLINE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN FASCINATING TO ME.
I LIKE THAT IT IS BIGGER IN
BASEBALL THAN PRETTY MUCH ANY
OTHER SPORT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF TEAMS THAT
MAKE OR BREAK THEIR SEASON.
THERE IS A LOT OF GREAT
CANDIDATES THIS YEAR BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF TEAMS THAT
ARE EITHER FRINGED OR NEED ONE
OR TWO PIECES TO GET TO THE NEXT
ECHELON.
I MAY EVEN MAKE A PART THREE.
ALL THE COMMENTS ARE HEY, YOU
SHOULD TALK ABOUT THIS GUY.
PEOPLE SEEM TO REALLY ENJOY IT.
KYLE: TRILOGIES ARE ALWAYS
RISKY.
I VOTE FOR A PART THREE AS LONG
AS IT IS BETTER THAN "THE
GODFATHER PART THREE."
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH JOLLY
OLIVE?
IS THIS A "POPEYE" REFERENCE?
JOLLY: FIRST I'VE HEARD OF THAT.
I KNEW I WANTED TO MAKE MY
CHANNEL THEME GREEN.
JOLLY OLIVE WAS A NICKNAME I HAD
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
I HAD A LOT OF NICKNAMES GOING
UP AND THAT IS THE ONE I ALWAYS
ENJOYED BECAUSE IT WAS SO OUT
THERE AND STRANGE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST SOMETHING
THAT ROLLED OFF THE TONGUE WELL
SO I DECIDED TO GO WITH IT.
NOW, WE ARE AT 18,000
SUBSCRIBERS SO I DON'T THINK I
CAN CHANGE IT, BUT I STILL LIKE
IT AND I LIKE BEING CALLED
JOLLY.
KYLE: HOW DID YOU GET THE
NICKNAME?
THERE HAS TO BE A REASON WHY.
YOU WERE LAUGHING OR YOU ARE
GLUM AND IT WENT THE OTHER DAY.
HOW DOES IT FIT IN?
JOLLY: IT PLAYS ON MY LAST NAME.
THE JOLLY PART COMES FROM JUST
BEING A HAPPY-GO-LUCKY KID IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL LOOKING AT ALL MY
BASEBALL CARDS.
[LAUGHTER]
KYLE: WE ALL NEED TO FIND OUR
PASSIONS AND JOYS IN LIFE.
I'M GLAD YOU FOUND YOURS.
JOLLY: THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
KYLE: GREAT STUFF FROM JOLLY
OLIVE.
SPENCER HOWARD HAS NOT PITCHED
MUCH SO FAR THIS YEAR FOR THE
PHILLIES, BUT HE WILL GET THE
CALL AGAINST THE MIAMI MARLINS.
MORE ON THIS MATCHUP INCLUDING
PABLO LOPEZ.
HOW MANY STRIKEOUTS WILL THEY
GET AGAINST THE PHILLIES?
ALL OF THAT IS COMING UP AS WE
ARE GETTING YOU SET.
PHILLIES AND MARLINS DOING
BATTLE.
>> AND NOW BOHM, OFF THE WALL IN
RIGHT.
GET IT IN.
HARPER STOPS AND THERE IS
ANOTHER ONE.
THAT IS ANOTHER OUTFIELD ASSIST
FOR ADAM DUVALL.
LINED AND CAUGHT BY RO.
ROJAS TAKES A HIT AWAY.
YOU GOT TO BE GETTING ME!
WHAT A THROW BY SIERRA.
COOPER SENDS ONE IN THE AIR LEFT
FIELD.
THIS ONE IS HIT DEEP.
THIS ONE IS GONE.
WE ARE TIED IN THE SEVENTH.
GARRETT COOPER DOES IT AGAIN.
FLY BALL OUT TO DEEP LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
GARRETT COOPER IS THE HERO TODAY
!
IT IS A MARLIN'S WALKOFF WINNER!
THE BIG HOME RUN AND LAST
NIGHT'S BALLGAME TIED IT UP.
TONIGHT, THE WALKOFF WINNER.
>> FOR THE MARLINS, THEIR SECOND
WALK A VICTORY OF THE SEASON.
BOY, DID THEY NEED THIS WHEN.
-- WIN.
KYLE: YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY "GLAD YOU ASKED."
IT IS TIME NOW FOR PICKS TO
CLICK PRESENTED BY BETMGM.
THIS IS ALWAYS FUN TO PUT DAN
O'DOWD ON THE SPOT.
DAN: WHATEVER I PICK, PICK THE
OTHER.
KYLE: THE LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE IS
ALWAYS INTERESTING.
TOTAL RUNS SCORED, THE
OVER-UNDER IS SEVEN.
THE UNDER HAS HIT IN EIGHT OF
THE LAST 10 PHILLIES ROAD GAMES.
DAN: I'M GOING OVER.
I THINK THE PHILLIES ARE DUE.
SOME POINT IN TIME, YOU PLAY THE
GAME AT ODDS.
I DO BELIEVE THE PHILLIES ARE
DUE TO SCORE SOME RUNS AT SOME
POINT IN TIME.
TODAY IS THE DAY FOR ME.
KYLE: SEVEN IS NOT A TON OF
RUNS.
WE WILL SEE.
THAT IS THE OVER.
STRIKEOUTS FOR PABLO LOPEZ, A
PART OF THOSE GREAT YOUNG
MARLINS VICTORY WITH ALCANTARA
AND ROGERS.
SIX OR MORE STRIKEOUTS.
DAN: OVER.
EVERYBODY IS STRIKING OUT.
THAT IS NOT A REACH.
KYLE: PHILADELPHIA, THEY ARE
SECOND-MOST IN STRIKEOUTS.
DAN: THIS GUY'S CHANGEUP IS
UNHITTABLE.
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE GAME.
KYLE: BEHIND TAMPA BAY, NO ONE
STRIKES MORE THAN THE PHILLIES.
HOW ABOUT OUTS FOR PABLO LOPEZ?
17.5.
THAT IS AROUND 5.2.
DAN: I'M GOING TO GO OVER.
KYLE: HE HAS DONE THAT IN FIVE
OF 10 STARTS.
DAN: 50-50.
KYLE: YOU LOOK AT HIS NUMBERS,
HE MATCHED HIS SEASON BEST WITH
SEVEN INNINGS.
DAN: LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGE.
HE THROWS THAT MORE THAN ANY
OTHER PITCH.
KYLE: THAT IS STUNNING TO ME.
DAN: IF YOU HAVE A GOOD
CHANGEUP, YOU ARE GOING TO GET A
LOT OF SWINGS AND MITCH --
MISSES.
KYLE: WHICH TEAM WILL WIN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE EAST?
DAN: WHOEVER HAS THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF INJURIES BETWEEN NOW
AND THE END OF THE YEAR.
I'M GOING TO STILL STICK WITH
ATLANTA.
I'M NOT CRAZY ABOUT THEIR
BULLPEN.
SIROCCO GOING BACK ON THE DEAL
HURT THEM.
YOU LOOK AT THE REST OF THE
CLUBS IN THIS DIVISION AND THERE
ARE SO MANY?
.
KYLE: THE METS ARE THE FAVORITE
AT -115.
DAN: I'M GOING TO TAKE ATLANTA
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE IT BEFORE
AND THE METS STILL HAVE NOT
FIGURED OUT HOW TO WIN YET.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THEIR HEALTH.
KYLE: YOU GET PLUS MONEY ON THE
BRAVES.
DAN: THAT IS WHY I WENT BRAVES.
I AM A GAMBLING MAN.
KYLE: DON'T CONDESCEND ME.
I'M SORRY, I APOLOGIZE.
DAN: I'M TRYING TO ACT LIKE I
KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
KYLE: WHICH DIVISION WILL HAVE
THE N.L. PENDANT WINNER?
DAN: I'M GOING TO SAY N.L. WEST.
MAYBE THE TWO BEST TEAMS IN
BASEBALL RESIDE IN THE N.L. WEST
IN THE DODGERS AND PADRES.
KYLE: N.L. WEST, 130.
SAFE PICK THERE.
I JUST WANT TO GO BACK TO
SPENCER HOWARD.
YOU ARE TELLING ME, IN AN IDEAL
WORLD, HE WOULD NOT BE POSTING
SERVICE.
DAN: THE PROBLEM WITHIN OUR GAME
TODAY, THIS YOUNG MAN HAS
PITCHED ONLY FOR INNINGS AT
DOUBLE-A.
I JUST DON'T THINK HE IS READY
TO PITCH CONSISTENTLY WELL.
HE WILL HAVE A FEW GOOD STARTS,
BUT LOOK AT HIS VELOCITY
READINGS.
WHAT THAT TELLS ME, ONE, HE IS
COMING OUT AND THROWING AS HARD
AS HE POSSIBLY CAN.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
MENTALLY, HE HAS NOT FIGURED OUT
HOW TO MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT.
THOSE ARE THE FIVE KIND OF
THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN A PLAYER
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM YOU LEARN AT
THE MINOR LEAGUE LEVEL, HOW TO
TRUST YOUR STUFF WITHOUT
THROWING AS HARD AS YOU POSSIBLY
CAN.
THE PHILLIES ARE IN A BOX.
THE HAS STEPPED UP AND BEEN
PRETTY GOOD NOW IN THAT FOR
SPOT.
THEIR TOP THREE HAS BEEN AN
ALL-STAR.
AFTER THAT, IT HAS BEEN
PROBLEMATIC.
IT IS A CASE FOR ME WHERE THE
PHILLIES, THE TOP LINE OF THEIR
CLUB IS GOOD.
THE DEPTH OF THE ORGANIZATION IS
VERY BAD.
CONSEQUENTLY, YOU END UP RUSHING
A PLAYER LIKE THIS WHO HAS
ABILITY BUT NOT EXPERIENCED YET
WHERE HE SHOULD BE AT THE
BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
KYLE: HE WILL HAVE THAT
CHALLENGE AGAINST THE MARLINS
TODAY.
NEWS JOINING US AS NOAH
SYNDERGAARD AS -- IS SHUT DOWN
FOR ANOTHER SIX WEEKS.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT HAS BEEN
BESET BY CALAMITOUS INJURIES.
DAN: MIGHT NOT PITCH THIS YEAR.
SANDY ALDERSON IS A HALL OF FAME
BASEBALL MAN FOR ME.
THEY COULD NOT GO INTO THIS
SEASON IN MY MIND THINKING HE
WAS GOING TO HELP THEM AT ALL.
WHATEVER THEY GOT FROM HIM --
KYLE: I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE BACK
SOON OR JULY.
DAN: COMING OFF, JOHN'S, WE HAVE
THIS THOUGHT PROCESS WITH THE
ENERGY -- INDUSTRY.
AS SOON AS YOU GET TOMMY JOHN
DONE, YOU'RE GOING TO BE DONE.
WHAT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT WHAT
TOMMY JOHN IS ALL THE PLAYERS
THAT DON'T COME BACK.
YOU COULD NOT GO INTO THIS
SEASON THINKING FROM A PLANNING
STANDPOINT AND DEPTH STANDPOINT
THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE A PART
OF YOUR ROTATION AT SOME POINT.
IF THAT HAPPENED, THAT WAS ONLY
GOING TO MAKE YOU THAT MUCH
BETTER.
I FEEL MORE DISAPPOINTED NOW FOR
THE PLAYER.
HE HAS A FREE AGENT AT THE END
OF THE YEAR.
IF HE DOES NOT GET A CHANCE TO
GET ON THE MOUND AT ALL, THAT
PUTS HIM IN A PRECARIOUS
SITUATION AS HE ENTERS THIS
OFF-SEASON.
KYLE: THAT CERTAINLY COULD BE
FRUSTRATING FOR THE METS.
EARLIER, JOLLY OLIVE WAS LOOKING
AT THE TRANSACTIONS AND TRADE
DEADLINE BECAUSE HE WANTS KNOW
WHAT THE METS COULD BRING IN.
HOW MANY MOVES CAN YOU REALLY
MAKE?
DAN: YOU HAVE GOT TO GET YOUR
CORE PLAYERS.
KYLE: WE TALKED ABOUT THE
MARLINS PITCHING.
WHAT ABOUT JESUS AGUILAR FINDING
HIS STROKE AGAIN?
DAN: THEY DID, BUT INDIVIDUALLY,
THEY HAVE SOME PLAYERS HAVING
REALLY GOOD YEARS.
COREY DICKERSON IS PERFORMING
WELL.
CHAD CHISHOLM HAS MADE A REALLY
BIG IMPACT.
IT IS WEIRD BECAUSE WHEN YOU PUT
IT ALL TOGETHER, THEY DON'T
SCORE RUNS.
LOSING MARTE, GETTING HIM BACK
IS GOING TO BE CRUCIAL.
THE MARLINS COULD BE THE SLEEPER
TEAM AT THE DEADLINE.
THEY HAVE THE KIND OF STARTING
PITCHING AND THEIR CLOSER HAS
BEEN LIGHTS OUT FOR THEM THIS
YEAR.
MAYBE THEY CAN BE ONE THAT ADDS
IT BACK INTO THIS MIX THAT PUTS
THEM IN THE POSITION OF HAVING
AN OPPORTUNITY TO POTENTIALLY
WIN THIS DIVISION.
KYLE: INTERESTING POINT.
JAZZ CHISHOLM ROLLED HIS ANKLE.
POLL RESULTS THIS GAME TODAY AT
THE PHILIP -- PHILLIES WINNING
67%.
DAN: JUST PLAYING THE ODDS, THE
PHILLIES HAVE BEEN SO HORRENDOUS
ON THE ROAD SO FAR.
THEIR TALENT IS SO GOOD THAT AT
SOME POINT TIME, YOU FEEL LIKE
THEY ARE GOING TO START WINNING
A FEW MORE GAMES.
KYLE: PHILLIES OUTFIELDERS NOT
NAMED BRYCE HARPER, 645 O.P.S..
DAN: AGAIN, IT IS AN INCOMPLETE
TEAM AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
WHEN YOU LOSE RYO NAITO AND YOU
LOSE HARPER, YOU REALLY ARE
GOING TO HAVE A TOUGH TIME
PUTTING UP POINTS BECAUSE THEIR
OFFENSE IS BUILT AROUND THOSE
GUYS.
KYLE: EXCITED THIS YEAR'S PLAYER
VANDERBILT.
DAN: I'M GOING TO GO DOWN AND
WATCH THE GAMES THIS WEEKEND.
I'M EXCITED.
ADAM: PHILLIES AND MARLINS
COMING UP.
ENJOY THE GAME, EVERYBODY.
>> HERE IS THE PITS.
♪
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
>> ARE YOU GETTING ME?
-- KILLING ME -- KIDDING ME?
>> LOOK AT THIS.
COME A CALL THE GAME FROM THIS
EXACT SPOT?
LUNCHTIME IN SOUTH FLORIDA OR
MAYBE BREAKFAST FOR THE LATE
WAKE-UP CROWD.
THIS BALLPARK BARELY RESTED FROM
LAST NIGHT TO TODAY'S 12:10
EASTERN FIRST PITCH.
FOR THE GLOBAL AUDIENCE, THIS IS
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY "GLAD YOU
ASKED." I'M SCOTT BRAUN ALONG
WITH TWO OF MY VERY GOOD FRIENDS
DAN PLESAC RIGHT HERE AND CLIFF
FLOYD IS ACTUALLY IN THIS
STUDIO, JUST DISTANCE FOR US.
I WILL START OFF WITH TWO TRIVIA
QUESTIONS.
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU ARE THE
FIRST MARLINS PLAYER TO EVER
HAVE YOUR OWN BOBBLEHEAD OUT
AGAIN.
GO AHEAD.
THERE WE GO.
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU ARE THE
LAST PHILLIES PITCHER TO CLOSE
OUT VETERANS STADIUM.
GOOD.
I JUST WANTED TO GO OVER SOME
RESUME ACTION.
AND NOW, WE CAN BEGIN.
TO THIS GLOBAL AUDIENCE ON
YOUTUBE, WE ARE STREAMING LIVE,
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
THIS CHANNEL FEATURES ALMOST 3
MILLION SUBSCRIBERS.
WE MIGHT HIT THE MAGIC NUMBER
TODAY.
SOMEONE MIGHT CLICK SUBSCRIBE
AND BE NUMBER 3 MILLION ON THE
CHANNEL.
WE DO ALL KINDS OF AMAZING
THINGS HERE.
WE WILL CHAT WITH PLAYERS DURING
THE GAME, MIKE DUNN CONTENT.
MANY OTHER SPECIAL FEATURES
HEADING YOUR WAY.
LET'S START WITH THE VISITING
TEAM.
NINE CONSECUTIVE NON-WINNING
SEASONS FOR PHILADELPHIA.
THEY HAVE BEEN SPENDING BIG AND
TRYING TO WIPE THAT AWAY.
M.V.P.'S LIKE MCCUTCHEN AND
HARPER AND THEN A LITTLE
PITCHING, ZACK WHEELER SIGNED
AWAY FROM THE METS.
LOOK AT THE CHUNK OF CHANGE IT
TOOK TO GET ALL THESE GUYS.
THEY RE-SIGNED DIDI GREGORIUS AS
WELL, TWO YEARS, $20 MILLION.
THE PHILLY PHANATIC'S PRICELESS
BY THE WAY.
DAN: LITERALLY SOLD THE SHIRT
OFF THE FANATICS BACK TO PUT
THIS TEAM TOGETHER.
IT HAS NOT BEEN FOR A LACK OF
EFFORT.
SCOTT: AND RIGHT NOW, MCCUTCHEN
IS OUT TODAY.
BRYCE HARPER IS ON THE INJURED
LIST, SO IS DJ REALMUTO.
WHO IS GOING TO STEP UP?
DAN: I THINK RIGHT NOW, IT IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE RHYS
HOSKINS.
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND THEY
ARE NOT INDICATIVE OF SEEING THE
BALL BETTER.
SINCE APRIL 27, ONLY TWO HOME
RUNS.
HE IS STARTING TO MAKE BETTER
CONTACT HITTING A BIG HOME RUN.
VELASQUEZ PITCHED VERY WELL AND
STARTING TO HIT THE BALL TO
RIGHT AND RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
HE WILL PULL IT FOR A HOME RUN.
THEY NEED RHYS HOSKINS IN THE
WORST WAY TO KEEP GOING.
SCOTT: WHEN HE DEBUTED IN AUGUST
OF 2017, HE HAD 11 HOMERS IN HIS
FIRST 18 GAMES.
LOOK AT HIS RANKS SINCE HIS
DEBUT.
WE HAVE SEEN A LITTLE CHANGED
HIS HITTING PROFILE THIS YEAR.
LES WALKS, MORE STRIKEOUTS.
HE HAD MORE POWER IN APRIL THEN
WE SAW IN MAY.
HE WILL HELP SUPPORT THE LUXURY
BELL.
FOR THE MARLINS, THEY ARE ONE OF
THE LOWEST PAYROLL TEAMS IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THEY WILL GO AGAINST SPENCER
HOWARD, BUT THEY WILL BE
THROWING PABLO LOPEZ ON THE
MOUND TODAY WHO LOVES THE HOME
COOKING.
HE IS A REALLY NICE GUY, BUT NOT
A FUN --
CLIFF: THE BIGGEST THING WITH
PABLO, HE HAS MADE MAJOR STRIDES
, JUST SORT OF DEFINING HIS
REPERTOIRE, UNDERSTANDING WHAT
YOU NEED TO DO TO BE A GOOD,
SOLID PITCHER IN THIS LEAGUE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS CHANGEUP
AND SOME OF THE THINGS HE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DO AS FAR AS MAKING
SURE HE GETS LONGEVITY OUT OF
HIS OUTINGS, MAKING SURE HE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT HE HAS TO DO
CONSISTENTLY TO GET THESE
LEAGUERS OUT, ESPECIALLY GUYS
LIKE RHYS HOSKINS, IS KEEP THESE
GUYS OFF BALANCE.
I WAS FELT THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE FASTBALL CHANGEUP
COMBINATION, IT WORKS.
IT REALLY KEEPS GUYS OFF
BALANCE.
THIS IS JUST GOING TO SORT OF
LEAN INTO WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU SEE HIS FASTBALL AGAINST
LEFTIES, GETTING IN ON A GUY
LIKE JOSH BELL IS NOT EASY TO
DO.
BRANDON BELT JAMS THEM AND GET
THEM OFF OF THEM.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CHANGEUP IN YOUR SECONDARY
PITCHES TO GET YOUR FASTBALL.
YOU CANNOT BE A FASTBALL TYPE OF
GUY ALL THE TIME.
THAT BALL RIGHT THERE IS RUNNING
IN ON A HITTER THAT IS LOOKING
ON TRYING TO CHEAT.
A GUY LIKE PAUL BUSHMAN, YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO GET HIM OUT
SUCCESSFULLY IF YOU ARE A
ONE-DIMENSIONAL PITCHER.
I GUY LIKE BARNES ALSO SHOWING
REALLY QUICK TO THE BASEBALL.
PABLO HAS DONE A TERRIFIC JOB
KEEPING GUYS OFF BALANCE.
UTILIZE HIS CHANGEUP AND WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THIS ROTATION AND
YOU TALK ABOUT LENGTH AND
LONGEVITY, NOT JUST THIS YEAR,
BUT LONG-TERM, PABLO LOPEZ IS
GOING TO BE IN THE MIX BECAUSE
HE HAS LEARNED HOW TO PITCH.
HIS E.R.A. IS GOING DOWN FROM
2019 WHEN IT WAS OVER FIVE.
THAT IS HIM UNDERSTANDING WHAT
HE HAS TO DO.
I'M DOWN THERE WATCHING THESE
GUYS AND IT IS GOING TO BE FUN
TO WATCH.
SCOTT: STATCAST 3D SHOWING US
ALL THE STRIKEOUTS.
HIS CHANGEUP USAGE,
SECOND-HIGHEST IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THERE ARE SOME BIG NAMES MISSING
FOR BOTH SIDES.
FOR MORE ON DOCUMENT AND GOT,
LET'S SEND IT OVER TO CHRISTINA,
FOURTH MEMBER OF OUR CREW.
SHE IS IN MIAMI AT THE BALLPARK.
ROSINA: I'M HERE AT LOANDEPOT
PARK WHERE THE MARLINS UP TO GET
A BIG REINFORCEMENT WHEN THEY
BEGIN A THREE CITY TRIP IN
BOSTON.
STARLING MARTE BEGAN A REHAB
ASSIGNMENT WITH TRIPLE-A
JACKSONVILLE TUESDAY WHERE HE
PLAYED TWO GAMES.
AT THE TIME OF THE INJURY, HE
STARTED ALL 15 GAMES AT CENTER
AND MOVE TO THE TOP OF THE
LINEUP BECAUSE IT IS PRODUCTION.
IN HIS ABSENCE, THE MARLINS HAVE
GONE TO FOUR DIFFERENT CENTER
FIELDERS.
THEY EVEN TURNED TO ADAM DUVALL
WITH JUST ONE INNING OF
EXPERIENCE.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THE MARLINS
WILL WELCOME MARTE BACK.
BACK TO YOU.
SCOTT: PABLO LOPEZ LOVES THE
HOME COOKING AND HIS CHANGEUP.
HE IS ON THE MOUND FOR THE WORLD
TO SEE.
1-2 PITCH.
SWING AND A MISS.
STRUCK HIM OUT.
ZACK WHEELER PRETTY IMPRESSIVELY
STRIKES OUT THE SIDE.
1, 2, 3 GO THE MARLINS.
>> THAT BALL IS CRUSHED DEEP TO
RIGHT FIELD.
GOING BACK ON IT IS DUVALL.
OFF THE TOP OF THE WALL.
SIERRA IS THERE TO BACK IT UP
AND WHEELER IS INTO SECOND BASE
WITH HIS SECOND DOUBLE OF THE
YEAR.
>> A LITTLE TAPPER BACK TO THE
MOUND.
WHEELER HAS GOT IT, THROWS TO
FIRST.
>> WHEELER HAS ALREADY GOT A
STRIKEOUT.
A SWING AND A MISS.
98.
2-2.
BASE HIT FOR WHEELER.
WORKING THE COUNT WITH HIS
SECOND STRAIGHT AT THAT.
RUNNERS ON FIRST AND SECOND WITH
TWO MEN DOWN.
>> NOT ALL THAT DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT HIS NORMAL RATIOS ARE.
>> THERE IS THE SLIDER.
10 STRIKEOUTS FOR ZACK WHEELER.
SWING AND A MISS.
>> A LITTLE LONG.
>> THE CURVEBALL FOR THE 11TH
STRIKEOUT TODAY FOR ZACK
WHEELER.
SWING AND A MISS.
THAT MATCHES HIS CAREER-HIGH, 12
STRIKEOUTS FOR WHEELER.
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY "GLAD YOU ASKED.
TODAY, WE ARE AT LOANDEPOT PARK.
MARLINS HAVE TAKEN TWO OF THE
FIRST THREE.
THERE IT IS.
RUTH IS CLOSED FOR A FOURTH
CONSECUTIVE DAY.
I KNOW THE WINDOWS WERE OPEN
YESTERDAY.
SIX THE SEASON FOR DON MATTINGLY
RUNNING THE MIAMI MARLINS.
HE ACTUALLY GOES UP AGAINST JOE
GIRARDI, WHO RUNS THE PHILLIES.
GIRARDI IS THE ONE WHO ACTUALLY
TOOK THE YANKEES JOB BACK IN
2008.
SECOND PLACE FOR THAT JOB WAS
DON MATTINGLY.
THESE TWO HAVE MANY CONNECTIONS.
JOE WINNING A WORLD SERIES WITH
THE YANKEES.
WHILE THOSE MANAGERS IN A BIT.
JOE'S LINEUP CARD IS PRESENTED
BY "GLAD YOU ASKED."
HERE ARE THE PHILLIES
SWITCHHITTING ROMAN QUINN.
BRAD MILLER, FOURTH POSITION IN
FOUR DAYS.
RHYS HOSKINS HAVE A HUGE HOMER
THE OTHER DAY FOR THE PHILS AND
IS NOT A FIVE GAME HIT STREAK.
BACK IN THE LINEUP TODAY, MATT
GETS THE START.
RONALD TORREYES HAS HAD GOOD
NUMBERS AGAINST THE MARLINS.
RAFAEL MARCHAN WILL CATCH
SPENCER.
FIRST ON THE MOUND FOR THE
MARLINS IS THE GREAT PABLO
LOPEZ.
DAN: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
STICKS OUT, HE HAS A TREMENDOUS
CHANGEUP.
WE TALKED TO MANAGER DON
MATTINGLY AND HE LIKES THE USAGE
OF A CHANGEUP.
HE JUST IS NOT WANT HIM TO FALL
IN LOVE WITH IT.
A FINE E.R.A. OF 2.73.
MORE IMPORTANT I, YOU SEE THE
WALKS, THE STRIKEOUTS.
LESS HITS THAN WINNING PITCHED.
LOOK AT HOME E.R.A..
0.6 WHEN AT HOME.
HOME COOKING FITS PABLO JUST
FINE.
SCOTT: GETS ME THINKING ABOUT
TODAY'S ODDS COURTESY OF BETMGM.
6.5 IS THE LINE.
WHEN PABLO LOPEZ IS DOING WHAT
HE IS DOING AT HOME, I DON'T
KNOW.
MAYBE YOU ARE GOING UNDER THAT
MARK.
DAN: THIS IS A PRETTY BIG
SERIES.
MARLINS ARE IN SECOND PLACE,
TIED WITH THE BRAVES.
PHILLIES ARE ONLY TWO GAMES
BACK.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS MARLINS
TEAM, THEY MIGHT BE BETTER
SITUATED PITCHING WISE THAN ANY
OF THE OTHER TEAMS IN THE EAST.
THEY ARE HEALTHY, HOPING TO GET
SANCHEZ BACK BEFORE THE END OF
THE SEASON.
THEY SHOULD GET BETTER ON THE
MOUND ALSO.
SCOTT: LET'S PLAY BALL IN MIAMI.
PABLO LOPEZ STARTS ROMAN QUINN
WITH A STRIKE ON THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
SCOTT, DAN PLESAC, CLIFF FLOYD
AND CHRISTINA.
.
HE IS LIGHTNING FAST, CLIFF,
TOP THREE IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
IF YOU LOOK AT SPRINT SPEED,
USUALLY UP THERE.
CLIFF: JUST GETTING HIS
OPPORTUNITY IN TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF IT.
THAT IS WHAT IT BOILS DOWN TO
FOR THESE GUYS, ESPECIALLY A GUY
LIKE WIN, A GOOD TABLE SETTER
FOR THIS TEAM.
WHEN YOU'RE MISSING  START
PLAYERS, GUYS LIKE QYINN
HAVE TO GET ON BASE AND CAUSE
SOME HAVOC FOR THE BASE PATH.
SCOTT: QUINN WENT 2-3 YESTERDAY.
THE COUNT IS 2-2.
LET'S GET TO OUR PITCHER
BREAKDOWN PRESENTED BY "GLAD YOU
ASKED."
PABLO LOPEZ, WHAT IS THE ABOUT?
DAN: HE IS ALL ABOUT HIS.
TERRIFIC CHANGEUP
CHANGEUP IS THE KEY.
.
FASTBALL COMMAND.
.061 E.R.A.
HE LOVES PITCHING IN MIAMI.
SCOTT: HIS OVERALL E.R.A. KEEPS
GETTING BETTER.
HE HAS HIT 2.73 THIS SEASON.
THE NUMBERS KEEP IMPROVING.
HE KEEPS UPPING THE CHANGEUP
USAGE.
TWO EARNED RUNS OR FEWER IN 8 OF
10 STARTS THIS SEASON.
CLIFF: THIS IS A GREAT AT-BAT BY
QUINN.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU WANT IF
YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI AND THE
PHILLIES, A GUY GIVING YOU A
LOOK FOR EVERYBODY ELSE AND THE
REST OF THE LINEUP.
SCOTT: 3-2 ON ITS WAY HOME.
RIGHT SIDE.
FAIR BALL.
DIAZ THE TOSSING TO LOPEZ.
BEAT HIM BY MAYBE A STEP.
ROMAN QUINN NEVER THINKS HE'S
OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
SHOULD WE REVIEW THIS ONE?
CLIFF: YOU HAVE TO.
QUINN IS WALKING BACK, NOT TO
THE DUGOUT.
SCOTT: I DON'T WANT TO SAY HE
FELL ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL, BUT
MADE IT AWFUL CLOSE TO FIRST
BASE.
CLIFF: HE'S OUT.
SCOTT: LET'S GET A LOOK.
BREAK IT DOWN.
CLIFF: YOU SEE PABLO IS LATE TO
DANCE POINT.
THAT WAS REALLY CLOSE.
PABLO MADE UP FOR MAYBE A MENTAL
LASTS -- LAPSE BY GETTING OVER
THERE.
CLIFF: I DON'T KNOW.
I'M CHECKING THAT ONE IF I AM
JOE.
SCOTT: THEY DON'T AND IF QUINN
GOES TO CHECK HIMSELF, HE MIGHT
NOT BE PLEASED WITH THE RESULTS
ON THE REPLAY.
CLIFF: THAT WAS AN EASY LOOK.
THAT WAS OUR FIRST LOOK AT IT.
SCOTT: NOW, IT IS BRAD MILLER.
7 FOR HIS LAST 17.
CONNECTING, SHALLOW CENTER
FIELD.
SIERRA FOR OUT NUMBER TWO.
LET'S SHOW YOU THE MARLINS
DEFENSE.
SIERRA IS IN THE OUTFIELD
PLAYING CENTER, DUVALL ON ONE
SIDE.
DICKERSON ON THE OTHER.
SHORTSTOP MIGUEL ROJAS, RELAY
THE CAPTAIN OF THE TEAM PLAYING
ON THE LEFT SIDE WITH JON BERTI
IN THE INFIELD.
ISAN DIAZ AND LEWIN DIAZ ON THE
RIGHT SIDE.
LOPEZ PLAYING CATCH WITH SANDY
LEON.
RHYS HOSKINS ABOUT TO DIG IN.
DO YOU THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
CHALLENGED THAT CALL?
DAN: THAT WAS PRETTY CLOSE.
THAT WAS ABOUT AS BANGED AS IT
GETS.
THIS GUY RIGHT HERE, RHYS
HOSKINS -- WITH BRYCE HARPER OUT
OF THE LINEUP, MCCUTCHEN GETTING
THE DAY OFF, THIS IS A BIG BAT.
PHILLIES FELT PRETTY GOOD,
STARTING TO SWING THE BAT.
YOU SEE ON THE YEAR WITH 10 HOME
RUNS.
STARTING TO SPREAD THE BALL
AROUND A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
HE HAS A BIG PART OF WHERE THE
PHILLIES ARE GOING.
SCOTT: HE HAS CHANGED HIS GAME A
BIT.
LESS WALKS, LESS PASSIVE THIS
SEASON AND MORE AGGRESSIVE.
CLIFF: THAT IS A GOOD POINT
BECAUSE HE WAS BASICALLY A GUY
THAT HAD TO BE EXACTLY THE WAY
HE WANTED TO SWING THE BAT AND
THAT IS JUST NOT GOING TO GET IT
DONE.
HE IS TOO GOOD OF A HITTER TO BE
THAT PASSIVE.
YOU SEE THE NUMBERS RIGHT THERE,
THEY DON'T LIE AND WHEN HE IS
SWINGING THE BAT, HE HAS SUCH A
GOOD EYE.
HE HAS JUST A GOOD EYE AS FAR AS
KNOWING WHAT HE IS DOING WHEN HE
IS IN THE BOX AND HE HAS TO
EXPAND WHEN HE NEEDS TO.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE FOR A GUY LIKE
REESE.
DAN: HAD A BIG SWING AND THE BAT
ON TUESDAY.
VERY WELL PITCHED GAME BY VINCE
VELASQUEZ ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
THIS IS A BIG ONE FOR THE
FAMILIES.
THEY HAVE ALREADY LOST TWO OF
THE FIRST THREE OF THE SERIES.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO GET OUT OF
HERE WITH A SPLIT.
SCOTT: THAT HOME RUN ON TUESDAY
WAS OFF THE 1-2 PITCH.
I AM UP, PAUL SEVERINO.
100 MILES PER HOUR, I WILL CALL
IT FROM SANDY ALCANTARA.
410 FEET.
RHYS HOSKINS IS NOT AWAY SHOW A
TON OF EMOTION ON THE FIELD.
HE WAS FIRED UP.
TURNED TO THE DUGOUT AND SAID
LET'S GO, BOYS.
HE SWINGS THROUGH ON THE TO TWO.
PABLO LOPEZ AND THAT CHANGEUP.
TART
THE DAY FOR THE MAN WHO LOVES
PITCHING AT HOME.
>> SANDY GETS THE STRIKEOUT OF A
MCCUTCHEN.
1-2 ON HOSKINS.
SWING AND A MISS AND THAT WILL
DO IT.
A COUPLE OF STRIKEOUTS IN THE
INNING.
BEATS HIM WITH A FASTBALL UP.
. SANDY WITH THE STRIKEOUT
IT IS ACTUALLY ZACK WHEELER WHO
IS GOING TO TAKE THE AT-BAT
HERE.
SWING AND A MISS AND SANDY HAS
FIVE STRIKEOUTS THE FIRST TIME
THROUGH THE ORDER.
ANDREW MCCUTCHEN.
>> SWING AND A MISS.
HE RAN THAT ONE IN AND HE HAS
GOT ANOTHER CATCH.
>> SANDY READY TO DO IT AGAIN.
SWING AND A MISS DIALS UP 99.
THAT IS NINE FOR ALCANTARA.
>> SANDY ON HIS GAME.
CHANGEUP DOWN TO THE FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL LOOKING TO EXECUTE.
. PHILLIES OFF BALANCE
HOLDING THAT BELOW THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE START.
>> HOSKINS, A BROKEN BAT AND IT
IS LINED SOFTLY TO THE THIRD.
ANDERSON HAS GOT IT THROUGH SIX
INNINGS WITH A TWO HIT SHUTOUT.
SCOTT: A SCORELESS TOP OF THE
FIRST.
TIME TO INTRODUCE YOU TO DON
MATTINGLY'S STARTING LINEUP.
THE HOME TEAM, MIAMI MARLINS
WITH MAGNEURIS SIERRA LEADING
THE WAY.
LOOK AT THE POWER HE HAS HAD
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF LAST
SEASON.
LEWIN DIAZ IN THE LINEUP TODAY,
JUST CALLED UP THIS AFTERNOON.
SANDY LEON WILL CATCH.
ISAN DIAZ IS PLAYING SECOND
BASE.
JON BERTI WITH A BIG KNOCK FOR
THE MARLINS YESTERDAY IN THE
EIGHTH.
AND PABLO LOPEZ, THE PITCHER IN
THE NINE SPOT.
THE OPPOSING PITCHER ON
PHILADELPHIA, SPENCER HOWARD,
MAKING HIS SECOND START OF THE
SEASON.
COMING OFF AN INTERESTING, WEIRD
DAN: DAN: OUTING ON SATURDAY.
HIS VELO, STARTED OUT THE GAME
95 TO 97 MILES AN HOUR.
BIG, STRONG GUY.
45TH OVERALL PICK OF THE 2017
DRAFT OUT OF CAL POLY.
DID NOT EVEN HAVE A SCHOLARSHIP.
WALKED HIS WAY ONTO THE BASEBALL
TEAM AND A COUPLE OF YEARS
LATER, FOUND HIMSELF 45TH
OVERALL.
BELOW IS GOOD, GOOD BREAKING
BALL TO GO ALONG WITH IT.
LIKE A LOT OF YOUNG PITCHERS, I
DON'T WANT TO SAY RUSHED THROUGH
THE SYSTEM, BUT WITH THE COVID
SHORTEN SEASON LAST YEAR OF
2020, MADE HIS DEBUT AGAINST THE
BRAVES.
BIG TIME FASTBALL.
A LITTLE BIT OF CONCERN HE HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN OR
HOLD THAT VELO IN HIS LAST START
AGAINST THE RED SOX.
THIRD OR FOURTH INNING, THE TWO
OR THREE MILE AN HOUR DIP IN THE
VELO.
SCOTT: 1-1 TO SIERRA.
95.3 MILES AN HOUR IN HIS FIRST
TWO INNINGS IN THAT LAST START.
STATCAST 3D BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
A LOT OF FOUR-SEAM FASTBALLS.
IN THE THIRD INNING, WHICH WAS
EVENTUALLY HIS FINAL INNING,
92.9 MILES AN HOUR.
ACTUALLY REMOVED IN THE FOURTH,
BUT COULD NOT DO MUCH AGAINST
THE BOSTON LINEUP AFTER THE
FIRST COUPLE OF --
MICE CATCH.
CLIFF: SEE?
THAT IS WHAT YOU BRING YOUR
GLOVE TO THE GAME.
SCOTT: ALWAYS A BIG DEBATE ABOUT
THE AGE LIMIT FOR ALLOWING A
GLOVE IN THE BALLPARK.
DO YOU GUYS CARE ABOUT THAT?
CLIFF: ABSOLUTELY NOT.
DAN: IF YOU ARE GOING TO PAY AND
WATCH A BALLGAME, I WOULD RATHER
CATCH ONE WITH A GLOVE AND TAKE
ONE IN THE HAND AND POSSIBLY
BREAK MY HAND.
I KNOW IF A FOUL BALL IS COMING
MY WAY, I RATHER HAVE A GUY IN
FRONT OF ME WITH A GLOVE ON THEN
TRYING TO BAREHAND IT.
THAT IS AN OLD-SCHOOL GLOVE.
CLIFF: I THINK HE MADE THAT ONE
HIMSELF.
DAN: LOOK AT THAT GLOVE.
THAT GLOVE HAS SOME WEAR AND
TEAR ON IT.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: SWING AND A MISS, SPENCER
HOWARD PICKS UP A STRIKEOUT.
THAT GUY HAS GOT YOUR BACK.
CATCH PROBABILITY ABOUT 12% ON
THAT SNAG.
DAN: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
SPENCER HOWARD.
6'3", 205 POUNDS.
HE IS A GUY THAT COMES OUT GUNS
BLAZING.
FIRST PITCHES STRIKES ARE THE
KEY TO KEEP THE PITCH COUNT DOWN
AND BE MINDFUL OF BASE RUNNERS.
A LOT OF YOUNG PITCHERS, SOME
SPEED IN THIS MARLINS LINEUP.
PAY ATTENTION TO THE MARLINS
WHEN THEY GET ON BASE.
SCOTT: YOUR PITCHER BREAKDOWN
PRESENTED BY "GLAD YOU ASKED.
HE STARTED OFF ON FIRE AGAINST A
REALLY GOOD RED SOX LINEUP.
STRUCK OUT FOUR OF THE FIRST SIX
BATTERS FACED.
HERE IS MIGUEL ROJAS, OVER 400
AGAINST THE PHILLIES A SINCE THE
START OF LAST YEAR.
BIG HOME RUN ROAD SPLITS.
329 AT HOME.
225 ON THE ROAD.
CLIFF: SO VALUABLE FOR THIS
MARLINS TEAM.
I THINK WHEN THEY HAD JAZZ
CHISHOLM GO DOWN, HE GOT
INSERTED TO LEADOFF SPOT AND
KEPT GOING.
HE IS SUCH A GOOD HITTER AS FAR
AS GOING -- UNDERSTANDING THE
STRIKE ZONE.
HE HAS GOTTEN BETTER EACH YEAR.
SCOTT: CAN THEY NAME HIM
CAPTAIN?
I KNOW THERE IS NOT AN OFFICIAL
TITLE, BUT I FEEL LIKE WITH
DEREK JETER AS THE CEO OF THE
TEAM, IT WOULD JUST BE FITTING.
MIGGY RO HAS HAS BEEN THERE FOR
A WHILE.
HE IS THE GUY.
CLIFF: THEY CAN.
YOU WONDER HOW THEY GO ABOUT
THAT, BUT HE IS THE GUY.
HE COMES TO THE PARK READY TO
WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY.
ALL THE GUYS LOVE HIM.
HE KEEPS EVERYBODY'S HEAD UP.
HE IS ONE OF THE REASONS THEY
ARE FINALLY PLAYING BETTER
BASEBALL.
THE MARLINS ARE HERE FOR A LONG
TIME AND HE IS A BIG PART OF
THAT.
SCOTT: GOING TO BE A TOUGH PLAY
AT SHORT AND THE THROW WAS ON
TIME.
RONALD TORREYES WITH A THROW ON
THE RUN FOR THE OUT.
DAN: YOU CAN SEE WHY RIGHT THERE
WHY THE PHILLIES REALLY LIKE
SPENCER HOWARD.
THAT IS A GOOD FASTBALL TO A GUY
THAT CAN TURN ON THE HEATER
PRETTY GOOD.
THIS BALL EATS HIM UP HERE.
MICE PLAY BY RHYS HOSKINS.
YOU SEE THERIOT INTO THE WHOLE
-- YOU SEE TORRE AS GOES INTO
THE HOLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE PHILLIES
NEEDS TO DO IS TECHNIQUE THE
DEFENSE.
EIGHTH INNING LAST NIGHT, A
DOUBLE PLAY THAT WAS TURNED.
LED TO WHAT STARTED TO BE A
BEGINNING, A PASSED BALL ALSO
HURT.
PUTTING A LOT OF PRESSURE ON A
BULLPEN THAT STRUGGLED A LITTLE
BIT AT TIMES.
THEY NEED TO GO BETTER JOB
CATCHING THE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: BRING TO LAST IN BASEBALL
AND DEFENSIVE RUNS SAVED.
DAN: AND IT IS NOT A LOT OF
EFFORT.
WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO JOE
GIRARDI BEFORE THE GAME.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING AT IT,
TAKING GROUND BALLS, TURNING
DOUBLE PLAYS.
IT IS JUST A MATTER OF PUTTING
IT ALL TOGETHER.
SCOTT: UPSTAIRS TO COREY
DICKERSON.
DAN: WHEN YOU WATCH HOWARD, HE
REMIND ME A LOT OF A FORMER
PHILLY PITCHER, JERAD EICKHOFF.
THE SAME KIND OF BODY BILLS.
JERAD EICKHOFF, UNFORTUNATELY,
JUST SO MANY INJURIES, LIMITED
HIS TIME WITH THE PHILADELPHIA
PHILLIES.
SIMILAR STYLE, SIMILAR BUILD.
SCOTT: DICKERSON CONNECTS DEEP
CENTER AND CAUGHT BY CABRERA WHO
MADE A SICK PLAY YESTERDAY.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
ONE SCORELESS INNING ON THE
OTHER SIDE IN MIAMI.
>> ONE AT THE TOP, ONE AT THE
BOTTOM.
DICKERSON TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
NOT GOING TO GET THERE.
ONE RUNNER WILL SCORE EASILY AND
HE IS IN THERE WITH A TWO R.B.I.
TRIPLE.
MARLINS TAKE A 4-2 LEAD.
.
>> DOUBLED IN THE THIRD, DROVE
IN RUN NUMBER TWO.
NOW, MARLINS AT FIRST AND
SECOND.
>> THERE IS A BASE HIT FOR AGG
IE.
>> AGUILAR HAS HIMSELF ANOTHER
R.B.I..
5-2, MARLINS HERE IN THE SEVENTH
IN --.
>> ADAM DUVALL WITH A BLAST.
GOODBYE.
THREE RUN HOMER.
ADAM DUVALL,8-2 MARLINS.
COOPER, LEFT FIELD.
DOES IT HAVE THE LEGS?
IT IS OFF THE BOTTOM OF THE
WALL.
SIERRA IS GOING TO SCORE AND
COOPER CRUISES IN TO SECOND.
THAT IS FIVE IN THE NINE-GAME
HIS -- HIT STREAK.
>> THE PHILLIES ARE ONE
BASERUNNER AWAY FROM BRINGING
THE TYING RUN TO THE PLATE.
>> GROUND BALL.
THAT IS JAZZ, LONG, STRONG
THROW, GOT HIM.
IT IS A MARLINS WIN!
SCOTT: WE ARE INTO THE SECOND IN
SOUTH FLORIDA.
LET'S GO BACK TO MAY 23.
ZACK WHEELER DEALING.
FASTBALL UP IN THE ZONE.
LOVES IT.
CHANGE HIS APPROACH A LITTLE BIT
WITH PHILADELPHIA.
IT IS WORKING FOR HIM.
COMES OVER FROM THE NEW YORK
METS A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, BIG
SIGNING BY THE PHILLIES.
ANGERED TOWARD THE TOP OF THE
ROTATION AND ANCHORED IN THE
DUGOUT, CHATTING WITH US FOR
THIS HAPPENING.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON BOARD, HOW
ARE YOU TODAY?
ZACH: I'M DOING WELL, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
SCOTT: GREAT SEASON.
78 STRIKEOUTS.
HERRERA, ALEC BOHM AND MAC --
MATT JOYCE COMING UP FOR THE
PHILLIES.
ALSO, YOUTUBE CREATORS, YOU KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR ZACK,
WE WILL RELAY SOME OF THEM IF WE
HAVE TIME.
CABRERA BOUNCES OUT.
SCOTT: I WILL GET TO MY FIRST
QUESTION.
HOW IS THIS SEASON GOING FOR YOU
ON A PERSONAL STANDPOINT?
HOW DO YOU EVALUATE WHAT YOU DO
AND HOW GOOD IS THAT HOW NICE IS
IT TO BE PITCHING IN FRONT OF
MANY MORE HUMAN BEINGS?
ZACH: IT IS GOING WELL FOR ME SO
FAR THIS YEAR.
USUALLY, I GET OFF TO A SLOW
START AND USUALLY TURN ON THE
SECOND HALF ARE SOME REASON.
THIS YEAR, DOING WELL SO FAR.
JUST GETTING AHEAD OF GUYS AND
JUST ATTACKING THE ZONE.
DAN: WAS THERE ANY CONCERN
COMING OFF OF A 60 GAME SPRINT
THAT YOU GUYS HAD LAST YEAR, DID
YOU HAVE TO ALTER YOUR WORKOUTS
OR YOU'RE THROWING PROGRAM
BEFORE THIS SEASON STARTED?
ZACH: NO, NOT NECESSARILY.
I JUST HANDLED IT LIKE A NORMAL
OFF-SEASON.
LIKE YOU SAID, WE ONLY THREW 11
STARTS LAST YEAR.
I HAVE DONE THAT PLENTY OF TIMES
IN THE PAST.
EVEN IN THE MINOR LEAGUES, YOU
ONLY THREW A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
FITTINGS.
I THINK WE ARE USED TO IT MORE
THAN PEOPLE. ACTUALLY THINK
THIS YEAR, HOPEFULLY, WE CAN
STAY HEALTHY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF INJURIES
BECAUSE OF THE SHORT SEASON.
I THINK SO FAR, SO GOOD FOR ME.
CLIFF: YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT A
LOT OF INJURIES, UNFORTUNATELY,
BUT FOR YOU, IS THERE A LITTLE
BIT MORE PRESSURE FOR YOU TO BE
THE GUY THAT MAKES SURE, IF YOU
HAVE A LOSING STREAK, YOU CAN
STOP THAT WITH YOUR OUTING?
ZACH: DEFINITELY.
PLAYING WITH THOSE GUYS IN NEW
YORK WAS AN AWESOME STAFF.
YOU ARE OUT THERE TRYING TO BEAT
THOSE GUYS EVERY OUTING.
I HAVE CARRIED THAT HERE WITH
ME.
YOU HAVE NOLS AND EFLIN,
SPENCER.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD ARMS HERE.
FRIENDLY COMPETITION.
THE OTHER DAY, WE LOST FOUR
GAMES IN A ROW.
I WAS NOT GOING TO LET THE RED
SOX BEAT ME.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THAT MINDSET
GOING IN.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THE MINDSET
GOING AND YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THE STOPPER.
SCOTT: HIT BALL A STRIKE TO MATT
JOYCE.
I WILL GET ONE QUESTION IN FROM
OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS.
WHAT IS IT LIKE BEING DIVISION
RIVALS AGAINST A PART OF SO MANY
YEARS IN THE METS?
THIS ONE DRIVEN DEEP RIGHT.
OF IS THERE.
ZACK: IT IS FUN PLAYING AGAINST
THOSE GUYS.
I MET A LOT OF FRIENDS OVER
THERE IN MY TIME.
IT IS FUN PITCHING AGAINST THOSE
GUYS.
SCOTT: I WISH WE HAD MORE TIME.
WE ENJOYED IT.
QUICK ONE SO FAR.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
ZACK:IGHT, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
SCOTT: AGAIN, A 1, 2, 3 FRAME
FOR THE PHILLIES.
BACK TO THE MARLINS.
>> RHYS HOSKINS COMING UP.
FILLS AND MARLINS SCORELESS.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
IT IS GONE.
RHYS HOSKINS HITS A BULLET OUT
TO LEFT.
IT IS HIS 10TH HOME RUN OF THE
SEASON AND THE PHILLIES ARE ON
THE BOARD.
>> SIX SCORELESS INNINGS,
OUTSTANDING WORK BY VINCE
VELASQUEZ.
>> 23 INNINGS, THREE EARNED RUNS
IN HIS LAST FOUR PARTS.
>> COMING TONIGHT, HE WAS
SHUSHING THE CROWD.
>> ABSOLUTELY DOMINANT SINCE
THAT HOME RUN.
HE WAS REALLY SUPERB.
>> THEY MAKE ONE MISTAKE AND AT
THE MOMENT HE IS ON THE HOOK FOR
THE LOSS.
>> PICKS IT UP.
UNDERHANDS FOR THE OUT.
NICE WORK, SANDY ALCANTARA.
THREW EIGHT INNINGS.
>> COREY DICKERSON IS COMING UP.
HE POPS IT UP.
HOW TO CENTER FIELD.
ODUBEL SAYS HE HAS THAT.
HE MAKES THE CATCH AND THE
BALLGAME IS OVER AND THE
PHILLIES HANG ON AND WIN BY A
FINAL SCORE OF 2-0.
SCOTT: AND INNING AND A HALF OF
CLEAN BASEBALL SO FAR IN MIAMI.
TIME FOR OUR FIRST POLL
QUESTION.
YOU SEE THIS, YOUR FAVORITE
PHILLY PHANATIC MOMENT.
WE WILL SHOW YOU SOME OPTIONS.
IF YOU WANT TO WAIT FOR YOUR
VOTE, COOL.
DAN: I ALREADY HAVE MINE.
IT IS THE TOMMY LASORDA STRIKES
BACK.
[LAUGHTER]
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CAME TO
VETERAN STADIUM.
YOU WERE PREPARED FOR THE
FANATIC TO LAY IT ON YOU AND HE
LAID IT ON TOMMY LASORDA.
SCOTT: HE DID, WE HAVE VIDEO.
IT IS COMING SOON.
WE ARE IN THE LAST OF THE
SECOND.
ADAM DUVALL TAKES A STRIKE ON
THE OUTSIDE CORNER.
SCOTT BRAUN, DAN PLESAC, CLIFF
FLOYD.
DID YOU GET TO SEE THE OPTIONS?
CLIFF: I'M FOLLOWING DAN.
THAT IS THE BEST ONE OF ALL FOUR
OF THOSE.
SCOTT: I THINK SO.
WE WILL HAVE TO SHOW THAT ONE
FIRST.
YOU GUYS ARE HEAVILY INFLUENCING
THE AUDIENCE.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT WILL BE
THE CASE.
DUVALL STRIKES AT LEFT CENTER.
DEEP, WARNING TRACK, AND OFF THE
WALL.
IT IS PLAYED BY QUIN AND HE WILL
TRUCK INTO SECOND BASE WITH A
STANDUP DOUBLE.
DAN: LOOKED LIKE A FIRST PITCH
BREAKING BALL FROM SPENCER
HOWARD.
DUVALL KNOWN FOR HUNTING A
FASTBALL.
I THINK THE IDEA WAS RIGHT, THIS
ONE JUST SPUN OVER THE INNER
THIRD.
THIS BALL INTENDED TO BE DOWN
AND AWAY.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE FRONT DOOR UP
AND IN KIND OF SPEED UP THE BAT
SPEED OF THE BALL.
CLIFF: YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
LINEUP.
THEY HAVE SOME YOUTH BUT THEY
HAVE SOME VETERAN PLAYERS AND
PRESENCE FROM A GUY LIKE ADAM
DUVALL.
JESUS AGUILAR, WHO IS NOT IN THE
LINEUP.
THIS IS WHAT DEVOL HAS BEEN
DOING THIS SEASON.
-- DUVALL HAS BEEN DOING FOR
THIS -- DOING THIS SEASON.
SCOTT: THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
HOME RUN IN 13 MLB BALLPARKS.
ALMOST HAD IT.
CLIFF: AND THEY MOVED TO THE
FENCES IN.
SCOTT: THAT'S RIGHT.
MOVED TO THEM IN ABOUT 12 FEET
IN CENTER AND RIGHT CENTER.
CLIFF: SO IT NEVER AFFECTED LEFT
CENTER.
SCOTT: NOPE.
DIAZ FOULS IT BACK.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DID NOT MOVE
IT IN 12 FEET FOR DEVOL IN HIS
FAVORITE SPOT -- DUVALL IN HIS
FAVORITE SPOT.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN: THAT LAST SWING IS
INDICATIVE OF THE WAY BASEBALL
IS PLAYED IN 2021.
YOU WOULD NORMALLY THINK WITH
YOUR FIVE WHOLE HITTER YOU WOULD
TRY TO HIT SOMETHING ON THE
RIGHT SIDE TO GET DUVALL OVER TO
THIRD BASE.
ALL BETS OFF, YOU'RE KIND OF AN
DEFENSE MODE AT THE 0-2 COUNT.
THEY GET THEM ON, GET THEM IN
BASEBALL IS KIND OF GOING OUT
THE WINDOW.
SCOTT: I FOUND THAT CLIP FOR
YOU, DAN.
DAN: THIS IS CLASSIC PHILLY
PHANATIC, TOMMY LASORDA.
1988.
TOMMY TOOK EXCEPTION TO THIS.
HERE HE COMES.
HE IS GOING AFTER HIM.
LOOK AT TOMMY.
[LAUGHTER]
THEN HE HITS HIM WITH IT.
SCOTT: CAN WE GET AN OPPOSING
MANAGER TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IN BILLY?
-- PHILLY?
THAT WOULD BE NICE.
SECOND K OF THE DAY AS HE PAINTS
THE BOTTOM OF THE ZONE.
DAN:, MUST'VE WOKE UP ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE BED THAT
MORNING.
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF: YES, HE DID.
THAT IS A GREAT PITCH RIGHT
THERE BY SPENCER HOWARD.
A BAD AT BAT BY DIAZ.
YOU ALLUDED TO IT, THAT IS NOT
GOING TO GET IT DONE.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAY AND PLAY
CONSISTENTLY, YOU HAVE TO GET
THAT GUY TO THIRD BASE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WINNING GAMES.
1.5 GAMES OUT OF FIRST PLACE.
DAN: THE MARLINS ARE NOT GOING
TO HIT A LOT OF HOME RUNS.
THEY PLAY IN A LOT OF ONE RUN
GAMES, LOW-SCORING GAMES.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO THUMP A
LOT.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE.
LEADOFF DOUBLE.
GET THE GUY OVER TO THIRD.
THERE IS A GUY THAT CAN HANDLE
THE BAT, DON MATTINGLY.
IT IS AMAZING HE IS NOT IN THE
HALL OF FAME.
ONE OF THE GREAT HITTERS IN THE
1980'S.
SCOTT: 1985A.L M.V.P., SIX-TIME
ALL-STAR.
DAN: EIGHT HOME RUNS IN EIGHT
CONSECUTIVE GAMES IN 1988.
GOLD GLOVER AT FIRST BASE.
SCOTT: SANDY LEON, DEEP LEFT.
WHEN AT THE TRACK -- QUINM AT
THE TRACK.
TAGGING UP AS DEVOL.
-- DUVALL.
DAN: DONNIE BASEBALL COULD DO IT
ALL.
WHAT A HANDLER OF THE BAT.
HE DID NOT STRIKE OUT A LOT.
HE WAS AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
MASHER.
PRETTY GOOD MANAGERIAL CAREER,
TOO.
CLIFF: AWESOME, MAN.
HE COULD HANDLE THAT GLOVE.
DAN: COULD HE EVER. DONNIE
BASEBALL.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE GOOD WHEN YOU
ARE TEDDY BALLGAME, DONNIE
BASEBALL.
CLIFF: ALL THESE DIFFERENT TYPE
NICKNAMES.
SCOTT: 18 AT-BATS AGAINST YOU,
DAN.
DAN: PRIDE AND JOY OF
EVANSVILLE, INDIANA.
HE AND I BOTH FROM THE HOOSIER
STATE.
SCOTT: BREAKING BALL JUST
MISSES.
DUVALL, 90 FEET AWAY FROM A
SCORING CHANCE.
CLIFF: YOU CAN'T THROW OUT
AT-BATS AND NOT GIVE THE
AVERAGE.
SCOTT: I WAS WAITING FOR DAN TO
ASK ME.
DAN: I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO SAY
THERE WAS A HOME RUN IN THEIR.
SCOTT: HE DID HAVE A WALKOFF
HOMER.
DAN: SHORT PORCH AT THE OLD
YANKEE STADIUM.
SCOTT: YOU DON'T FORGET THOSE,
DO YOU?
DAN: NEVER.
SCOTT: 6-18.
CLIFF: HE WAS REALLY GOOD
BECAUSE DAN, EVERY TIME I THINK
ABOUT LEFTY RELIEVERS, I'M LIKE,
NEVER WANT TO FACE HIM.
NEVER WANTED TO FACE HIM.
6-18.
DAN: I HAVE DREAMS OF ABOUT
THREE OR FOUR HOME RUNS.
CESSA FIELDER HIT ONE OFF ME.
CLIFF FLOYD TOOK ME STRAIGHTAWAY
CENTER FIELD IN SHEA STADIUM.
CLIFF, I KNOW YOU REMEMBER WELL.
IT WAS COLD, IT WAS DAMP.
I'M LIKE, I WILL SEE HOW FAR YOU
CAN HIT IT.
THAT PLAN DID NOT WORK.
[LAUGHTER]
BUGGY WHIPPED ME.
THAT BOMB WAS ALLOWED WHEN IT
SHOULD HAVE COUNTED FOR LIKE
FOUR OF THEM.
THERE ARE SOME NIGHTS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE PLAYING
IN THE OPEN-AIR STADIUMS, WHERE
IT IS COLD AND IT IS DAMP AND IT
IS EARLY IN THE YEAR.
SHEA STADIUM WAS A GOOD
BALLPARK, A PITCHERS BALLPARK.
THE LAST THING YOU ARE THINKING
IS SOMEBODY TO TAKE YOU DEEP.
CLIFF BUCK TO THAT MYTH.
CLIFF: GOT LUCKY.
SCOTT: 3-1 TO DIAZ.
DEVOL STARTED WITH A DOUBLE
--DUVALL STARTED WITH A DOUBLE.
NOW FILLS UP THE COUNT.
DAN: REALLY GUTSY PITCH.
THAT IS WHAT SPENCER HOWARD WILL
HAVE TO DO TO HANG AROUND AT THE
BIG-LEAGUE LEVEL.
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD PITCH.
THIS IS A GUY A PITCH TO OR
THREE YEARS INTO THE BIG LEAGUES
HAS TO MASTER.
NOW YOU CAN JUST ABOUT DO
ANYTHING YOU WANT.
YOU HAVE SHOWN THE CHANGEUP TO
THROW -- SLOW HIM DOWN.
YOU CAN SHOW ANYTHING IN YOUR
ARSENAL.
SCOTT: JUST MISSED.
WE CAN SHOW THAT AND SEE WHAT
THE BOX SAYS.
DAN: THIS IS A REALLY GOOD PITCH
3-2.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A HAIR DOWN IN
THE STRIKE ZONE.
YOU CAN SEE THE GRIP, THE CIRCLE
CHANGEUP GRIP.
WELL LOCATED.
DIAZ THINKING IT IS A FASTBALL
IN.
CLIFF: FOR ME, I'M LOOKING AT
THAT FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
CATCHER FRAMING AND HOW MUCH HE
PULLED THAT BALL UP.
I THINK WHEN YOU ARE FRAMING THE
BASEBALL, I'M NOT SAYING HE
SHOULDN'T DO IT, BUT YOU ARE
FRAMING TOO MUCH, IT GIVES AWAY
A GREAT PITCH LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: JON BERTI CONNECTS THE
OTHER WAY.
JOYCE HUSTLING TOWARD THE LINE
AND HE MAKES THE CATCH IN STRIDE
TO RETIRE THE SIDE.
LEAVE TWO ON.
TREVOR ROGERS WILL JOIN US IN
THE NEXT HALF INNING.
YOUTUBE CREATORS, BRING ON THOSE
QUESTIONS.
>> I BALL, TWO STRIKES.
REACHES OUT.
TAGGING.
COMING HOME WAS SEGURA.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE IS CUT
OFF.
THE PHILLIES TAKE THE LEAD.
CENTER FIELD, WELL HIT.
HERRERA IS GOING BACK AND HE IS
THERE.
HE PULLED IT RIGHT OFF THE TOP
OF THE FENCE.
WHAT A PLAY.
ODUBEL HERRERA ROBBED DIAZ OF A
HOME RUN.
>> BASE HIT SHOULD SCORE TWO.
>> ONE RUN IS IN.
HERE COMES THE SECOND.
JON BERTI COMES THROUGH.
>> WOULD NOT MIND AN EXTRA RUN.
>> MIGHT GET IT RIGHT HERE.
>> JON BERTI AROUND THIRD.
HE WILL SCORE.
DEVERS HAS AN R.B.I.
IT IS A 4-2 MARLINS LEAD.
SOME INSURANCE FOR THE MARLINS.
RIGHT BACK TO GARCIA.
THE BOBBLES, GATHERS, THROWS TO
FIRST, FINISHES THAT OFF.
IT IS A MARLINS WIN.
WHAT A COMEBACK WIN FOR THE
MARLINS.
>> OH NO.
YOU DID SAY YOU WANTED POPCORN
BEFORE, DIDN'T YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> HE'S DRUNK.
HE'S GOT TO BE DRUNK.
JUST DESTROYING OUR BOOTH.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
[LAUGHTER]
OH MY GOODNESS.
>> WHY DO PEOPLE LIKE YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: TOM MCCARTHY AND JOHN
KRUK.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO OUR BOOTH?
[LAUGHTER]
THE POPCORN DELIVERY IS AN
OPTION.
WE SHOWED YOU TOMMY LASORDA,
THAT STILL GETS INSANE NUMBERS
ON THE YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
JOINING US RIGHT NOW LIVE ON A
GLOBAL STAGE ARE GLAD YOU ASKED
INTERVIEW, TREVOR ROGERS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE PHILLY
PHANATIC?
DO YOU HAVE A FAVORITE MOMENT OR
A FAVORITE MASCOT?
TREVOR: DEFINITELY, THE PHILLY
PHANATIC IS UP THERE.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT HE IS GOING
TO DO.
ALWAYS KEEPS IT LIGHT AND FUN
AND DEFINITELY GIVES THE
OPPOSING TEAM A LITTLE GRIEF,
THAT'S FOR SURE.
SCOTT: THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US FOR THIS HAPPENING.
OFF TO A SUPERB START TO YOUR
SEASON AND ALSO MOST IMPORTANTLY
I WATCHED YOU LAST TIME OUT.
THERE IS THE TOWEL.
YOU SMASH THE BALL THAT RHYS
HOSKINS COULD NOT BRING DOWN.
IN NICE PLAY AT THIRD BY JON
BERTI.
THROWS ACROSS FOR THE OUT.
ONE AWAY.
LET'S START WITH YOUR BAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
FROM THE OTHER DAY?
COULD NOT BRING THE BALL DOWN
WAS HOSKINS.
THEY GAVE YOU THE KNOCK, RIGHT?
TREVOR: AT LEAST I HOPE THEY
GAVE ME THE KNOCK.
I GOT THE BARREL OUT THERE.
SCOTT: YOU SMOKED IT.
LOOK AT JON BERTI MAKE A SWEET
PLAY.
CLIFF: THEY DON'T COME EASY.
TREVOR: I NEED A FEW MORE.
[LAUGHTER]
I NEED TO PAD THE STATS.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
DAN: WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
DIFFERENTLY IN 2021 AS OPPOSED
TO LAST YEAR?
TREVOR: IT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
PROBABLY MY CHANGEUP.
DEFINITELY DEVELOPING THE
CHANGEUP.
LEFTY ON LEFTY AND TO RIGHTIES,
AS WELL.
THE CHANGEUP HAS BEEN HUGE FOR
ME.
DEVELOPING THE SLIDER.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO THROW IT BACK
DOOR AND THEN TO THE BACK FOOT.
DEVELOPING THAT BACKDOOR PITCH
HAS BEEN HUGE FOR ME.
CLIFF: CLIFF HERE.
WITHOUT MESSING WITH JESUS
SITTING RIGHT THERE TO YOUR
LEFT, HOW BIG HAS HE BEEN FOR
THAT CLUBHOUSE?
AS FAR AS THE YOUNG CLUBHOUSE,
HOW BIG HAS HE BEEN?
I KNOW HE IS MESSING WITH YOU.
TREVOR: YEAH, HE HAS BEEN HUGE.
HE HAS BEEN AWESOME.
ESPECIALLY TO THESE YOUNG GUYS
AND JUST TO SEE HOW HE GOES
ABOUT HIS BUSINESS EVERY DAY, IT
IS DEFINITELY A GOOD GUY TO LOOK
UP TO, GOOD GUY TO FOLLOW.
I'M GLAD TO HAVE HIM ON OUR
BALLCLUB, THAT'S FOR SURE.
SCOTT: WE DO THE YOUTUBE PLAYER
OF THE GAME TROPHY, BUT YOU ARE
GETTING ALL KINDS OF GOODIES
RIGHT NOW FOR DOING THIS
INTERVIEW.
[LAUGHTER]
TREVOR: I HAVE TEAMMATES HAVEN'T
GIVEN ME THIS MUCH ATTENTION AND
FOREVER.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
I'M SURPRISED THEY EVEN KNOW MY
NAME.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M ALL FOR.
GETTING CANDY, GETTING DRINKS.
I'M LOVING IT RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: THIS IS ROOM SERVICE,
DUGOUT SERVICE WITH TREVOR
ROGERS.
[LAUGHTER]
ROUGHLY ON MARCHAND IS ON FIRST.
TEREUS WAS DROPPED BY JON BERTI.
NOW SPENCER HOWARD.
I'VE GOT ONE FROM OUR YOUTUBE
CREATORS.
AS A LIFELONG PITCHER, HOW DO
YOU FEEL ABOUT PITCHER SITTING
AND HOW DO YOU PREPARE TO TAKE
IT BATS?
TREVOR: I MEAN I JUST TRY TO GET
THE JOB DONE.
EVERYONE IN THE STADIUM PROBABLY
KNOWS I'M GOING TO BUNT 95% OF
THE TIME, SO IF I CAN GET IT
DOWN AND GET THE GUYS OVER AND
GET MY GUYS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SCORE SOME RUNS, THEN I WILL DO
MY JOB.
I DON'T EXPECT ANYTHING LESS OR
ANYTHING MORE, TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
DAN: WERE YOU A GOOD HITTER IN
HIGH SCHOOL?
TREVOR: I COULD HANDLE A LITTLE
BIT OF BACK IN HIGH SCHOOL.
-- BAT IN HIGH SCHOOL.
IN NEW MEXICO, WE USED WOOD BATS
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I WAS USUALLY THREE OR FOUR
HOLE, SO I HAD A LITTLE JUICE IN
THE SWING. NOT THE PRETTIEST
LOOKING SWING, BUT IT GOT THE
JOB DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: DOES NEW MEXICO GET
ENOUGH LOVE AS A STATE FOR
BASEBALL?
YOUR COUSIN'S FORMER MARLIN CODY
ROSS, RIGHT?
TREVOR: RIGHT.
WE ARE KIND OF REALLY LOW-KEY.
NOT REALLY KNOWN FOR BASEBALL.
BUT DEFINITELY UP IN THE
ALBUQUERQUE AREA THERE ARE SOME
REALLY GOOD TEAMS.
LA CUEVA AND EL DORADO.
WE'VE GOT SOME GOOD COMPETITION
IN NEW MEXICO.
SCOTT: YOU ARE HELPING THE STATE
MAKE MORE OF A NAME FOR ITSELF.
MOST STRIKEOUTS BY A LEFTY IN
FIRST 17 CAREER STARTS.
LOOK AT THESE NAMES.
DAN: WHENEVER YOU ARE ON A LIST
WITH FERNANDO VALENZUELA, YOU
ARE DOING SOMETHING.
HOW ABOUT LIRIANO AND RON
GUIDRY?
TREVOR ROGERS IN SOME ELITE
COMPANY.
CLIFF: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS,
THE ROSTER AND ROTATION, SO
YOUNG -- WHERE DO YOU GO WHEN
YOU NEED TO FIND YOURSELF?
YOU HAVEN'T HAD TO, YOU HAVE
BEEN OUTSTANDING.
IF YOU WANT TO SEEK HELP ON THIS
TEAM, EVERYBODY IS SO YOUNG.
WHERE DO YOU GO?
TREVOR: ABSOLUTELY.
I ALWAYS GO TO OUR PITCHING
COACH.
HE HAS BEEN DOING IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
REALLY KNOWLEDGEABLE.
I PICK HIS BRAIN EVERY
OPPORTUNITY I GET.
WE ARE STILL YOUNG, BUT SANDY
AND PABLO, THEY HAVE BEEN UP
HERE IT COUPLE YEARS, SO I TRY
TO PICK THEIR BRAINS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL UP
HERE.
THEN WE'VE GOT SOME REALLY
EXPERIENCED BULLPEN GUYS.
PRETTY MUCH ABOUT SIDES, BULLPEN
AND STARTERS, I TRY TO PICK
THEIR BRAINS TO SEE WHAT GIVES
THEM SUCCESS.
SCOTT: THAT IS A FOUL BALL OFF
THE BAT.
LEADOFF HITTER FOR PHILADELPHIA.
TREVOR ROGERS WITH US RIGHT NOW
ON YOUTUBE.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE FACING A TEAM
IN BACK-TO-BACK STARTS COMING
OFF YOUR LAST ONE?
TREVOR: IT IS ALWAYS A LITTLE
TOUGHER.
IT DEFINITELY GIVES A LITTLE BIT
MORE ADVANTAGE TO THE HITTER.
I DEFINITELY KNOW I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO MIX MY PATTERNS A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
I CAN'T GIVE THEM THE SAME MIX
MORE THAN ONCE.
BUT IT IS ALWAYS A FUN
CHALLENGE.
I ENJOY THE COMPETITION.
I'VE JUST GOT TO BEAR DOWN EVEN
MORE AND MAKE PITCHES WHEN I
NEED TO.
SCOTT: WHO IS YOUR INSPIRATION?
IT COULD BE SOMEONE IN THE PAST
OR SOMEONE CURRENTLY THAT YOU
REALLY WATCH, THAT YOU ARE
ROLLING BACK CLIPS TO SEE WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
TREVOR: YEAH, ALL-TIME FAVORITE
IS THE BIG UNIT, RANDY JOHNSON.
THAT IS MY GUY.
I ALWAYS WATCH CLIPS FROM HIM.
I CAUGHT HIM AT THE BACK END OF
HIS CAREER, WHEN HE WAS ON THE
MARINERS EARLY IN HIS CAREER,
JUST 102 FROM THREE-QUARTER
MAYBE EVEN A LITTLE LOWER.
IT WAS AMAZING TO WATCH AND I
CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF WATCHING HIS
STUFF AND HOW HE WENT ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS.
SCOTT: APPARENTLY, RANDY JOHNSON
CAME OUT TO WATCH YOU WHEN YOU
WERE PITCHING IN ARIZONA.
WE ARE SHOWING YOUR LAST START
MONDAY AGAINST THE PHILLIES,
GETTING THE JOB DONE.
FIVE INNINGS, ONE EARNED RUN,
THREE HITS.
COMING OFF A CAREER-HIGH 7.1.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME.
PABLO LOPEZ DID GOOD WORK IN THE
THIRD.
THANKS AND GOOD LUCK THE REST OF
THE WAY.
TREVOR: THANKS, GUYS.
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING ME.
SCOTT: ROGERS.
THE GREAT MARLINS STARTING STAFF
SHOWING ITSELF OFF AGAIN THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> HIT SHARPLY TOWARD THE HOLE.
DIVING STOP.
THROWS TO FIRST.
IN TIME.
EXCELLENT PLAY.
>> WOW.
>> WHAT A PLAY BY RHYS HOSKINS.
>> LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST TAG.
RHYS HOSKINS ROBBED HIM OF IT.
>> SWING AND A GROUNDBALL.
DEEP SHORT.
POPS UP.
LONG THROW TO FIRST.
HOSKINS DIGS IT OUT.
HE GOT HIM.
>> I DID NOT THINK HE WOULD HAVE
A CHANCE TO GET TO -- CHANCE TO
CATCH IT.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A FAIR BALL
AND GONE AND FINALLY NUMBER 100
FOUR RHYS HOSKINS.
THAT HAS GOT TO FEEL GOOD TO GET
THAT MONKEY OFF HIS BACK.
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> HE LINES IT TO RIGHT FIELD.
THAT IS IN FOR A BASE HIT.
ONE IS IN.
HERE COMES MCCUTCHEN.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE NOT IN
TIME!
TWO RUN SINGLE FOR HARPER.
IT IS A SEVEN-RUN EIGHTH INNING.
THE PHILLIES LEAD IT 8-3.
SCOTT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY GLAD YOU ASKED, A
YOUTUBE ORIGINAL SERIES THAT
EXAMINES TIMELY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF SYSTEMIC RACISM ON
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IN OUR DAILY
LIVES.
ALL EPISODES ARE AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW, NO SUBSCRIPTION REQUIRE.
SEARCH "GLAD YOU ASKED" ONLY ON
YOUTUBE.
LOOK WHAT WINS OUR FIRST POLL
QUESTION.
FAVORITE PHILLY PHANATIC MOMENT.
TOMMY LASORDA STRIKES BACK.
I FEEL LIKE WE INFLUENCE TO
THAT.
YOU BOTH PICKED IT.
WE SHOWED THE VIDEO, WHICH WAS
MONEY.
DAN: WHEN YOU PASS THE TEST OF
TIME, 1988, RIGHT?
A LOT OF THE YOUNGER VIEWERS,
YOUNGER GENERATION, IT IS GOOD.
WHEN YOU CAN MAKE IT THROUGH
1988 TO 2021, IT IS SPECIAL.
SCOTT: YOU ARE DOING SOMETHING
RIGHT.
HE WILL STEP ON THE BAG FOR THE
FIRST OUT.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER
AND MAY NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM.
DAN: I THINK JOE GIRARDI AND THE
PHILLY STAFF WILL KEEP A
WATCHFUL EYE ON SPENCER THIS
INNING.
GOING BACK TO THAT LAST START
AGAINST THE RED SOX, A BIG DIP
IN VELOCITY.
HE HAS LOOKED REALLY SHARP SO
FAR.
COMMENDING THE FASTBALL, A
COUPLE OF BREAKING BALLS.
THERE IS A GOOD FASTBALL.
95.
SCOTT: ALEC BOHM TRIED TO MAKE A
PLAY IN MIGHT HAVE HURT HIMSELF.
LOOKS LIKE HE IS FAVORING HIS
RIGHT ARM.
CLIFF: THAT IS THE LAST TEAM
THIS PHILLIES TEAM NEEDS.
SCOTT: COLLIDED WITH THE SIDE
GATE.
IT IS SHORT AND HE IS TALL.
HE KIND OF TUMBLES OVER IT.
CLIFF: THERE IS NOTHING IN
PREGAME THAT CAN PREPARE YOU FOR
THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE NET TO PROTECT
THE FANS AND I GET IT, THIS IS
WHAT YOU RISK AS FAR AS
ORGANIZATIONS AND PLAYERS.
DAN: YOU CAN KINDA SEE THAT
INDENTATION WHERE IT STICKS OUT.
I THINK INITIALLY CAUGHT THE
LEFT HIP AREA.
YOU WILL SEE PLAYERS, THEY ARE
NOT AS HESITANT TO GO TOWARD THE
FOUL LINES WITH THE NETTING.
YOU ALMOST HAVE A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY IT IS GOING TO SOFTEN
THE BLOW.
THAT IS A TERRIFIC EFFORT BY
ALEC BOHM.
TAKING A LOOK AT HIS RIGHT HAND.
THERE IS A LOOK AT THE NETTING
THAT THROUGHOUT MAJOR NOW HAS
HELPED TO PROTECT FANS.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF PLAYERS
MAKE CATCHES AND USE IT ALMOST
AS A PILLOW TO FALL ON.
SCOTT: LIKE A TRAMPOLINE
SOMETIMES IN THE OUTFIELD IF
THERE IS SOME GIVE TO IT.
CLIFF: THERE IS NO GIVE IN THAT
ONE.
THAT IS SOME GIVE, YEAH, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF HE WANTED IT.
SCOTT: HE IS OK.
2-1 TWO LEADOFF HITTER SIERRA.
IF THERE IS NO NETTING AND HE
DOES GO FOR THAT BASEBALL THAT
HARD, THEN HIS FACE PROBABLY
LANDS IN THE SEATS.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD MOVEMENT ON
THAT FASTBALL RIGHT THERE.
I COUPLE OF HIS FASTBALLS, HE
HAS HAD THE TAILING MOTION GOING
AWAY FROM THE LEFTY.
MARCHAND SITTING DOWN AND AWAY
AND A LITTLE NATURAL CUT.
CORBIN BURNES OF THE BREWERS HAS
REALLY BROUGHT THAT PITCH EN
VOGUE RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS ANOTHER GOOD FASTBALL.
IF YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI, YOU HAVE
TO LIKE WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN.
THAT WAS HIS 35TH PITCH.
HE HAS MAINTAINED HIS VELOCITY
EVERY A GOOD ASSORTMENT OF
CHANGEUPS.
HE HAS SLIPPED A COUPLE OF
BREAKING BALLS OVER FOR STRIKES.
THOUGH FAR, SO GOOD.
SCOTT: GOT HIM.
CLIFF: MAN, WHAT A NICE
CHANGEUP.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS
THE BEST COMBINATION, THE ONE
THAT GAVE ME THE MOST TROUBLE,
THAT FASTBALL-CHANGEUP COMBO.
DAN: YOU SEE THE GRIP, THE
CIRCLE CHANGEUP.
HE GETS AWAY WITH THIS ONE HERE.
THE INTENDED TARGET WAS DOWN AND
AWAY.
REACHING ACROSS HIS BODY.
MOST OF THE TIME WHEN YOUR
CATCHER HAS REACH THAT FAR AWAY
TO HAVE TO BRING A BALL EVEN
THOUGH IT IS A STRIKE, IT IS A
DIFFICULT PITCH FOR AN UMPIRE TO
CALL FOR A STRIKE.
DAN: TO ME, THAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE, BEING ABLE TO GET A
SWING ON A FIRST PITCH OTHER
THAN YOUR FASTBALL BECAUSE AS A
HITTER, OUR MEETING TELLS US HE
IS THROWING THE FASTBALL, THE
FOUR-SEAMER THIS SEASON.
THAT IS UP FROM 56% LAST YEAR,
SO I'M GIVING YOU NUMBERS.
THEN IT GETS YOU OFF THE
FASTBALL ENOUGH TO WHERE YOU FLY
OUT TO RIGHT FIELD THAT.
SCOTT: FLY BALL
TWO OUT OF THREE SO FAR TODAY
FOR YOUNG SPENCER HOWARD.
>> DUVALL.
NOW BOEHM OFF THE WALL AND
RIGHT.
GETS IT IN.
THERE IS ANOTHER ONE.
THAT IS ANOTHER OUTFIELD ASSIST
FOR ADAM DUVALL.
LINED AND CAUGHT.
WHAT A PLAY AT SHORT.
ROJAS TAKES A HIT AWAY.
HERE COMES THE THROW FROM
SIERRA.
APPLIES THE TAG.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
WHAT A THROW BY SIERRA AND WHAT
A PLAY ON THE BACK END BY SANDY
LEON.
CASTRO DEALS AND COOPER SENDS
ONE INTO THE AIR LEFT FIELD.
THIS ONE IS DEEP, THIS ONE IS
GONE.
WE ARE TIED IN THE SEVENTH.
GARRETT COOPER DOES IT AGAIN.
PAYOFF PITCH COMING.
THERE IS A FLY BALL TO DEEP LEFT
CENTER FIELD.
GARRETT COOPER!
IT IS A MARLIN'S WALKOFF WINNER!
A BIG HOME RUN IN LAST NIGHT'S
BALLGAME TIED IT UP.
TONIGHT, THE WALKOFF WINNER.
>> FOR THE MARLINS, THEIR SECOND
WALKOFF VICTORY OF THE SEASON.
BOY, DID THEY NEED THIS WHEN.
SCOTT: WE ARE JUMPING INTO THE
FOURTH AND MIAMI AND MLB IS
CURRENTLY IN THE MIDST OF ITS
FOOD FIGHT, A BRACKET
COMPETITION WHERE ALL 30 TEAMS
PUT THEIR BALLPARK SIGNATURE
FOOD ITEM AGAINST EACH OTHER.
BEST FOOD IN BASEBALL.
DID YOU GUYS EAT LUNCH?
DAN: LOOK AT THE BOOM STICK.
CLIFF: WHEN YOU SHOW ME THIS,
I'M READY.
SCOTT: DAN, CAN YOU HANDLE THAT?
DAN: COULD I EVER.
THERE IS A GUY ALL THE WAY DOWN
FROM SOUTH PHILLY.
CLIFF: ARE WE DEFINITELY GOING
WITH THE PHILLY CHEESE STEAK?
DAN: THE WEATHER IS WARM ENOUGH.
YOU WILL SEE ME AT CITIZENS BANK
BALLPARK THE NEXT HOMESTAND.
FOR SURE.
JUST A SHORT DRIVE.
GREAT BALLPARK FOOD, GREAT
AMBIENCE.
SCOTT: WEAKLY HANDLED.
MORE WEEK CONTACT FROM PABLO
LOPEZ.
THAT IS HIS SPECIALTY TO
SIT-DOWN BRAD MILLER.
NOW HERE COMES RHYS HOSKINS, ONE
OF THE PLAYERS MIKE DUNN FOR US
TODAY -- MICED U  --MIC-ED UP
FOR US TODAY.
>> WHAT ABOUT WAFFLE CRISP?
>> NEVER HAD THAT ONE.
>> GOLDEN GRAMS.
>> LOVE GOLDEN GRAMS.
THEY JUST GET SOGGY SUPERFAST.
THAT IS A HELL OF A PLAY, DUDE.
NICE JOB.
SCOTT: I LOVE THAT.
RHYS HOSKINS, ONE OF THE LEADERS
ON THIS TEAM, HE HAS BEEN THERE
A WHILE NOW.
DAN: SERIAL CONNOISSEUR.
-- CEREAL CONNOISSEUR.
THEY GET SOGGY.
CLIFF: HE IS RIGHT.
YOU BETTER EAT THEM RIGHT THEN
AND THERE.
SCOTT: THERE IS A SHOT CLOCK ON
THAT.
CLIFF: IT IS A WRAP.
NOTHING WORSE THAN SOGGY CEREAL.
DAN: HAVING PITCHED FOR 18
SEASONS AND THE BIG LEAGUES, I
NEVER REALLY ENJOYED BALLPARK
FOOD UNTIL I WAS DONE PLAYING.
RETIRED IN 2003 AND I WAS A
LIMITED SEASON TICKET HOLDER
WITH THE WHITE SOX AND I COULD
NOT GET OVER WHAT I WAS MISSING
FOR 18 YEARS WITH BALLPARK FOOD.
SCOTT, IT IS WORTH MAKING A TRIP
TO DRIVE TO CITIZENS BANK
BALLPARK JUST TO GO OUT AND THAT
LEFT AND RIGHT CENTER FIELD AREA
AND THEY HAVE WORLD-CLASS FOOD.
I'M TELLING YOU.
RIGHT THERE.
PHILLY CHEESE STEAK WITH SOME
FRENCH FRIES EVERY IT LOOK AT
THESE GUYS GETTING AFTER IT.
SCOTT: RHYS HOSKINS GOES DOWN.
THAT ONE AVOIDED HIM, BUT JUST
BARELY.
A CLOSE CALL.
SUMPTION MUSIC.
CLIFF: MAN.
I KNOW HE IS MIC'ED UP.
BUT WE PROBABLY WON'T HEAR AFTER
THAT PITCH.
SCOTT: HOW SCARY IS THIS?
CLIFF: LOOK, YOU ARE SO DIALED
IN.
YOU ARE LIKE HIT, HIT, HIT, GET
AWAY, TURN.
YOU ARE TAUGHT TO TURN AWAY FROM
THAT BASEBALL JUST LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE SEEN A FEW GUYS, ONE
BEING GIANCARLO STANTON, GET HIT
IN THE FACE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE PREPARED FOR A
LOT.
DAN: KEVIN PILLAR WITH THE METS
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
HOSKINS WEARS THAT EXTENSION ON
THE SIDE OF THAT HELMET.
SCOTT: BRYCE HARPER WAS CLIPPED.
CURRENTLY ON THE INJURED LIST.
CLIFF: THANK GOODNESS HE HAD THE
HELMET.
SCARY, MAN.
SCOTT: FULL BOAT TO RHYS
HOSKINS.
THIS IS WHAT I'M REFERRING TO
WITH BRYCE.
CURRENTLY ANOTHER SHELF.
APRIL 28.
CLIFF: THERE IS SO MUCH TALK IN
THE GAME WITH WHAT PITCHERS ARE
ALLOWED TO HAVE ON THEIR HANDS
TO HAVE MORE CONTROL.
LOOK --
SCOTT: HOSKINS WITH A DEEP
DRIVE.
LEFT CENTER AND HE GOT IT!
DAN: THAT IS THE ULTIMATE
PAYBACK RIGHT THERE AS HE
SALUTES THE FELLOWS OUT IN THE
BULLPEN.
GETS KNOCKED DOWN.
2-2.
DOES NOT GIVE UP THAT AT BAT.
GUTSY AT BAT.
BIG SWING.
HE IS ONE OF THE KEYS.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM BEFORE THE
GAME.
SCOTT: RHYS HOSKINS MUSCLES UP
FOR HIS 11TH OF THE YEAR.
EIGHT OF THEM ON THE ROAD.
HE BREAKS THE ICE FOR THE
PHILLIES.
HIS SECOND OF THE SERIES.
HE HIT THAT ONE WITH A LITTLE
ADDED MOTIVATION.
DAN: ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
RHYS HOSKINS RIGHT THERE.
TAKES ONE UP ON THE CHIN, KNOCKS
HIM DOWN, HANGS IN AND GETS A
TOUGH FRIDAY IN LOPEZ.
CLIFF: IT MAKES YOU FOCUS MORE
WHEN YOU GET KNOCKED DOWN.
HE ABSOLUTELY STAYS ON THIS
CHANGEUP.
THROUGH IT.
HE KNEW IT WHEN HE HIT IT THAT
HE GOT IT.
DAN: HIT A BIG HOME RUN IN
TUESDAY'S GAME OFF ALCANTARA.
TWO BIG BOMBS IN THIS SERIES.
CLIFF: THIRD HOMER IN THE LAST
SIX GAMES.
EIGHT R.B.I. IN THAT STRETCH.
HE HAS BEEN HUGE FOR THIS TEAM,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR
BIG BOY IN HARPER DOWN.
REESE -- RHYS HOSKINS IS
STEPPING UP.
SCOTT: I DO WANT TO HEAR THE MIC
ON THE HOMER.
CLIFF: YOU MIGHT NOT WANT TO
HEAR THAT EITHER.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: WE WILL WORK ON TURNING
THAT AROUND.
CLIFF: HE WAS HYPED GOING
AROUND.
AS SOON AS HE HIT IT, HE GOT IT.
SCOTT: WE WILL SEE IF IT WAS
CLEAN.
[LAUGHTER]
STAY TUNED.
CLIFF: THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
REFERRING TO, PEOPLE.
SCOTT: FAMILY SHOW, FAMILY GAME.
ODUBEL HERRERA.
ONE OUT, NOBODY ON FOR THE
PHILLIES AFTER THE HOSKINS SHOT,
403 FEET.
DAN: PHILLY IS VERY ENCOURAGED
ODUBEL HERRERA IS STARTING TO
SWING THE BAT MUCH BETTER.
MADE A TREMENDOUS CATCH LAST
NIGHT IN THE SEVENTH INNING.
DEEP FLY BALL TO CENTER FIELD.
AARON NOLA, BROUGHT WHAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A HOME RUN BACK INTO
THE BALLPARK.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PHILLIES LOST
THE LEAD IN THE EIGHTH INNING OF
THE GAME AND IT WENT UNNOTICED,
BUT IT WAS A TERRIFIC PLAY.
SCOTT: FOUL GROUND.
DIAZ THINKS HE FOUND IT, IT IS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE SCREEN.
HE HAS THAT GLARE RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT FROM YOU,
CLIFF.
CLIFF: HE IS JUST THINKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING, THE WHOLE AT-BAT.
JUST PLAYING IT BACK.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT -- AMONGST YOUR
BOYS, BUT YOU ARE LIKE IN YOUR
HEAD YOU ARE LIKE, YOU KNOCKED
ME DOWN, I DID WHAT I NEEDED TO
DO.
YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT THE NEXT
AT BAT RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS JUST THE GAME RIGHT
THERE.
WHAT WAS THAT PITCH?
CHANGEUP, STAYED ON IT.
SCOTT: HERRERA IS ALL OVER THAT
ONE AND IT IS INTO THE GAP AND
HE IS HEADING FOR TWO AND HE IS
IN WITH A ONE OUT DOUBLE.
DAN: PHILLY'S PUTTING ANOTHER
HITTING SHOES HERE.
EARLY START, 12:10 START.
YOU SEE THE CIRCLE CHANGEUP
GRIP.
ODUBEL KEEPS HIS HEAD DOWN AND
DRIVES THE BALL INTO THE GAP IN
LEFT CENTER.
WITH THE SHIFT.
THIS BALL ALMOST GETS TO THE
WALL.
A GREAT JOB OF CUTTING IT OFF
FOR THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN THREE
BASES.
CLIFF: WE TALKED ABOUT THE USAGE
OF PABLO AND HIS CHANGEUP.
THE PHILLIES HITTERS SEEM TO
HAVE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO
DETAIL.
DAN: THIS IS ANOTHER GUY THE
PHILLIES NEED TO GET GOING.
BOHM HAD SUCH A BIG YEAR LAST
YEAR.
YOU SEE THE AVERAGE ON THE YEAR,
DOWN A LITTLE BIT TO .211 ON THE
YEAR.
WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO JOE
GIRARDI AND IT IS A LITTLE BIT
OF BAD LUCK, LITTLE BIT OF THE
LEAGUE MAKING SOME ADJUSTMENTS
TO BOHM.
IF THE PHILLIES ARE GOING TO
STAY IN CONTENTION, THEY WILL
NEED THIS GUY TO START DRIVING
AND RUNS.
SCOTT: HE IS GOING THE OTHER WAY
AND THAT IS GOING TO DROP.
HERRERA WILL HOLD UP AT THIRD.
IT IS A SINGLE FOR BOHM.
THE PHILLIES POUNCING WITH A
HOMER, A DOUBLE, AND A SINGLE
AFTER THE FIRST OUT HERE IN THE
FOURTH.
DAN: REALLY GOOD SIGN.
THIS IS A GOOD FASTBALL THAT
RUNS IN ON BOHM.
HE DOES NOT TRY TO PULL IT.
GOOD INSIDE-OUT SWING.
LINE DRIVE AND A GREAT APPROACH.
CLIFF: THAT IS THE ONE THING
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT GETTING
GOING CAN GET YOU GOING.
NOT TRYING TO GO TO RIGHT FIELD,
BUT LETTING THE PITCH GET DEEP
ON YOU AND MAY BE THINKING ABOUT
BREAKING YOUR BAT, BUT STAYING
UP THE MIDDLE.
THAT IS ALWAYS THE ONE REMEDY TO
GET YOU GOING AND GET YOU OUT OF
A FUNK IN YOUR HEAD.
SCOTT: BOHM MIGHT HAVE HAD SOME
EXTRA MOTIVATION AS HIS RIGHT
PINKY WAS BEING TREATED IN THE
DUGOUT AND THEN HE STEPS BACK IN
THEIR AND CONTRIBUTES.
DAN: COULD HAVE BEEN PART OF
THAT FOUL BALL HE WENT THROUGH
THE INNING WHEN HE RAN INTO THE
NETTING FROM THE DUGOUT AT THIRD
BASE.
SCOTT: THAT IS A GOOD
LEADERBOARD TO BE A PART OF.
NATIONAL LEAGUE OPPOSITE FIELD
HIT.
FOR A YOUNG HITTER TO BE ABLE TO
GO THE OTHER WAY CONSISTENTLY
LIKE HE DOES.
CLIFF: WE TALK ABOUT THE SHIFT
AND EVERYTHING GOING ON IN THE
GAME AND YOU HAVE TO PLAY BOHM
COMING YOU HAVE TO PLAY HIM
STRAIGHT UP.
LAST YEAR, SMALL SAMPLE SIZE, HE
HAD A GREAT SEASON, BUT THIS IS
THE ADJUSTMENT HE HAS TO MAKE TO
WHAT THE LEAGUE IS GOING TO DO.
HE HAS TO MAKE THE ADJUSTMENTS
TO WHAT HE IS DOING.
GET BACK TO WHAT HIM -- MADE HIM
SO SUCCESSFUL IN HIS FIRST YEAR.
SCOTT: MATT JOYCE BRINGS THE
FIRST PITCH DOWNSTAIRS.
BOHM LAST YEAR HIT .338, SECOND
PLACE FOR ROOKIE OF THE YEAR IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
AND A .452 BATTING AVERAGE WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
JOYCE SENDS ONE CENTER, SIERRA
HAS IT.
THAT SHOULD BE PLENTY DEEP
ENOUGH FOR HERRERA TO COME ON
DOWN.
IT IS 2-0 PHILLIES ON THE SAC
FLY FROM MATT JOYCE.
ON THE PREVIOUS PLAY, THEY
DIDN'T RUN ON ADAM DUVALL AND
THAT MAKES SENSE GIVEN HOW GOOD
HE HAS BEEN OUT THERE.
CHRISTINA: THANKS, SCOTT.
WHEN THE MARLINS SIGNED ADAM
DUVALL BEFORE SPRING TRAINING,
THEY EXPECTED A MIDDLE OF THE
ORDER BAT, BUT SINCE HE TOOK
OVER IN RIGHT FIELD FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVERY DAY, HE HAS
BEEN GREAT.
HE ACTUALLY LEADS MLB WITH 10
DEFENSIVE RUN SAVED.
HE HAS SIX ASSISTS.
SCOTT: THAT IS ON THE GROUND.
SWEET PLAY AT SHORT FOR THE OUT
AT SECOND.
MIGUEL ROJAS FLIPPING IT OVER TO
ISAN DIAZ TO RETIRE THE SIDE.
TWO RUNS COME ACROSS FOR THE
PHILLIES, INCLUDING A MAMMOTH
SMASH OFF THE BAT OF RHYS
HOSKINS.
2-0, PHILADELPHIA.
SO SOLID.
>> THE CHEERFUL MAN WITH THE
COLORFUL HAIR IS A SMOOTH YOUNG
INFIELDER KNOWN AS JAZZ.
>> IS GOING TO BE JAZZY, HE IS
GOING TO BE FUN, BUT HE IS GOING
TO BE CHILLED BY EVERY SITUATION
AT THE SAME TIME.
>> JAZZ CHISHOLM HAS THE DRIP.
BUT DON'T GET THE WRONG IDEA.
HE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT HIMSELF
AND THE THIRD PERSON BECAUSE
HE'S ARROGANT.
>> I GET IN THE FIELD AND AS
SOON AS THE GLOVE IS IN MY HAND,
J NASTY, DON'T FORGET IT.
>> HE TALKS ABOUT HIMSELF AND
THE THIRD PERSON BECAUSE HE HAS
AN ARRAY OF ALTER EGO'S.
J NASTY.
PRINCE.
THE KID.
AS IN HALL OF FAMER KEN GRIFFEY
JR., WHOSE SWING HIS RESEMBLES.
>> JUST DOING EVERYTHING THAT HE
USED TO DO AND THAT IS MY THING.
THE KID IS REALLY NICE, BUT
WATCH WHEN YOU SEE J NASTY OUT
THERE.
HE'S GOING TO GET IT AND GET
EVERYTHING.
>> J NASTY IS HIS DISPOSITION ON
DEFENSE AND PRINCE A PERSONA HE
GOT FROM HIS GRANDMOTHER.
>> THAT IS ALL SHE THOUGHT OF
ME, LIKE YOU ARE MY PRINCE, YOU
ARE ROYALTY, YOU WILL ALWAYS BE
GREAT AT EVERYTHING YOU DO
BECAUSE YOU ARE BLESSED WITH
THAT ROYALTY IN YOUR BLOOD.
DAN: SO YOU WANT TO BE A HITTER
IN THE BIG LEAGUES?
IT TAKES SOME GUTS.
GETS A CUTTER AWAY.
HE IS SITTING PRETTY.
LOOKING FOR A HEATER.
LOOK OUT.
SEES A GOOD SINKER DOWN IN THE
SOUND THAT HE DOESN'T CHASE AND
THEN HE GETS A TWO-SEAMER HE HAS
TO HIS LIKING RIGHT HERE EVERY
IT ONE SWING OF THE BAT.
YOU CAN SEE THE BAT FLIP RIGHT
THERE.
GUTSY AT BAT FROM RHYS HOSKINS.
SCOTT: HOME RUN NUMBER 11 ON THE
SEASON.
HE HAD A BIG START TO THE YEAR
AND THE POWER DEPARTMENT.
DAN: THIS IS A BIG INNING FOR
SPENCER HOWARD.
THE MIDDLE PART OF THE ORDER,
JUST SCORED TWO RUNS.
YOU OFTEN REFERRED TO THE
INNINGS -- THESE INNINGS AS A
SHUTDOWN INNING.
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW HE
HANDLES THIS AFTER THE PHILLIES
SPOT HIM WITH A TWO-RUN LEAD.
SCOTT: QUICKLY AHEAD OF COREY
DICKERSON.
SPENCER HOWARD, 68 PITCHES LAST
TIME OUT.
DAN: I DON'T KNOW WHAT WORK HE
HAS DONE BETWEEN THAT START AND
THIS ONE, BUT HE LOOKS REALLY
LOCKED IN, NOT OVERTHROWING.
A COUPLE OF BREAKING BALLS HE
HAS GOTTEN AWAY WITH.
HE HAS LOOKED REALLY GOOD.
MECHANICS, STAYING UP OVER THE
RUBBER.
NOT FALLING OFF TOWARD FIRST
BASE.
SCOTT: POPPED UP.
BOHM PUTTING HIS HAND OUT
AGAINST THE NETTING AND MAKES
THE CATCH.
CLIFF: THERE YOU GO.
SCOTT: NOW HE'S GOT A FEEL FOR
THAT AREA.
TWO BALLS IN THE SAME SPOT IN
THE LAST 20 MINUTES.
CLIFF: GOT AWAY WITH A FASTBALL
IN THE ZONE.
A GREAT PLAY BY BOHM JUST
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HE HAS TO DO
TO PROTECT HIMSELF.
SCOTT: CHRISTINA, I JUST SAW
YOU.
HOW WAS THAT?
WHAT DID IT LOOK LIKE IN PERSON?
CHRISTINA: THANKS, SCOTT.
I'M A FORMER SOFTBALL PLAYER IN
THE ONE TIME I DON'T BRING MY
GLOVE TO THE BALLPARK --
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS EASILY THE CLOSEST I'VE
EVER HAD A FOUL BALL.
I THINK THIS ONE WORKED A LOT
BETTER FOR HIM THAN THE FIRST
ONE, LUCKILY.
DAN: CHRISTINA, IT IS DAN.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS AN AGE
RESTRICTION ON WHEN YOU SHOULD
OR SHOULDN'T RING A GLOVE?
CHRISTINA: THIS IS MY
PHILOSOPHY, SAFETY FIRST.
MY LIVELIHOOD IS MY HANDS, I'M A
WRITER.
IF I TRY TO CATCH A FOUL BALL IN
THE PRESS BOX AND BROKE MY HAND,
THEN I'M IN TROUBLE.
.
CLIFF: I THINK FOR A LOT OF
THESE FANS THAT COME OUT, THEY
THINK IT IS EASY TO CATCH A FOUL
BALL.
I GOT THIS, NO BIG DEAL,
BAREHANDS.
CHRISTINA: THE PROBLEM IS I'M
THINKING BACK TO MY SOFTBALL
COACHES, SOFT HANDS, I'M PRETTY
SURE MOST OF THE FANS IN THE
BALLPARK DID NOT GET THAT
INSTRUCTION, SO THEY ARE GOING
TO BE JABBING UP IT.
CLIFF: IF YOU ARE ON A DATE AND
THE GIRL DON'T BRING HER GLOVE
AND YOU BRING YOURS, YOU BETTER
PROTECTOR.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: THAT'S RIGHT.
NICE CURVEBALL FROM HOWARD AS HE
RINGS OF ADAM DUVALL.
DAN: HERE IS A GOOD LOOK AT IT
RIGHT HERE.
HIGH STRIKE CALLED MORE AND MORE
IN BASEBALL.
YOU CAN SEE THAT SPIKE
CURVEBALL.
GREAT 12 TO SIX ROTATION.
SCOTT: DUVALL FROZEN.
CLIFF: WITHOUT SAYING -- SEEING
HIS LAST START, I WOULD SAY --
WHAT HE HAS DONE DIFFERENTLY, IT
IS PROBABLY THAT FIRST PITCH.
WE HAVE SEEN THE CURVEBALL, THE
CHANGEUP.
THAT IS PROBABLY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT HE HAS DONE IN THE PAST.
DAN: IT MAKES THAT FASTBALL PLAY
A COUPLE OF TICKS BETTER.
THAT IS ONE OF THE KEYS TO
PITCHING.
JACOB DEGROM AND GERRIT COLE, I
GET IF THEY THROW 98-100.
IT IS NOT JUST ONE PITCH THAT
GETS THEM THROUGH, THERE IS
ANOTHER GOOD CURVEBALL.
YOU OFTEN HEAR ABOUT PITCHING,
IT IS ABOUT REAL ESTATE,
LOCATION.
A LOT OF TIMES IT IS LIKE REAL
ESTATE, CAN YOU SELL YOURSELF
THAT YOUR STUFF IS GOOD ENOUGH
FOR THE STRIKE ZONE?
GREAT SHUT DOWN INNINGS SO FAR.
CLIFF: SO, YOU GET THE
PERCENTAGE OF 80%, WHICH HE HAS
THROWN TODAY, 80% OF THE TIME.
THAT IS PRETTY MUCH RIGHT WHERE
HE HAS BEEN THE WHOLE SEASON,
BUT IT IS ALSO THE OTHER TIMES
HE HAS GOTTEN SWINGS OR HE HAS
THROWN IT FOR A STRIKE TO SORT
OF PUT HIMSELF IN A BETTER
POSITION TO UTILIZE THAT
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: 34 STRIKES OF 48 PITCHES.
THERE IS ANOTHER.
CLIFF: WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
SPLITTING THE PLATE WITH THE
FASTBALL, THAT IS TROUBLE FOR A
PITCHER.
HUNTING THE FASTBALL.
HE GETS AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE IN
THE BACK OF YOUR MIND IT IS
LIKE, THAT MIGHT BE THAT GOOD
CHANGE OF OR CURVEBALL HE HAS
BEEN THROWING UP.
SCOTT: A LITTLE TRAFFIC AGAINST
HOWARD AND THE SECOND, BUT 1, 2,
3 FIRST AND SECOND.
TRYING TO PICK UP ANOTHER
PERFECT FRAME.
DIAZ DID NOT GO AROUND.
THE COUNT IS FULL.
WHAT BUTTON ON YOU -- ARE YOU
PRESSING ON THIS PITCHER MENU?
HOWARD GOES WITH THE HEAT.
IT IS ON THE GROUND.
NICE STOP BY MILLER.
GETS UP AND MAKES THE PLAY.
THERE YOU GO.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN AGAIN FOR
HOWARD.
THREE OF HIS FOUR ENDINGS, HE
HAS DONE THE TRICK.
THE ROOKIE LOOKING VERY SHARP IN
HIS SECOND START OF THE SEASON.
BRAD MILLER PLAYS JUST ABOUT
ANYWHERE.
HE DOES IT WELL.
THE PHILLIES LOVE HIM.
2-0, PHILADELPHIA.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> O MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> I'VE TALKED ABOUT HIS
FIELDING SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: 2-0 OVER THE FISH.
WE WILL FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE
CREATOR, TODAY OUR SPOTLIGHT
SIGNS ON JOLLY ALL OF -- OLIVE.
JOLLY OLIVE, WHO CREATES ABOUT
8-10 MINUTE VIDEOS, FOCUSING
ANOTHER'S TOPICS IS A METS FAN.
HIS FIRST PLAYOFF GAME, NLDS,
METS AND DODGERS, OVER 18,000
SUBSCRIBERS, OVER ONE MILLION
VIEWS AND HIS CHANNEL ONLY
LAUNCHED ABOUT NINE MONTHS AGO.
FAVORITE MLB BALLPARK DELICACY.
PHILLIES FANS COMING IN HOT WITH
THE CHEESESTEAK.
CLIFF: I'M TELLING YOU, MAN, IT
IS A PROBLEM.
SCOTT: LANDSLIDE VICTORY.
CHEESESTEAKS FOR EVERYONE.
MIAMI'S CUBAN SANDWICH CHECKING
IN IN SECOND PLACE.
THAT ONE IS ON A FEW BOUNCES FOR
DIAZ.
THAT SITS DOWN MARCHAND.
SUSHI OPTIONS IN THE BALLPARK AS
WELL.
CLIFF: I DO A COUPLE OF GAMES IN
MIAMI.
SUSHI IS PRETTY GOOD THERE.
DAN: GIVE US A SCOUTING REPORT
IN OF THE FOOD IN MIAMI.
CLIFF: EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE,
MIAMI, YOU HAVE THE CUBAN
SANDWICH.
THEY HAVE THE NICE LITTLE CUBAN
SANDWICH SPOT THERE.
PRETTY GOOD WHEN YOU HAVE DONE
THE BIKE AND YOU ARE FEELING A
LITTLE FRISKY.
WHEN YOU ARE FEELING LIKE YOU
WANT TO SAVE YOURSELF A LITTLE
BIT, THEY HAVE A SUSHI BAR THAT
IS REALLY DANG GOOD.
SO, I TELL YOU WHAT, I GO FOR
SUSHI BECAUSE I'M LAZY AND IT IS
RIGHT BY OUR BOOTH.
I HAVE NOT TRIED THE NATHAN'S
HOT DOG.
THEY HAVE A NICE LITTLE SAUSAGE
STAND AS WELL.
THAT LINE IS ALWAYS TOO LONG, SO
I KEEP IT MOVING.
SCOTT: THAT WAS AN A PLUS
BREAKDOWN, DAN.
GOOD JOB, CLIFF.
CLIFF: MY KIDS -- I TELL YOU
SOMETHING ALL THE TIME, Y'ALL
DON'T EAT HOTDOGS AT HOME, BUT
WHEN YOU COME TO THE BALLPARK,
YOU GET HOTDOGS.
IT IS DIFFERENT HERE.
OK.
EVERY KID YOU SEE HAS A HOT DOG
OR NACHOS.
SCOTT: WE ARE SEEING IT HERE.
DAN: I MIGHT JUST DRIVE TO
CITIZENS BANK.
I KNOW THERE IS NOT A GAME GOING
ON.
YOU ARE MAKING ME HUNGRY, CLIFF.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO GET A HOLD
OF THE PHILLIES PR GUY AND TELL
HIM, OPEN THE DOORS, I NEED TO
CHEESESTEAK.
SCOTT: LOPEZ THOUGHT HE HAD
STRIKE THREE.
NOW HE FINDS IT.
CLIFF: NOBODY HAS A CLUE OF HOW
GOOD THOSE CHEESE ARE IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
PEOPLE THINK WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ON THE STREET.
THEY ARE GOOD WHEN YOU GO OVER,
WHEN YOU ARE IN DOWNTOWN PHILLY,
BUT CHEESESTEAKS IN THE
CLUBHOUSE WE HAD -- GUYS NEVER
EIGHT DINNER AFTER THE GAME,
THEY HAD CHEESESTEAKS MADE FOR
THEM TO TAKE TO THE HOTEL.
DAN: THE WORST THING FOR ME
WOULD BE A DAY GAME AND YOU ARE
FIGHTING THE TEMPTATION TO HAVE
ONE OF THOSE CHEESESTEAKS AT
ABOUT 10:30 IN THE MORNING WHEN
YOU ARE SITTING IN THE BULLPEN.
[LAUGHTER]
I WOULD BE SITTING IN THE
VISITING BULLPEN THINKING, WOW,
I HOPE THEY DON'T CALL MY NUMBER
TODAY BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF I
CAN MOVE.
I COULD NEVER STOP WITH JUST
ONE.
I ALWAYS DOUBLE FISTED.
CLIFF: DOUBLE FISTED FOR SURE.
DAN: GO INTO PHILADELPHIA
WAITING -- WAITING TO 15, GO OUT
WEIGHING TWO HUNDRED 35.
SCOTT: NEXT TIME WE DO A GAME,
I'M BRINGING FOOD FOR BOTH OF
YOU.
DAN: I NEED TO GO TO THE BANK
QUICKLY.
[LAUGHTER]
CITIZENS BANK PARK ON MY MIND.
SCOTT: ROMAN QUINN.
TWO GONE.
2-1.
SHOWED SOME OF THE GREAT WORK
PABLO LOPEZ HAS BEEN UP TO IN
THE PAST COUPLE SEASONS.
TWO EARNED RUNS OR FEWER MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT.
JUST A FEW CLUNKERS IN HIS
CAREER.
JUST FOUR STARTS THAT DID NOT
WORK OUT WELL FOR HIM OVER THE
LAST FEW SEASONS.
CLIFF: THAT IS THE PITCH RIGHT
THERE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HIM AND
MATURING AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT
HE HAS TO DO, THAT HAS BEEN THE
BIGGEST EYE-OPENER FOR ME IS
WATCHING HIS MATURITY AS FAR AS
HAVING AN E.R.A. OVER 5.00 IN
2019 AND THEN STEADILY GOING
DOWN TO WHERE HE UNDERSTANDS YOU
CAN'T GET AWAY WITH THROWING A
FIVE MILE-PER-HOUR FASTBALL.
.
SCOTT: USE THAT CHANGE PEACE AND
USE IT WELL.
-- PIECE AND USE IT WELL.
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
LINE DRIVE.
IF IT STAYS FAIR, IT WILL BE
GONE.
IT IS A HOME RUN!
HE HAS POUNDED A HOME RUN.
THEY THINK IT WAS FOUL.
LOOK AT MARIO SOTO.
THE FOUR UMPIRES ARE DISCUSSING
IT.
THEY ARE GOING TO REVERSE THE
RULING.
THEY WANT TO KNOW HOW COULD
ANYBODY REVERSE THE RULING OF
THE THIRD BASE UMPIRE WHO WAS
CLOSER TO THE PLAY THAN ANYBODY?
IT IS BREAKING OUT NOW.
CARRIED BACK.
LOOK AT THE GRAPHICS.
QUESTION MARK ON THE SCORE.
[LAUGHTER]
LOOK AT THIS!
THERE IS A FREE-FOR-ALL NOW,
BOYS.
THEY COME FROM ALL OVER.
HOLY COW!
WHAT A RHUBARB.
THIS HAS GOT TO BE ONE OF THE
PRIZE BASEBALL FIGHTS OF ALL
TIME.
SCOTT: SOMETHING WE LIKE TO DO
TO ADD TO THE VIEWING
EXPERIENCE.
CHECK OUT YOUTUBE'S LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY FEATURING MLB, THE
PHILLIES, THE MARLINS, AND A
SELECT GROUP OF YOUTUBE
CREATOR'S THAT CONTRIBUTE WITH
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
YOU CAN DO THAT LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY ON YOUR COMPUTER.
WE WILL BE KEEPING OUR EYE ON
THAT DISCUSSION DURING THE
BROADCAST.
THEY HELP US OUT.
THEY ORGANICALLY HOOK US UP WITH
SOME GOOD NOTES AND QUESTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY HERE ON
YOUTUBE.
ALSO, MLB ORIGINALS SEASON TWO
WAS LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
SEE YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE PLAYERS YOU
LOVE.
IT IS CLIFF'S BACKYARD.
CLIFF: YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
I LIVE ABOUT 10 MINUTES FROM
THERE.
SCOTT: I MISS MIAMI.
I LIVED THERE FOR FIVE YEARS.
WENT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI.
SO DID CHRISTINA.
WE WERE IN THE SAME CLASS.
CLIFF: YOU WERE IN THE SAME
CLASS AS CHRISTINA?
DAN: TRUE STORY.
WE BOTH WORKED FOR THE
NEWSPAPER.
THIS IS LEON.
THAT'S THE DREAM RIGHT THERE.
GO TO SCHOOL FOR JOURNALISM OR
BROADCAST JOURNALISM.
NOW YOU ARE WORKING THE MARLINS
GAME.
CLIFF: BIG TIME.
DAN: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
BUT APPRECIATIVE OF WHERE I'M
AT.
SCOTT: IF HOWARD KEEPS PITCHING
LIKE THIS, HE'S GOING TO BUY
HIMSELF A HOME SOMEWHERE IN
MIAMI IF HE WANTS TO.
HE'S BEEN BRILLIANT.
HE'S BEEN ALLOWED ONE HIT, A
DOUBLE BY ADAM DUVALL.
THERE'S ANOTHER GOOD HEATER.
GOOD PIECE OF HITTING RIGHT
THERE.
DAN: LAY ON JUST TAKES WHAT HE'S
GIVEN AND GOES TO LEFT.
IT'S A BASE HIT.
RHYS HOSKINS IS MIKED UP TODAY
ON YOUTUBE.
GIVE US THE GOODS.
>> WHAT DID YOU HAVE, LOW?
.
NISI.
GOOD TAKE.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
THAT WAS HIS LAST A.B..
HIS FIRST OF THE DAY.
A BASE ON BALLS.
RHYS HOSKINS KNOWS A GOOD TAKE.
THAT'S A QUALITY TAKE.
>> I WOULD NEVER TELL REESE, I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A STRIKE.
>> ESPECIALLY WHEN HE IS MIKED.
IS THAT HOT?
THAT BALL WAS DOWN.
WASN'T EVEN CLOSE.
>> WHERE YOU INTO THAT, CLIFF?
SOME OF THE FIRST BASEMAN SUPER
TALKATIVE.
CLIFF: OUR COLLEAGUE TALKED
ABOUT YOUR BROTHER, YOUR SISTER,
YOUR AUNTIE, YOUR DOG.
I'M LIKE, I'M GETTING PICKED OFF
OVER HERE.
I DIDN'T TALK MUCH AT FIRST.
>> YOU ARE LOCKED IN.
>> NOT REALLY.
UNLESS I KNEW THE GUY FIRST.
EVERYONE I LIKE TO TALK TO IS
GUYS LIKE TONY GWYNN.
DIES I WOULD MAYBE LEARN
SOMETHING FROM FOR A MINUTE.
I REMEMBER THE GUYS.
JUST CHATTING ABOUT CERTAIN
THINGS.
I PLAYED A LITTLE BIT OF FIRST
BASE, SEE WHAT TYPE OF GLOVE
THEY WERE USING WEATHER WAS A
LITTLE ONE.
ONE WAY YOU KNOW THEY HAD SURE
HANDS.
IT'S JUST DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE IT WAS
LIKE, WHERE ARE YOU GOING AFTER
THE GAME?
MAYBE WE CAN LINK UP.
>> MAYBE HER HOUSE.
THE MLB ACCOUNT SAID CAN YOU
CONFIRM THAT WAS ACTUALLY
CLIFF'S BACKYARD PLEASE?
>> MIGHT NOT BE A BAD TIME TO GO
OUT AND TALK WITH SPENCER
HOWARD.
THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE SEEN HIM DANCE AROUND THE
STRIKE ZONE.
>> NEW TO THE ML BECAME OF THE
WEEK FOR THE 2121 CAMPAIGN.
YOU CAN VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER
WILL RECEIVE A CHERISHED TROPHY
DURING THE POST GAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME POLLING OPTIONS.
THAT WILL COME YOUR WAY LATER.
AND YOU HELP DECIDE WHO THE
POSTGAME INTERVIEW IS GOING TO
BE.
SO FAR, LEADER OF THE PACK HAS
TO BE RHYS HOSKINS OR YOU COULD
MAKE A CASE FOR SPENCER HOWARD
IF HE CONTINUES.
>> A GOOD TIME TO GO OUT AND
TALK TO A YOUNG PITCHER RIGHT
NOW.
FIRST AND SECOND NOBODY OUT.
I DOUBT MARLINS WILL BE BUNTING
HERE WITH PABLO LOPEZ ON DECK
UNLESS DON MATTINGLY DECIDES HE
MAY WANT TO GO TO HIS BULLPEN
EARLY.
JUST HAVE TO REALLY GUARD
AGAINST LAYING THAT FIRST PITCH
RIGHT IN.
JOE GIRARDI HAS SUAREZ UP IN THE
BULLPEN.
HAS A REPUTATION OF BEING A
BIG-TIME STRIKE THROWER IN THAT
PHILLIES BULLPEN.
EARLY HAVE TO CONCENTRATE IF YOU
ARE SPENCER.
MAKING GOOD PITCH, CERTAINLY YOU
CAN'T MAKE ANYBODY HIT THE BALL
WHERE YOU WOULD LIKE TO.
WHENEVER YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN
BEST BE DOWN IN THE STRIKE ZONE
TO INITIATE SOME SOFT CONTACT.
>> THEY LOVE HIS DEFENSIVE WORK.
HE'S AN EXCELLENT RECEIVER
ALREADY.
ROOKIE.
>> THAT'S PRETTY ATHLETIC.
TO KEEP THAT BALL FROM -- IF YOU
ARE A MARLINS FAN, THAT WOULD BE
AS GOOD AS A SACRIFICE BUNT
ADDING RUNNERS OVER.
>> MARCHAND MAKING HIS THIRD
START OF THE YEAR.
HE CAUGHT HOWARD ON SATURDAY.
WE ARE SEEING THE VELOCITY DROP
AND THE CONTROL WAVERING.
>> YOU CAN KIND OF SEE BY HIS
DEMEANOR, HE'S MOVING AROUND A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON THE MOUND.
TAKING MORE IN BETWEEN PITCHES.
YOU CAN SEE THAT MIND IS
STARTING TO RACE QUICKLY.
HE WAS IN SUCH ATTACK MODE
THROUGH THE FIRST FOUR INNINGS.
NOW HE'S INDECISIVE ABOUT WHAT
HE WANTS TO THROW.
THIS BALL APPEARED TO BE UP AND
OUT OF THE ZONE.
A FRIENDLY CALL TO GET BACK INTO
THE COUNT.
HOWARD WAS ABSOLUTELY CRUISING
BEFORE THIS IS GETTING DICEY.
THIS WAS THE CASE ON SATURDAY
FOR HOWARD AGAINST THE RED SOX
IN THE THIRD INNING.
IT WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM GET
THROUGH IT.
-- THEY WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM
GET THROUGH IT.
THERE'S A MISS.
IF HE WALKS BERTI, DO YOU GO TO
SUAREZ?
>> I THINK SO.
HE HAS REALLY MISSED THE STRIKE
ZONE.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR HE HAS COMMAND
OF THE FASTBALL.
AS GOOD AS HE WAS THROUGH THE
FIRST FOUR INNINGS.
HE REALLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
APPEARANCE THAT HE CAN LAND
ANYTHING HE NEEDS FOR A STRIKE.
THE ONLY STRIKE WAS A FRINGE
BALL THAT WAS CALLED A STRIKE ON
A 2-0 COUNT.
EIGHT BALLS AND SIX STRIKES THIS
INNING.
BIG PAYOFF PITCH COMING OUT TO
EIGHT HITTER JON BERTI.
LEON AND DIAZ ON.
3-2.
>> NOT SO SURE ABOUT THAT.
THAT FASTBALL WAS CALLED FOR A
STRIKE.
LOOKS LIKE JOE GIRARDI IS GOING
TO SUAREZ.
>> I'M WITH YOU.
I THINK WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY
STRUGGLING, THE EASIEST PITCH
FOR HIM IS TO THROW THE
FASTBALL.
THE FEELING MUST STILL BE THERE.
AND THE CONFIDENCE WITH THE
CHANGEUP HASN'T BEEN THERE.
>> HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THREE
MARLINS ON BOARD.
IN COMES RANGER SUAREZ.
>> THE PHILLIES ARE ONE OUT AWAY
FROM WINNING THE WORLD SERIES.
>> I REMEMBER HEARING A LITTLE
BIT OF THE CROWD.
THAT WAS A PRETTY SPECIAL MOMENT
AND IT WAS PRETTY LOUD.
ABSORB THE ENERGY AND
ELECTRICITY.
>> BRAD HAS BEEN PERFECT ALL
YEAR LONG.
HE THROWS A DEVASTATING SLIDER.
>> THAT'S WHEN REALITY SET IN.
>> I'M THINKING TO MYSELF, THROW
THE BEST SLIDER YOU'VE GOT.
>> WORLD CHAMPIONS OF BASEBALL.
>> I SPRINTED AS FAST AS I
COULD.
WHEN THEY WENT DOWN TO THEIR
KNEES I TOLD THEM I'M TAKING
THEM BOTH OUT.
>> YOU'RE WATCHING THE ML BECAME
OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
I YOUTUBE ORIGINAL SERIES THAT
PRESENTS TIME EQUAL -- TIMELY
QUESTIONS ON THE IMPACT OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM.
HEAD OVER TO YOUTUBE AND JUST
SEARCHED GLAD YOU ASKED ONLY ON
YOUTUBE.
>> ANOTHER SHOT OF CLIFF'S
BACKYARD.
CLIFF: EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE
YOU'VE GOT TO DO THAT.
>> THIS IS RANGER SUAREZ TAKING
OVER AND HE'S BEEN EXCELLENT
THIS SEASON BUT THIS IS NOT A
FUN SPOT FOR HIM.
>> PHILLIES ASSIGNED HIM OUT OF
VENEZUELA.
WOULD YOU BE TEMPTED AT ALL AS A
MANAGER THE PENSION THIS EARLY
IN A GAME?
>> IT DEPENDS ON DON MATTINGLY.
THEY HAD TO EMPTY OUT THE
BULLPEN A COUPLE TIMES.
THE PHILLIES MIGHT BE WORKING
WITH JUST A TWO MAN BENCH TODAY.
IF THERE IS SUCH A THING AS AN
IDEAL SPOT TO BE BROUGHT IN AS A
RELIEVER WITH THE BASES LOADED.
HAVE THE LEFTY ON LEFTY
SITUATION.
JESUS AGUILAR SITTING TODAY
COULD HAVE BEEN A PINCH-HITTING
OPTION.
>> HE'S INNING READY.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF THEY DID
THAT.
THIS COULD BE A POTENTIAL LEFT
LEFT SITUATION.
HE MADE PINCH FOR SIERRA.
LOPEZ STRIKES OUT.
THAT'S A BIG FIRST OUT FOR
RANGER SUAREZ.
TREVOR ROGERS PINCH-HIT AS THEY
WERE SAVING UP THE BENCH.
GARRETT COOPER IS OUT EVEN
THOUGH HE'S NOT ON THE I.L..
SAME WITH JAZZ CHISHOLM WHO
ROLLED HIS ANKLE.
>> IT'S A SPOT RIGHT HERE FOR
SUAREZ.
LIVES AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
STRIKE ZONE.
MOVES THE BALL UP DOWN IN AND
OUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE BIG FELLA
DOESN'T DO ALL THAT WELL IS RUN.
HE CAN DO SOMETHING TO HIT ON
THE GROUND, IT WOULD GIVE THE
PHILLIES TO TURNING A DOUBLE
PLAY AND GET OUT OF TROUBLE.
>> THE ONE THING HE HAS DONE
WELL HAS BEEN -- THE MACHINE FOR
THE MARLINS TEAM THIS YEAR.
>> 36 OF THEM ON THE YEAR.
TOP THREE IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE.
BASES-LOADED.
FIRST PITCH MISSES DOWNSTAIRS.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS YOU LOOK
AT THE R.B.I. LEADERS IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE JUST A VETERAN
PRESENTS THAT HE AND DUVALL
BRING TO THIS YOUNG MARLINS
TEAM.
THEIR STARTING PITCHING IS GOING
TO KEEP THEM AROUND FOR A WHILE.
THEY'RE ONLY A GAME AND A HALF
OUT OF FIRST.
>> AGUILAR WAS A SAVVY PICKUP
LAST YEAR BY MIAMI.
HE WAS A LATE BLOOMER.
35 HOMERS, 108 R.B.I.'S AND SOME
SERIOUS DAMAGE WITH THE BASES
LOADED IN HIS CAREER.
DOWN 2019.
POUNCED BACK FROM MIAMI.
2-1.
SUAREZ BEING AWFUL CAREFUL WITH
THE BIG FELLOW HERE.
SUAREZ IS NOT AFRAID OF THE BIG
MOMENT.
HE CAN MOVE THE BALL IN AN OUT.
HE'S NOT RELYING ON ONE PITCH.
HAS A REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP THAT
HE WILL MIX IN.
TO THE LEFT SIDE AND THAT IS
FAIR BALL.
COULDN'T SEE THE HUMP ON THE
LEFT SIDE THERE.
>> PRETTY GOOD PITCH.
2-1 CHANGEUP HAD AGUILAR OUT
FRONT.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A DOUBLE PLAY
-- AN INNING ENDING DOUBLE PLAY.
>> RIGHT INSTINCTS BY ALEC BOHM.
TO TOUCH THIRD BASE AND KNOW
WHO'S RUNNING, NOT LOOK BACK AT
THE UMPIRE, BUT JUST GRAB IT,
TOUCH THIRD BASE AND KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO
BEFORE THE BALL GETS TO HIM.
STEP ON THIRD, NOT TRY TO GO
HOME.
NOT TRY TO DO ANYTHING CRAZY.
>> AGUILAR LIFTS IT TO CENTER.
IT'S CUT OFF, THROW TO THIRD IS
IN TIME.
RUN CAME ACROSS FIRST.
THE MARLINS GET ONE AND THAT
WILL SIT DOWN THE SIDE.
RANGER SUAREZ ENTERS THIS GAME,
BASES.
NOBODY OUT.
AND ALLOWS JUST.
>> THIS WAS A HEADS UP PLAY
RIGHT HERE.
HE HITS THE CUT OFF AND RHYS
HOSKINS DELIVERS A STRIKE.
>> ONE FOR THE MARLINS.
THEY TRAIL BY A RUN ON YOUTUBE.
>> HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> RILEY HURTS THIS ONE TO RIGHT
FIELD.
HE THEN FALLS DOWN.
>> HIT LEAVE RIGHT OFF THE
BRICKS.
>> 1-1.
>> DAVID BOTE WAS TRYING TO GIVE
HIM A HEADS UP.
CHRIS CONROY JUST DIDN'T EXPECT
COME AT HIM.
>> JUST DON'T STRESS ANY OF THE
LIGAMENTS.
>> HE'S TRYING.
>> HE'S BEEN FLIPPING IT OVER.
FINISHING THE JOB.
>> OFF AGAIN, TATIS.
INTO A SPLIT.
>> THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S LIKE THE FLOOR EXERCISES IN
THE OLYMPICS.
>> RHYS HOSKINS -- HAS BEEN
FRONT AND CENTER.
HERRERA REDS DOES A GREAT JOB OF
GETTING MOMENTUM.
RHYS HOSKINS CUTS IT IN A HEADS
UP PLAY.
HE'S TAKING A PEEK AT THE RUNNER
AND THIRD HE GOES AND GETS IT.
HEADS UP PLAY.
>> NICE JOB TO GET ISAN DIAZ.
THE RUN DID COME ACROSS FIRST SO
THE SAC FLY FOR PINCH HITTER
JESUS AGUILAR.
THAT ONE IS STRUCK TO CENTER.
NEWLY PUT IN CENTER FIELD.
JON BERTI FROM THIRD.
OUT DEEP AT THE TRACK TO MAKE
THE CATCH.
BRAD MILLER GAVE THAT BASEBALL A
RIDE.
BERTI IS IN CENTER.
ISAN DIAZ MOVES TO THE HOT
CORNER.
JOSE DEVERS ENTERS THE GAME
AFTER A REALLY SOLID DAY
YESTERDAY.
>> THE NAME SOUNDS FAMILIAR.
BECAUSE AND I BELIEVE TO RAFAEL
DEVERS.
THE THIRD BASEMEN THE RED SOX.
>> WAS A DEVERS PICKED UP FROM
THE NEW YORK YANKEES.
JOSE KEEPS IN VERY CLOSE TOUCH
WITH RAFAEL AND THE MARLINS ARE
HEADED UP TO BOSTON TO TAKE ON
THE RED SOX SO JOSE IS GOING TO
BE TREATED TO SOME NICE DINNERS
UP THERE.
>> HOW ABOUT HIS LAST AT.
TOOK A FASTBALL UP AND IN FROM
PABLO LOPEZ.
A COUPLE OF PITCHES LATER.
THE GREAT PLAY TO GET THE
PHILLIES OUT OF TROUBLE IN THE
FIFTH.
>> TWO STRIKES ON HOSKINS.
HE'S MIGHT UP ON YOUTUBE.
>> JESUS.
THAT HAPPENS ONCE A GAME.
>> WE HAD TO BE ABOUT SOMETHING.
>> THAT'S A FIRST-CLASS
TURNAROUND FROM THE SUPERSTAR
PRODUCTION TEAM TO GIVE US THE
RHYS HOSKINS REACTION AND HIS
11TH HOMER OF THE SEASON BACK IN
THE FOURTH.
THAT WAS AWESOME.
>> IT'S BEEN SUCH AN UP-AND-DOWN
SEASON FOR THE POLICE.
THAT HAD SOME DISAPPOINTMENTS
WITH THE BULL PEN THAT REALLY
LET THEM DOWN.
THAT 60 GAME ABBREVIATED SPRINT.
I REALLY BELIEVED THEY WERE A
PLAYOFF TEAM LAST YEAR.
THE BULLPEN TOOK THEM OUT OF
SEVERAL GAMES.
THEY'VE HAD SOME ISSUES IN THE
EIGHTH AND NINTH INNING.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE TALKED
ABOUT, THEY HAVE WILL HAVE TO
CLEAN UP DEFENSIVELY.
LAST NIGHT THERE WAS A DOUBLE
THAT WASN'T TURNED.
IT'S HARD TO EXPECT BRAD MILLER
WHO'S NOT THE EVERYDAY THIRD
BASEMAN.
LED TO A BIG INNING FOR THE
FISH.
>> GOOD TAKE.
>> RHYS HOSKINS, PHILADELPHIA IS
24-26 ON THE YEAR.
CURRENTLY SITTING IN FOURTH
PLACE.
>> THE METS ARE LEADING THE
DIVISION RIGHT NOW.
NOAH SYNDERGAARD IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE SHUT DOWN FOR A FEW
WEEKS.
THEY WERE HOPING TO HAVE HIM
BACK.
FRANCISCO LINDOR HAS GOTTEN OFF
TO A ROUGH START.
JACOB DEGROM WAS AWFULLY GOOD
FIVE INNINGS.
THIS N.L. EAST IS SHAPING UP TO
BE QUITE A DIVISION DOWN THE
STRETCH.
THE MARLINS HAVE HAD TWO.
HOW ABOUT THAT PLAY?
>> STEPS ON THE BAG AND THEY
DOUBLE UP THE PHILLIES TO END
THE INNING.
>> YOU GET CALLED UP TODAY, YOU
SHOW OFF THE GLOVE WORK.
>> HE WAS READY.
>> THINK FAST.
>> NOTHING HOSKINS CAN DO.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE.
>> OVER TOWARD THIRD.
HARPER SCORES EASILY.
JEAN SEGURA WAS A MAN ON A
MISSION IN THE MISSION WAS
VICTORY.
LET THE SEASON BEGIN.
>> DEEP TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
FORGET ABOUT THAT ONE.
ECHOES RIGHT DOWN THE STAIRWELL.
THAT WAS SMOKED AND IT HAD SOME
DISTANCE ON IT.
IT'S 2-0 PHILLIES.
>> THAT MAY BE ONE OF THE
FURTHEST HOME RUNS I'VE EVER
SEEN HIT THERE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THEM.
>> FIRST PITCH SWINGING.
HAMMERS IT TO LEFT.
HOME RUN NUMBER 100 FOR RHYS.
FINALLY ALMOST A MONTH STUCK ON
99 AND HOSKINS'S SELLS THOSE
SHOTS.
>> FOR YOU YOU LIVE THERE.
>> I DON'T SEE THAT AREA.
>> I NEED TO TAKE YOU INTO MY
HELICOPTER MORE OFTEN.
>> WHEN YOU ARE THERE, DO YOU
FEEL SORRY FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE
MIDWEST AND NORTHEAST?
>> I DO.
WHY ARE YOU ALL UP THERE?
COME ON DOWN.
>> I'M IN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ASK ME TWICE.
>> ROJAS LIVES IN MIAMI YEAR
ROUND.
RANGER SUAREZ ASKED TO WORK.
>> TALK ABOUT THE PHILLIES.
THEY'VE HAD TO GO TO THAT
BULLPEN A LOT.
17 ONE RUN GAMES.
SO JOE GIRARDI KNOWS THIS ONE'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE ANOTHER ONE
OF THOSE NIGHT -- WHITE
KNUCKLERS.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> ZOOM IN.
>> HE'S JUST CHILLING.
>> THAT'S A GREAT VIEW.
>> VERY CALM OUT THERE.
>> THAT'S JON BERTI OUT THERE,
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
NEXT HAPPENING.
BERNIE IS PLAYING CENTER NOW FOR
MIAMI.
THIS PHILLY BULLPEN WAS SO BAD
LAST YEAR.
IT WAS THE SECOND-HIGHEST
RELIEVER E.R.A. IN BASEBALL
HISTORY.
>> I MADE MY LIVING PITCHING OUT
OF THE BULLPEN.
YOU NEED TO HAVE TWO GUYS.
AND SOMEBODY THAT CAN BE YOUR
TROUBLESHOOTER THAT YOU GO TO IN
THE SEVENTH OR EIGHTH INNING
WITH TRAFFIC, GUYS ON BASE.
THAT'S GOING TO GET PAST MILLER
AT SECOND.
MIGUEL ROJAS WITH THE BASE HIT
TO START THE BOTTOM OF THE SIX.
>> MULTIPLE RELIEVERS, THE
PHILLIES AREN'T THE ONLY TEAM
HAVING TO GO THROUGH THAT.
IT'S TOUGH.
STARTING PITCHERS ARE GOING NOT
AS DEEP IN THE GAME.
RIGHT BY SUAREZ AND MILLER.
>> I JUST THINK THE BULLPEN AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE DEFENSE, THEY GO
HAND-IN-HAND WITH THE PRESSURE
OF PLAYING THE DEFENSE.
IN PLAYING THE WAY THAT THESE
GUYS KNOW THEY CAN PLAY.
DIDI GREGORIUS HAS SIX OR SEVEN
ERRORS THIS YEAR.
A LOT OF IT IS MORE OF THEM
PUTTING THE PRESSURE ON
THEMSELVES TO MAKE THE ROUTINE
PLAYS IT LEADS TO A LOT OF
MISHAPS.
EVEN THAT GUY RIGHT THERE HAD A
LITTLE RUN IN THIS YEAR.
IT'S JUST A LITTLE TOO MUCH FOR
TEAM TRYING TO STAY IN THE TOUGH
N.L. EAST DIVISION.
>> JOE GIRARDI HAS BEEN KNOWN OF
HANDLING AND MANEUVERING A
BULLPEN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE PHILLIES
HAVE THAT IS GOING TO BENEFIT
THEM IN THE LONG RUN, THEY CAN
EAT UP SOME INNINGS.
AT LEAST A COUPLE OF DAYS.
JOE GIRARDI, STAFF, THEY FEEL
CONFIDENT THEY CAN RUN INTO THE
EIGHTH.
ZACK WHEELER, A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
BASEBALL WERE SURPRISED AT THE
CONTRACT.
HE HAS LIVED UP TO EVERY BIT OF
THAT CONTRACT.
THERE'S THREE REALLY GOOD
PITCHERS BACK TO BACK TO BACK.
I THINK THE BULLPEN EVENTUALLY
WILL TAKE CARE OF ITSELF.
THIS YOUNG GUY SUAREZ, HE CAN
MOVE UP IN THE PECKING ORDER.
>> GETS THE RATE LEAD RUNNER AT
SECOND.
HE WAS BACKING UP TOWARDS THE
LINE.
>> THAT'S A TOUGH PLAY FOR A
LEFTY.
THAT BALL IS TAKING YOU AWAY
FROM THE MOUND AND YOU HAVE TO
THROW.
HE HAS A LOWER THREE-QUARTER ARM
ANGLE.
WATCH HIM GET TO IT RIGHT HERE.
NOT AN EASY PLAY.
DOES A GOOD JOB OF GETTING HIS
BODY TURNED SO HE DOESN'T HAVE
TO MAKE A COMPLETE WHEEL AROUND.
PRETTY NICE PLAY.
>> NOW DICKERSON IS THE BASE
RUNNER AT FIRST.
ROJAS ERASED.
CLETO PENNER ADAM DUVALL.
>> I THINK ANOTHER THING THAT
PUTS SUAREZ INTO PLAY IS HIS
ABILITY TO THROW MULTIPLE
PITCHES.
IF YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI, YOU
HONOR THAT NOT AFRAID TO RUN HIM
OUT THERE IN SITUATIONS OR HE
CAN FACE MORE HITTERS.
HE HAS A GROUND BALL PITCH IF HE
NEEDS ONE.
THIS THREE BATTER MINIMUM, HE
VERY RARELY SEE LEFT-HANDED
SPECIALISTS THROUGHOUT BASEBALL
ANYMORE.
YOU'LL HAVE TO LEAVE HIM OUT
THERE FOR MULTIPLE HITTERS.
THIS WAS A GREAT SPOT FOR
GIRARDI.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET LOPEZ THE
LAST INNING.
SAC FLY.
DOUBLE PLAY IN THAT POP UP.
REALLY GREAT TOP FOR JOE
GIRARDI.
>> HOMER AGAINST THE PHILLIES
RELIEVER.
>> FIVE K'S AGAINST THAT PITCH
ENTERING TODAY.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD PITCH THAT
SETS UP THAT STRAIGHT CHANGEUP.
SIMILAR TO THAT BAT AGAINST
JESUS AGUILAR.
THAT FOUL BALL THAT WENT OVER
THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
NEXT PITCH WAS HIT FOR THE SAC
FLY.
THERE IS, HE PULLS THE STRENGTH.
REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP.
WHAT SET THAT UP WAS THE 93
FASTBALL THAT WAS IN THE
PREVIOUS PITCH.
YOU HAVE TO THINK IF YOU ARE
DUVALL -- REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP
THERE.
>> TWO OUTS, ONE ON FOR MIAMI.
LET'S FINISH UP WITH OUR LAST
POLL QUESTION.
WHICH PLAYER HAS THE MOST
SWAGGER IN THE GAME RIGHT NOW?
JAZZ CHISHOLM.
HOW ABOUT THAT THING WITH THAT
BIG NECKLACE THAT THEY WEAR?
THAT'S THE KING OF PLAYING RIGHT
THERE.
>> MANNY MACHADO, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT TATIS, HE'S BRING IT.
JAZZ CHISHOLM, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU GUYS HAVE SEEN THE SWAG THIS
KID RINGS TO THE TABLE EVERY
NIGHT.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
HE'S RIGHT THERE.
THEY'RE ALL ROCKING THE CUBAN
LINKS.
HE HAS ABOUT THREE OR FOUR.
HE LOOKS LIKE MR. T ONCE IN A
WHILE.
SOME SWAG GOING ON IN THIS GAME.
YOU GUYS KNOW I LOVE IT.
>> THE SWAG CHAIN IS WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> IT WAS MADE BY GABRIEL THE
JEWELER WHO MADE THE TURNOVER
CHANGE.
PADRES GIVE IT TO A PLAYER WHO
HOMERS.
>> LET ME ASK YOU, YOU THINK IT
IS SEES HE OR REAL DIAMONDS?
>> I THINK THEY ARE BOTH REAL.
>> I RECEIVED ON OFFICIAL WORD
ON THE PRICE.
I CAN'T SHARE IT APPARENTLY.
I WAS NOT GIVEN FROM MY SOURCE
PERMISSION.
>> THAT THING BETTER BE LOCKED
UP.
>> RANGER SUAREZ
>> DIAZ WITH THE DRIVE, RIGHT
CENTER FIELD.
IT IS GONE.
A GRAND SLAM.
HE HAS FOUND THAT STROKE.
I COULD NOT BE HAPPIER FOR THIS
YOUNG MAN.
SMOKES THIS ONE INTO LEFT FIELD.
AND JORGE ALFARO IS THE HERO
TONIGHT.
>> ANYTHING IN THE GAP REALLY
WOULD GIVE ANDERSON THE
ADVANTAGE.
>> FLY BALL OUT TO DEEP CENTER
FIELD.
>> WE'VE BEEN TALKING SWAGGER
THE ENTIRE BREAK BETWEEN
INNINGS.
RONALD ACUNA HAS GOT IT.
FERNANDO TATIS.
>> THERE IT IS RIGHT THERE.
>> THEY GOT THE LITTLE EUROSTAT
GOING.
I'M TELLING YOU, WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
I DIDN'T QUESTION IF IT WAS REAL
DIAMONDS.
THAT'S A LOT GOING ON AND THAT'S
REAL.
YOU HAVE $640 MILLION ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE DIAMOND AS FAR
AS MANNY MACHADO AND TATIS.
I'M SAYING IF YOU ARE SAYING
THAT'S REAL, THAT'S A LITTLE
IFFY BECAUSE THAT'S COLLEGE.
THAT'S ALL I WAS SAYING.
>> IT'S PROBABLY A BOOSTER THAT
SETS THAT UP.
CHRISTINA KNOWS THAT WELL.
>> IF ANYONE IS GOING TO KNOW
SWAGGER IT'S YOU AND ME BECAUSE
YOU INVENTED IT.
>> EARLIER IN THE SEASON HE
WARNED US THAT THERE AIN'T A
SWAG YOUR TEAM THAN THE MARLINS
AND HE REITERATED THAT WHEN THEY
WORE THEIR UNIFORMS WHICH WERE
SELLING LIKE HOT CAKES.
>> THOSE UNIFORMS ARE AWESOME.
>> I HAVE HEARD HIM SAY MY
BIGGEST FEAR IS NOT MAKING THE
HALL OF FAME.
HE'S A ROOKIE, HE'S GOT
CONFIDENCE.
HE'S GOT STYLE THE POLL IS UP
RIGHT NOW SO LET US KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS, BUT A CLICK FOR VERY
SOLID OPTIONS.
>> IT SHOULD BE REALLY CLOSE.
>> HE HAS SOME BLING, BUT HE CAN
ALSO HIT A HEATER.
HE HAS HIT TWO 100 MILE AN HOUR
FASTBALLS OUT.
JOSE ALVARADO OF THE PHILLIES.
>> HE'S BEEN A STUD AND HE'S
MISSING TIME.
THREE PITCHES.
MATT JOYCE IS PUT AWAY BY PABLO
LOPEZ.
>> THERE WAS THAT GREAT
CHANGEUP.
>> PABLO HAS PITCHED REALLY
WELL.
>> THAT'S DIRTY RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT'S A SPECIAL PITCH.
HE USES IT MORE AND MORE IN THE
BIGS.
THERE'S SOME HEAT TO RONALD
TORREYES.
IF HE GETS THROUGH THIS BATTER,
YOU MIGHT AS WELL LET HIM GO
PITCH TO THE, TWO.
HIS STUFF LOOKS BETTER THAN EVER
RIGHT NOW.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE FASTBALL
CHANGEUP.
THAT WAS THE SLIDER RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S WHY THE MARLINS ONE
DEFENDER ON THE RIGHT SIDE
THERE.
>> AS WE CONTACT GROUND BALLS.
STRIKEOUTS ON THEHE IS ROLLING .
MARLINS LOOKING FOR SOME OFFENSE
AGAINST THE PHILLIES BULLPEN.
LET'S STRETCH.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON HERE RIGHT
NOW?
>> I LOVE MY WIFE.
>> CAN'T WAIT FOR MOTHER'S DAY.
>> 2:00.
-- NO RAIN.
>> THE YELLOW LINE NEEDS TO BE
BELOW THAT.
>> STEP UP TO THE PLATE,
COMPLETE -- COMPETE ONLINE AND
CRUSHED FINGERS.
>> I WANT TO PLAY AS CLIFF FLOYD
IN THAT GAME.
SIX AND A HALF.
THIS IS A 2-1 CONTEST.
PABLO LOPEZ PITCHES SO WELL IN
THIS PARK.
SPENCER HOWARD WAS GOOD.
RANGER SUAREZ TO THE RESCUE FOR
THE PHILLIES.
THAT'S WHY THE UNDERS LOOKING
STRONG.
>> TWO SCORELESS INNINGS SO FAR.
JOE GIRARDI DID A MASTERFUL JOB
OF MATCHING THEM UP, BRING THEM
IN THE GAME.
>> I GUESS THAT'S IT FOR PABLO
LOPEZ.
BASED ON THE ART TEST.
THERE'S HOGS COMING, I PROMISE.
THERE YOU GO.
AT LEAST THE HANDSHAKE.
HE PROBABLY WANTS ONE MORE.
HE'S LIKE, THAT YOU SEE ME IN
THE SEVENTH?
THAT'S MY BEST INNING.
LEON TO CENTER.
THAT'S HANGING UP FOR HERRERA.
HE'S THERE.
>> GREAT CLOSING SPEED, CLIFF
FLOYD.
LOOKS LIKE HE SLOWLY BUT SURELY
ROUNDING BACK IN THE FOURTH.
>> CC THAT CONCENTRATION IN THAT
SAME GETTING A GOOD JUMP,
UNDERSTANDING WHERE HE'S AT.
WHEN THESE GAMES ARE CLOSE LIKE
THAT, YOU CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE
ANY BASE RUNNERS.
>> HE ABSOLUTELY ROCK ISAN DIAZ
YESTERDAY.
HE CLIMBED THAT TALL CENTER
FIELD WALL, TIMED IT PERFECTLY.
TWO FREE TICKETS TODAY FOR DIAZ.
SOLID CONTACT THE OTHER WAY AND
THAT HANGS UP LONG ENOUGH FOR
QUINN.
GREAT CLOSING SPEED AGAIN.
A CENTER FIELDER PLAYING LEFT
AND IT PLAYS OFF.
>> QUINN DOES A GREAT JOB.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN YOU HAVE A
LEFT ON LEFT SITUATION, HE IS
PLAYING IT MORE SHALLOW.
IT CAN BE RISKY PLAY IF THE BALL
GETS BY.
IT'S AT LEAST TWO AND PROBABLY
THREE IF DIAZ RUNS.
>> BIGGEST DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE PHILLIES TODAY AND YESTERDAY
AND FOR MUCH OF THE SEASON,
DEFENSE.
>> THOSE PLAYERS, YOU CAN'T
TEACH INSTINCT.
'S PLAYERS WERE INSTINCTIVE
DECISIONS MADE OFF THE JUMP
THAT'S A TRIPLE AND MEN ON THIRD
WITH A CHANCE TO TIE THE GAME
UP.
>> ANOTHER STAT TO MEASURE
DEFENSE.
SOME SOLID GLOVES IN THE
OUTFIELD.
IT'S BEEN MORE ON THE INFIELD
SIDE.
YOU'VE GOT TO SEPARATE THE
SLUMPING AT YOUR PLATE.
WITH YOUR DEFENSE OF PLAY.
>> WITH ALEX IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE YOU RUN INTO THE
SOPHOMORE SLUMP IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT IT THAT WAY OR WHATEVER.
FOR ME IT IS PAY ATTENTION TO
DETAIL.
THE BALL IS COMING TO ME.
ALL THOSE LITTLE THINGS, BUT THE
WORK IS FIRST.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO JUST LIVE
WITH THE MISTAKES.
>> WHAT A JOB SO FAR BY RANGER
SUAREZ.
HE'S NOT THE RANGER.
HE'S GOING TO BE THE LIEUTENANT
AFTER THIS ONE.
>> PROMOTE THE MAN.
>> LET ME TAKE YOU BACK IN CASE
YOU MISSED YESTERDAY'S CATCH.
DIAZ WAS KIND OF ROBBED IT JUST
NOW, BUT THIS WAS FULL ON HOME
RUN ROBBERY.
GLOVE OVER THE WALL AND THAT'S A
TALL WALL.
>> LOOK WHERE HE'S AT TO MAKE
THAT PLAY.
DEVON WHITE.
DO YOU KNOW DEVON WHITE?
YOU'VE SEEN HIM IN ACTION.
HE USED TO RUN TO THE SPOT.
>> TO REYES TO THE RIGHT SPOT ON
THE GROUND BALL AND RANGER
SUAREZ, YOU ARE OFFICIALLY
PROMOTED.
HE IS THE LIEUTENANT.
>> EVERYWHERE YOU GO IN MIAMI,
THERE IS SOMEONE PLAYING THE
GAME.
CULTURE IS RIDDLED WITH BASEBALL
STORIES AND MOMENTS.
>> MARLINS ARE PART OF MIAMI.
IT MEANS CULTURE AND PRIDE IN
OUR CITY.
>> VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/MARLINS TO
FOLLOW THE TEAM TODAY.
>> NO TRAFFIC TODAY.
THAT'S NICE.
CRUISING THROUGH MIAMI.
WHICH PLAYER HAS THE MOST
SWAGGER IN THE GAME RIGHT NOW?
YOUR WINNER, FERNANDO TATIS JR..
HE STARTING TO MAKE A NATIONAL
NAME FOR HIMSELF AND BAEZ
CLARKSON IN THE FOURTH SPOT.
-- CLOCK SEE IN IN THE FOURTH
SPOT -- CLOCK'S IN IN THE FOURTH
SPOT.
>> BAEZ NEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE
LOVE.
I'M SORRY.
>> IT WAS A TOUGH QUESTION.
>> BAEZ IS TONING DOWN A LITTLE
BIT.
HE IS STILL SWAG HE, MAN.
>> LA TORTUGA, ONE OF DAN'S
FAVORITES.
>> WE'VE GOT A NEW PITCHER.
DYLAN FLORO IN FOR THE MARLINS.
FIVE PUNCH-OUTS.
92 PITCHES, 61 FOR STRIKES, 18
FOR 25 FIRST PITCH STRIKE ZONE.
IT'S UP TO DYLAN FLORO TO KEEP
THE PHILLIES AT BAY.
>> THAT'S RAFAEL MARCHAN.
BASE HIT IN THE THIRD.
ONLY ALLOWED ONE RUN ALL OF
2021.
A COUPLE OF THINGS YOU WANT TO
DO COMING OUT OF THE BULLPEN.
HE'S DONE A GREAT JOB OF BOTH.
>> CHRISTINA, IT SEEMS LIKE THE
MARLINS BULLPEN IS REALLY
SETTLING ITSELF INTO SOME NICE
ROLES AT THIS POINT.
>> EXACTLY.
WHEN KIM NG TOOK OVER AS GENERAL
MANAGER, SHE MADE IT HER SEASON
PRIORITY TO UPGRADE.
DYLAN FLORO WAS ONE OF THOSE BIG
ADDITIONS.
SINCE ANTHONY BASS WAS TAKEN OUT
OF THE CLOSER'S ROLE AND YIMI
GARCIA TOOK OVER, THE BULLPEN
HAS THE FIFTH BEST E.R.A. IN THE
MAJORS.
>> THE MARLINS ON THE BOARD IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
>> I THINK A LOT OF THAT AS I
SEE IT IS ROLES ARE DEFINED IN
DON MATTINGLY HAS GARCIA, I
THINK HE HAS NINE SAVES ON THE
SEASON.
SO EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THE
ROLES DOWN THERE.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, THINGS
GET THROWN AROUND.
FOR THE MOST PART THESE GUYS
KNOW WHEN TO GET READY.
I KNOW YOU CAN SPEAK TO HOW HUGE
THAT IS.
>> A HOT SHOT GETS PAST DEVERS.
THE BALL SKIPS AWAY.
MARSH ON HEADING TO SECOND.
TWO MISCUES.
TROUBLE IN THE OUTFIELD TURNS
INTO AN EXTRA-BASE.
>> THIS BALL GETS BY AT SECOND
BASE.
HE'S GOT TO HANG OUT AND RIGHT
FIELD.
>> YOU ARE NOT LYING.
HE'S STILL THERE.
>> HE DIDN'T MOVE.
HE'S LIKE, I'M NOT MOVING.
I PAID FOR THIS SEAT.
>> THAT'S AMAZING.
SO BASE HIT AND THEN NINE ON
DUVALL.
UNFAZED.
>> SOMEBODY RIGHT FIELDER WITH
THE SUNFLOWER SEED.
GET A FRESH -- FRESH BATCH OF
SUNFLOWER SEEDS.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO TURN
THIS INTO SOME INSURANCE.
>> IT'S EITHER ADAM DUVALL OR
MATT JOYCE.
HELPING THAT BERNIE OUT AND
RIGHT FIELD.
>> TO FALL ON THE MARLINS SIDE
HAS BEEN STATISTICALLY ONE OF
THE BEST DEFENDERS IN THE SPORT
THIS YEAR.
>> IF YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI, THIS
IS NOT A WELL-MANAGED GAME.
YOU HAVE AN IDEAL SPOT, SUAREZ
JUST PITCHED THREE TERRIFIC
INNINGS.
SEGURA ON THE BENCH MAKES IT
EASIER.
THAT PITCHER SLOT COMES UP.
>> THERE IS A LOOK AT BIRD IN
THE BUEHRLE.
YOU GET TWO-FOR-ONE.
ON THURSDAY IN MIAMI.
>> SEGURA AVOIDS IT.
LIVE GAME COMMENTARY WITH A NOTE
THAT THE PIGEONS ARE OUT OF
CONTROL.
IT'S BAD ENOUGH WHAT THEY DO TO
OUR CARS.
TRUE STORY.
MARCHAND AND SCORING POSITION
AND JEAN FOULS IT BACK.
-- IN SCORING POSITION AND JEAN
FOULS IT BACK.
ONE OF THE ADDITIONS TO THIS
MARLINS BULLPEN COMING UP BIG
LIKELY -- LATELY.
>> THEY CAN ATTENDS -- ATTEST TO
WHAT YOU GO THROUGH DURING A
SEASON.
NOBODY IN BASEBALL KNEW WHAT TO
EXPECT.
THERE WERE VIRTUALLY NO MINOR
LEAGUES, SO YOU REALLY DON'T
HAVE A HANDLE ON WHAT YOUR DEPTH
CHART IS GOING TO BE.
I THINK IT'S A CONCERN OF EVERY
GENERAL MANAGER.
LOOK AT JEAN SEGURA TURNING THAT
ONE AROUND.
>> RIPS IT FOUL.
>> THEY WORRY ABOUT NOT ONLY
THEIR STARTING PITCHING, BUT THE
BULLPEN.
TWO OR THREE RELIEVERS EVERY
NIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO BE SURVIVAL OF THE
FITTEST.
CAN YOU DEVELOP FRESH ARMS, CAN
YOU SIGN FRESH ARMS.
PART OF BASEBALL IN 2021.
>> AS FAR AS THE YOUTH OF IT IN
THE GUIDE BACK.
THAT IS KEY.
FOR KIM NG AND DON MATTINGLY.
JUST UNDERSTANDING HOW MANY
STARTS ARE YOU GOING TO GET FROM
TREVOR ROGERS OR PABLO.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT THESE GUYS
FROM THEMSELVES.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT UPGRADING
YOUR BULLPEN.
THE KIND OF ACQUISITION THAT YOU
GET, MAYBE SKIP A START OR TWO
FOR THESE YOUNGSTERS.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN TERRIFIC.
>> A ROUTINE DAY OFF OUT OF THE
STARTING LINEUP.
>> BEST RECORD IN BASEBALL, THE
SAN DIEGO PADRES.
OTHER COUPLE OF REALLY GOOD
BULLPENS, THE CLEVELAND INDIANS.
FIVE GAMES OVER 500.
AND THE CUBS.
CRAIG KIMBREL IS BACK.
THE CUBS BULLPEN DEEP RIGHT NOW.
REMEMBER THE NAME KEEGAN
THOMPSON.
THROWING THE BALL REALLY WELL
OUT OF THE BULLPEN.
>> DIAZ PUTS AWAY SEGURA FOR OUT
NUMBER ONE.
NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK,
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING ON A MOBILE
DEVICE OR COMPUTER, YOU ARE
GOING TO VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER
WILL RECEIVE THIS TROPHY DURING
THE POSTGAME SHOW.
WE WILL HAVE THE POLE OPTIONS
COMING SOON ON YOUTUBE AND IF
YOU CAUGHT ANY OF OUR BROADCASTS
FROM EARLIER THIS SEASON, THE
PLAYERS LOVE THE TROPHY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT DOES, BUT
THE NAME GETS ENGRAVED ON THE
TROPHY.
REGULAR SEASON IS 162 GAMES.
PLAYERS ARE SUPER COMPETITIVE.
THEY ARE LOVING THE TROPHY.
>> WE ARE NOT REALLY SUPPOSED TO
INFLUENCE THE VOTERS.
GOING TO CAST MY VOTE A LITTLE
EARLY FOR THE LIEUTENANT IF THIS
HOLDS UP.
RANGER SUAREZ.
>> NO HOSKINS, NO HOWARD.
YOU'RE GOING SUAREZ.
>> ONLY ONE SCORES.
THREE SCORELESS INNINGS.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR POSITION WHEN
YOU PLAYED?
>> RELIEVER.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE EXCUSES
FOR IT.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
IF YOU HAVE A BAD BULLPEN, IT
STICKS OUT LIKE A SORE THROWN.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY OTHER TEAM
IN BASEBALL HAS A GOOD BULLPEN
BUT YEARS.
IT'S TOUGH IN THE DAY AND AGE
WHERE YOU ARE RUNNING RELIEVERS
OUT THERE.
IN A PERFECT WORLD YOU WOULD
THINK, WE HAVE THE LEAD.
LET'S JUST RUN GUYS OUT THERE.
IT'S HARD TO RUN GUYS THAT ARE
ALL ON.
WANT ME TO GO TO MATCH UPS IN MY
SEVENTH AND EIGHTH INNING, IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK OUT THAT
WAY.
>> IT'S A GOOD CHOICE.
AND OF COURSE PLEASE NOT GOING
FOR THE RELIEVER.
SUAREZ WAS BRINGING IT TODAY.
>> HE'S NOT THE RANGER, HE'S THE
LIEUTENANT.
>> I'M JUST THROWING ONE OUT
THERE.
>> QUINN DID NOT GO AROUND
ACCORDING TO SAM HOLBROOK.
SO WE HAVE A FULL COUNT TO ROMAN
QUINN.
MARSH IS STILL AT SECOND BASE.
QUINN HITLESS IN THREE TRIPS
TODAY.
HE DOES NOT WRITE.
-- HE DOES NOT BITE.
TWO ON FOR THE PHILLIES.
THIS BROUGHT TO YOU BY NOON
BASEBALL OF OPERATIONS HEAD DAVE
DOMBROWSKI.
>> ARCHIE BRADLEY MISSED
SOMETIME.
JOSE ALVAREZ, WHEN HE IS
THROWING STRIKES AND DOWN IN THE
ZONE, HE IS AS DIFFICULT AS
ANYONE IN BASEBALL.
THERE IS A GOOD LOOKING ARCHIE
BRADLEY.
LOOK AT THAT THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IN FIVE YEARS I
COULD GROW SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WELL SAID.
STRIKE, BOTTOM OF THE ZONE TO
BRAD MILLER.
ARCHIE BRADLEY IS A FUN PERSON.
LOOK AT THE LINE FOR MILLER AS A
PHILLY.
.309, FIVE HOMERS.
HE HAS BEEN HOT LATELY.
WE MIGHT SEE JOSE ALVARADO FOR
THE PHILLIES.
HE IS HEATING UP.
MILLER IN THE AIR.
AND, DICKERSON CAMPS UNDER IT.
BOTH RUNNERS RETREAT.
DAN: I MADE A CASE FOR RANGER
SUAREZ FOR THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME.
THIS GUY WALKING UP CAN CHANGE
THAT WITH ONE SWING.
IT HAS PRETTY MUCH BEEN THE RHYS
HOSKINS SHOW.
HIT A BIG HOME RUN AFTER BEING
KNOCKED DOWN IN HIS SECOND
AT-BAT.
MADE A BIG PLAY, INNING ENDING
DOUBLE PLAY AND A GOOD GUN DOWN
OF A RUNNER TRYING TO GO TO
THIRD.
A BASE HIT RIGHT HERE AND I
MIGHT HAVE TO CHANGE MY THINKING
FOR THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
SCOTT: RAFAEL MARCHAN ON SECOND
NOW GETS A DOUBLE INSTEAD OF THE
SINGLE AND E-9.
NO ERROR CHARGED AGAINST DUVALL.
I THINK THE BIRDIE WAS HELPING
TO MAKE THE CASE.
JUST GIVE HIM THE DOUBLE.
CLIFF: I PUT DOUBLE DOWN AND
THEN I CHANGED IT.
SCOTT: SORRY.
HOSKINS IN THE FOURTH.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
GO LONG.
DAN: HE KNEW IT AS SOON AS HE
HIT IT.
THIS BALL IS TORCHED.
106.5 EXIT VELOCITY.
403 FEET.
THAT WOULD HAVE TO FEEL AWFULLY
GOOD AFTER GETTING KNOCKED DOWN
A COUPLE OF PITCHES BEFORE THAT.
CLIFF: YOU SEE THOSE BOYS BEHIND
HIM IN THE DUGOUT SHOWING MAD
LOVE.
SCOTT: I LIKED THE APPROACH FROM
THE PHILLIES BENCH, THEY LET HIM
COOL DOWN FOR A COUPLE OF
MINUTES AND THEN THEY WERE LIKE
TELL ME ABOUT THAT EXPERIENCE.
THAT GOES AWAY AND BOTH RUNNERS
MOVE UP.
IT GETS PAST LEON.
DAN: THIS IS A BREAKING BALL
HERE.
NOT SURE HOW THIS WOULD BE
SCORED.
MY GUT FEELING IS THIS MIGHT BE
A PASSED BALL.
THAT BALL WAS A PITCH THAT
NORMALLY HE HANDLES RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: DO YOU GIVE HOSKINS THE
BASE?
DAN: NO, YOU CAN'T.
YOU HAVE THE LEFTY, ODUBEL
HERRERA, COMING UP NEXT.
THEY HAVE GONE FASTBALL IN,
BREAKING BALL AWAY.
SCOTT: ON THE GROUND AND IT IS
HANDLED BY DIAZ TO PUT AWAY RHYS
HOSKINS AND SITTHE MARLINS BULLS
JOB.
NOW IT IS UP TO THE OFFENSE.
2-1, MID EIGHTH.
>> JIM LEYLAND HAS PLAYED
THROUGH 34 SEASONS OF
PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL, TRAILING
2-1 AS HIS TEAM COMES UP FOR THE
LAST LEG IN GAME SEVEN.
>> IN THE BOTTOM OF THE NINTH,
ROOKIE CRAIG COUNSELL CAME
THROUGH IN THE CLUTCH.
>> GAME SEVEN OF THE WORLD
SERIES IS TIED.
>> THEN, FLORIDA WOULD LOAD THE
BASES IN THE BOTTOM OF THE 11TH.
LELAND'S FIRST WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> I AM THING MYSELF, ONE OUT,
BASES LOADED, A SAC FLY WE ARE
CHAMPIONS.
I LOOKING BACK AT MY CARD,
LOOKING AHEAD, I HAD ALEX ARRAEZ
LEFT ON THE BENCH.
>> ONLY ONE GAME SEVEN IN WORLD
SERIES HISTORY HAS GONE LONGER
THAN THIS.
>> RENTERIA BATS WITH TWO OUTS,
AND A BREAKING BALL IS IN THERE.
>> THE FIRST PITCH, A STRIKE.
THE NEXT I LOOK UP, THE WORLD
SERIES IS OVER.
>> A LINER INTO CENTER FIELD.
THE MARLINS HAVE WON THE WORLD
SERIES!
SCOTT: GOOGLE IS HELPING TO
POWER STATCAST WITH MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF DATA POINTS TO REVEAL
NEW INSIGHTS TAKING YOU DEEPER
THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
IS SHOWING US NOT ONE BUT TWO
HOME RUNS OFF OF 100-PLUS.
DAN: THIS IS UPPER TAKEOFF JACOB
DEGROM.
HOW ABOUT THIS EXPECTED
DISTANCE, 402 FEET.
THIS LOOKS LIKE 502 FEET.
THEN HE TAKES ALVARADO DEEP.
95 MILES AN HOUR ON THE EXIT
VELOCITY.
SPEAKING OF ALVARADO, HE IS
GOING TO COME IN AND PIGGYBACK
OFF SUAREZ, WAS TERRIFIC.
THREE SCORELESS INNINGS AND THE
PHILLIES WILL TURN IT OVER TO A
GUY THAT CAN BRING SOME NOISE
FROM THE LEFT SIDE.
3-0, THIS GUY CAN BRING IT WITH
SOME MOVEMENT.
98 TO 100 MILES PER HOUR.
HE IS A NIGHTMARE FOR LEFTIES.
WHEN HE IS THROWING STRIKES, HE
IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO ELEVATE
THE BALL OFF.
IF THE PHILLIES ARE GOING TO
STAY RELEVANT THE REST OF THE
YEAR, THIS BULLPEN WILL HAVE TO
PULL IT UP -- HAVE TO PICK IT
UP.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS,
HELPING TO BRIDGE THE GAP TO GET
THE BALL TO HECTOR NERIS IN THE
NINTH INNING.
SCOTT: NICK MATON TO SECOND BASE
NOW ON THE DOUBLE SWITCH.
BRAD MILLER WAS AT SECOND BASE
TO START THE GAME.
HE TAKES A SEAT.
THE PITCHER SPOT IS NOW THE
NUMBER TWO HOLE.
EIGHTH INNING ACTION ON YOUTUBE.
THERE IS 100.
CLIFF: THAT IS TOUGH.
YOU ARE WAITING AROUND FOR
OPPORTUNITY MAY BE TO PINCH-HIT
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU GET.
DAN: YOU COULD NOT HAVE ASKED
FOR THE LINEUP TO BE SITUATED
ANY BETTER IF YOU ARE JOE
GIRARDI.
BROUGHT SUAREZ IN AT THE EXACT
TIME, ELECTED TO KEEP PABLO
LOPEZ IN THE GAME.
A BIG STRIKEOUT AND SAC FLY FROM
JESUS ALFARO.
PART OF THE ORDER HERE, YOU ARE
GETTING A GUY WHO HAS NOT HIT A
HOME RUN ALL YEAR.
SITUATED RIGHT -- SITUATED
PRETTY WELL, 9, 1, 2.
SCOTT: JUST RETURNED THIS WEEK
FROM THE INJURY LIST, A STRAINED
HAND STRING.
-- STRAINED HAMSTRING.
MAKES THE PLAY AND ALFARO HEADS
BACK TO THE BENCH.
DAN: THIS GUY IS THE CLOSEST
THING WE HAVE SEEN TO ZACK
BRITTON, WHO IS NOW PITCHING
WITH THE YANKEES.
THIS GUY THROWS HARDER TO THAT
HARDER THAN ZACK BRITTON.
HIS BREAKING BALL AT TIMES IS A
LITTLE BIT THAT ARE, TOO.
YOU WONDER HOW HE CAN HAVE AN
E.R.A. OF THREE WITH THE STUFF
YOU SEE.
CLIFF: THE HEAVY FASTBALL HE
THROWS, FOR A HITTER, DO I MOVE
UP IN THE BOX TOWARD HIM?
NO, HE THROWS 100, SO I HAVE TO
STAY BACK.
DAN: WE TOUCHED ABOUT TWO THINGS
THAT KILL YOU IN THE BULLPEN,
HOME RUNS AND WALKS.
46 WALKS IN A LITTLE OVER 55
INNINGS THE LAST COUPLE OF
SEASONS.
WHEN HE IS THROWING STRIKES --
WHEN THE ROOF STARTS TO FALL IN
ON HIM, IT IS ALMOST
SELF-INDUCED BASE ON BALLS.
SCOTT: THIS IS JOSÉ DEVERS.
NOW A BALL AND A STRIKE.
I KNOW THE MARLINS ARE ABOUT TO
HEAD UP TO BOSTON.
THAT MEANS FAMILY TIME, RIGHT?
>> JOSE DEVERS, THE NUMBER EIGHT
PROSPECT IN MIAMI'S SYSTEM, WILL
BE REUNITING WITH HIS OLDER
COUSIN, RAFAEL DEVERS, THIS
WEEKEND WHEN THE MARLINS BEGIN A
THREE CITY TRIP.
SCOTT: RAFAEL DEVERS HAS A
FAMOUS HOMER OFF 100-PLUS AS
WELL.
LEFTY ON LEFTY CRIME.
DEVERS HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
BETTER HITTERS IN BASEBALL SINCE
HE DEBUTED.
JOSÉ, A DIFFERENT STYLE.
GOOD BACK TO BALL SKILLS.
WE SAW THAT ON A PITCH AT 97
APPEND AWAY.
ACQUIRED IN THE STANTON TRADE.
DEVERS IS ALSO LIGHTNING FAST.
HE HAD A BIG DAY YESTERDAY,
CLIFF.
YOU AND I WERE TALKING BEFORE
THE GAME.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF HE WERE
NOT IN THE STARTING NIGHT AFTER
WHAT YOU DID YESTERDAY.
YOUNG GUY.
THAT IS WHAT THEY DO NOWADAYS.
BUT, 3-2 COMING UP.
CLIFF: I WOULD NOT BE HAPPY.
THAT IS THE GAME THOUGH, GETTING
THESE GUYS TO BUY INTO THE
PHILOSOPHY.
IF YOU HAD A GOOD DAY, IT DOES
NOT MEAN YOU'RE PLAYING
TOMORROW.
IT MEANS HAD A GOOD DAY TODAY.
ME PERSONALLY, I HAVE GOT TO GO
INTO THE OFFICE AND HOLLER AT
THEM A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: DID YOU SEE WHAT I DID
WITH 97 UP AND AWAY?
MAKE KNOCKING THE EIGHTH.
THAT MISSED.
HE SETS THE TABLE FOR THE
MARLINS WITH ONE OUT.
RHYS HOSKINS AND THE MIGUEL
ROJAS HAD A LITTLE CONVERSATION
AND WE TAKE YOU INSIDE.
>> WHO DID YOUR SHOES?
>> IT IS CALLED STADIUM CUSTOM
KITS.
>> LOVE THAT.
THEY ARE LOUD BUT COOL.
>> A HOMER.
>> I MIGHT HAVE SAID A COUPLE OF
BAD WORDS ALONG THE WAY.
SORRY, DAD.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: WE DUBBED IT.
IT IS ALL GOOD.
NOW HE IS GOING TO WANT TO BE
MIC'D UP EVERY DAY.
DAN: IF YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI, THE
LAST BASE ON BALLS HAS BEEN WHAT
IS INDICATIVE OF ALVARADO IN HIS
CAREER.
A SITUATION THAT YOU LIKE,
REALLY NOT MUCH POP, BUT ONE
THING HE CAN DO IS RUN.
ALVARADO WALKS HIM.
IF YOU ARE GIRARDI, YOU HAVE TO
KIND OF BEAR WITH THIS.
THE CONSISTENCY AND COMMAND, IT
COMES AND GOES.
SCOTT: HE FINDS THE ZONE.
ROJAS ASKING ABOUT IT.
DAN: WHAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT AT
TIMES WHEN YOU ARE READY ON
LEFTY.
HE DOES NOT FACE A LOT OF
LEFTIES NORMALLY.
HE IS PROBABLY MORE COMFORTABLE
FACING RIGHT-HANDERS WITH THAT
SINKER.
A LOT OF TIMES, YOU ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE FACING RIGHTIES
BECAUSE YOU FACED MORE RIGHTIES
THAN LEFTIES.
SCOTT: DEVERS AND MOVE.
ALVARADO KEEPING AN EYE ON HIM.
DAN: THIS CAN BE A VERY TRICKY
BALANCE AS A RELIEVER.
YOU WANT TO PAY ATTENTION TO
DEVERS OVER AT FIRST BUT YOU
ALSO HAVE TO BE WORRIED ABOUT
ROJAS SWINGING A BIG STICK.
I HAVE OFTEN FELT LIKE YOU HAVE
TO MAKE YOUR MIND UP WHEN YOU
COME SAID.
YOU ARE EITHER COMING TO FIRST
ORDER GOING TO HOME PLATE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET CAUGHT IN
THAT AREA WHERE YOU ARE
INDECISIVE.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR
MIND MADE UP, I AM DELIVERING TO
HOME, IF HE GETS A GOOD JUMP, HE
GETS A GOOD JUMP.
CLIFF: HOLDING THE BALL, IT
THROWS YOU OFF AS FAR AS JUST
HAVING THAT RHYTHM?
DAN: IT DOES.
IT VARIES FROM PITCHER TO
PITCHER.
HE DOES NOT MIND HOLDING THE
BALL.
SCOTT: BASE RUNNERS THIS SEASON
AGAINST JOSE ALVARADO, OR IN HIS
CAREER, 8-8 IN THE STOLEN BASE
DEPARTMENT.
DAN: A COUPLE OF THINGS YOU CAN
DO TO STOP THE RUNNING GAME, YOU
CAN VARY YOUR LOOKS.
WE DO NOT SEE MANY PITCHOUTS IN
BASEBALL RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU ARE GIRARDI, YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO PITCH OUT RIGHT HERE ON
A 2-1 COUNT.
THAT IS WHY HITTING IS SO TOUGH.
YOU HAVE A GUY WHO CANNOT REALLY
FIND THE STRIKE ZONE AND HE
DROPS A 2-1 SLIDER.
CLIFF: I HATED THOSE GUYS.
YOU THROW ONE DOWN 100, AND THE
NEXT ONE, YOU ARE LIKE, REALLY?
DAN: IF YOU'RE ROJAS, HE JUST
FLIPPED UP A 2-1 BREAKING BALL
FOR A STRIKE BUT YOU ARE
GUARDING AGAINST THE 100 MILE
PER HOUR A BOWLING BALL SINKER
THAT HE THROWS.
SCOTT: HE WOULD LOVE A GROUND
HERE HIT SHARPLY.
ROJAS STICKS WITH IT.
COVID-19 VACCINES ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
JOIN THE TEAM AND GET THE
VACCINE TO HELP US ALL GET BACK
TO DOING WHAT WE LOVE TOGETHER.
VISIT MLB.COM/COVID-19RESOURCES
FOR MORE INFORMATION.
ERIC COOPER ON DECK.
THAT IS A GREAT SIGN FOR
MARLON'S FANS.
HE WAS A LATE SCRATCH ABOUT 20
MINUTES BEFORE LAST WEEK'S GAME
WITH OBLIQUE TIGHTNESS.
DAN: HERE COMES THE SINKER.
SCOTT: SPIKED IT.
GOOD STOP BY MARCHAN.
HE IS SO SMOOTH BACK THERE.
DAN: JOE GIRARDI TOLD US BEFORE
THE GAME, HIS CATCHING SKILLS,
CATCHING THROW, HE IS VERY
ADVANCED FOR A YOUNG PLAYER.
MAY STUCK BEHIND JT REALMUTO.
A BACKHAND ON A 90 TO
MILE-PER-HOUR -- LET'S CALL IT A
SINKER.
SCOTT: THE BIG MAN, JT REALMUTO,
STILL ON THE INJURED LIST.
DIDI ON THE I.L., JT, BRYCE.
MCCUTCHEN OUT TODAY.
PAYOFF PITCH MISSED.
TWO ON FOR THE MARLINS IN THE
EIGHTH.
AUNT HERE COMES GARRETT COOPER
ON A 10 GAME HIT STREAK.
.444 DURING THAT SPAN INCLUDING
THIS WALKOFF BLAST ON MAY 22
AGAINST THE METS.
CLIFF: NOTHING BETTER RIGHT
THERE.
THAT LITTLE HOP, 305 UP, LET'S
GO HOME.
SCOTT: IT IS A GLOBAL AUDIENCE.
305, THAT IS THE AREA CODE IN
THE AREA.
I AM JUST HELPING EVERYONE OUT
BESIDES THE MARLON'S FANS.
DAN: PHILLIES DEFENSE RIGHT NOW,
THEY CAN'T HELP MR. ALVARADO IF
HE CAN'T HELP HIMSELF.
THAT IS THE 15TH WALK THIS YEAR.
THIS PART OF THE ORDER VERY
FAVORABLE.
HE IS RUNNING HIMSELF NOW INTO
SOME DICEY WATER.
HAS NEVER BEEN A QUESTION ABOUT
THE STUFF.
THE ABILITY TO FLIP UP A 2-1
BREAKING BALL FOR A STRIKE.
THE SINKER HE HAS IS SO GOOD.
THE INABILITY TO COMMAND THAT
SINKER HAS MADE IT REALLY TOUGH.
SCOTT: SWINGS THROUGH 100.
DAN: PHILLY FANS, IT CAN BE
AWFUL FRUSTRATING.
YOU CAN THROW A FIRST PITCH
STRIKE FOR 100, THEN THE BALL
JUST STARTS DANCING ALL OVER THE
STRIKE ZONE.
MIGHT BE ONE OF THOSE GUYS YOU
ARE BETTER OFF JUST SITTING DOWN
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE AND
SAY, BRING IT TO ME.
SCOTT: CHECK OVER TO FIRST, BACK
PICK ATTEMPT, AND HE GOT HIM.
WHAT A PLAY BY THE ROOKIE,
RAFAEL MARCHAN.
IT LOOKS LIKE MIGUEL ROJAS MAY
HAVE HURT ONE OF HIS FINGERS ON
THE SLIDE ATTEMPT BACK.
SNEAKY MOVE BY THE PHILLIES
CATCHER.
WE WILL SEE IF ROJAS IS OK.
DAN: OH MAN.
THIS IS A GREAT PLAY AND A GREAT
TAG BY RHYS HOSKINS.
THE SWIPE TAG, I THINK THAT IS
WHAT GOT ROJAS.
WHAT A TERRIFIC THROW BY MARCHAN
, A LA ST. LOUIS CARDINALS
BACKSTOP RIGHT THERE.
LOOKS LIKE MR. MOLINA.
CLIFF: NICE.
SCOTT: YADI LOVES THE BACK PICK,
SO DOES WILLSON CONTRERAS OF THE
CUBS.
DAN: ANOTHER LOOK AT IT.
LOOK AT THE QUICK FEET TO CATCH
AND THROW.
GREAT JOB BY HOSKINS TO GET
HIMSELF IN A POSITION.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE LEFT HAND OF
ROJAS, POINTER FINGER.
SCOTT: WE SAW AN INJURY LIKE
THAT TO MARCELL OZUNA THE OTHER
DAY.
HOPE ROJAS IS OK.
DAN: WHEN YOU ARE STRUGGLING TO
SCORE RUNS LIKE THE MARLINS ARE,
JUST IN LITTLE BIT TOO FRISKY AT
FIRST BASE WITH RHYS HOSKINS
PLAYING OFF THE BASE, ROJAS
TRYING TO GET A LITTLE EXTRA
REAL ESTATE.
MORE THAN LIKELY THINKING IF THE
BALL IS HIT IN THE GAP, HE WANTS
TO SCORE FROM FIRST.
CLIFF: THAT IS COMING FROM A GUY
WHO WAS A CATCHER FOR HIS
CAREER, JOE GIRARDI OF THE
PHILLIES SAYING, LOOK, LET'S PUT
IT ON RIGHT NOW.
DAN: RHYS HOSKINS CONTINUES TO
BUILD HIS CASE FOR THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
SCOTT: DEVERS ON SECOND.
COOPER TAKES THE PITCH.
THAT IS A CLOSE PITCH.
CLIFF: COMING OFF THE BENCH,
THAT IS SO TOUGH.
YOU MISS A PITCH PRIOR TO THAT.
FASTBALL-AWAY.
THAT RIGHT THERE IS JUST A GOOD
TAKE.
IF YOU ARE THE PHILLIES, A GUY
GETTING IN THE BOX, GETTING
COMFORTABLE.
DAN: I AM NOT SURE HOW
COMFORTABLE HE IS THROWING THAT
BACK FOOT SLIDER DOWN AND IN.
THIS MIGHT BE THE TIME TO BURY
THE BREAKING BALL.
SCOTT: COOPER ON THE GROUND,
THROUGH THE RIGHT SIDE.
DEVERS ROUNDING THIRD AND HE
WILL SCORE AND TIE THE GAME AT
2-2.
GARRETT COOPER OFF THE BENCH
COMES THROUGH FOR THE MARLINS.
DAN: MIGHT THE A CASE OF ONE TOO
MANY FASTBALLS.
I KNOW THAT IS HIS BREAD AND
BUTTER PITCH BUT THAT DID NOT
HAVE TO MUCH SINK IN IT.
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
DOWN IN THE ZONE.
THIS BALL JUST KIND OF TRACKS
MIDDLE-MIDDLE.
GREAT JOB OF HITTING, NOT TRYING
TO PULL THAT PITCH.
THE PHILLIES BULLPEN CONTINUING
TO STRUGGLE AND ALVARADO WITH
THE WALKS, AS WE TOUCHED ON.
15 WALKS IN 16 AND A THIRD,
EVENTUALLY COMES BACK TO BITE
HIM AGAIN.
SCOTT: JUST LIKE LAST NIGHT, A
TWO-OUT RALLY FROM THE MARLINS
IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
CLIFF: CREDIT COOPER.
THE SWING ON THAT BASE HIT.
I KNOW THERE WAS A PITCH IN
BETWEEN WHERE HE TOOK.
BUT HE FOULED OFF A BALL, SORT
OF A BIG HACK.
LET ME SHORTEN UP AND GET
REWARDED WITH A KNOCK R.B.I. TO
TIE THIS GAME.
SCOTT: THEY WOULD BE FIRST AND
THIRD IF MARCHAN DID NOT HOOKUP
HOSKINS WITH THIS BASEBALL.
DAN: THIS WILL BE ANOTHER ONE
DEPENDING ON HOW THIS ENDS UP IF
YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI, YOU GET A
BIG PLAY FROM YOUR CATCHER, THE
GOLF, YOU ARE FEELING PRETTY
GOOD, YOU HAVE A TWO-STRIKE
COUNT.
INABILITY TO MAKE PITCHES WHEN
IT COUNTS.
SCOTT: DEVOL HAS HAD SOME CLUTCH
HITS FOR THIS TEAM.
THIRD IN THE NL IN R.B.I.S.
2-1.
NOW, 3-1.
CLIFF: HE'S JUST TOO GOOD ON THE
MOUND, FOR ME, TO BE ALL AROUND
AND BE THIS WILD.
IT IS TOUGH TO WATCH WHEN YOU
HAVE THIS TYPE OF STUFF AND
STRUGGLE TO BE ABLE TO THROW
STRIKES.
DAN: IT MAKES YOU TOUGH AS A
MANAGER.
YOU ARE NOT SURE, DO YOU GO OUT
AND GET HIM, DO YOU LEAVE HIM
OUT THERE, DO YOU LET HIM FIGHT
THROUGH IT?
SCOTT: THAT IS THE THIRD FREE
PASS ISSUED BY JOSE ALVARADO IN
THE EIGHTH.
DAN: JOE GIRARDI WILL HAVE TO GO
TO THAT BULLPEN.
HE GETS BROGDON UP.
REALLY COULD NOT HAVE PLANNED
THIS OUT ANY BETTER IF YOU ARE
THE PHILLIES TO START THIS
BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH INNING.
9, 1, AND TWO, VERY FAVORABLE
MATCHUPS.
I GO BACK TO THE WALK OF DEVERS,
A LEFT ON LEFT SITUATION.
YOU WALK HIM, WALK ROJAS.
SELF-INFLICTED.
CLIFF: YOU WON'T WIN A SERIES
THAT WAY.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
SCOTT: MARLINS TRYING TO TAKE
THREE OUT OF FOUR HERE IN MIAMI.
DIAZ, JUST CALLED UP TODAY.
NICK NEIDERT TO THE INJURED LIST
WITH RIGHT BICEPS INFLAMMATION.
RIGHT DOWN BROADWAY FROM
ALVARADO.
FIRST START OF 2021 FOR DIAZ.
COOPER HAD THE BIG KNOCK TO TIE
THE GAME.
THEN A WALK TO DEVOL.
HE IS GOING RIGHT AT HIM.
CLIFF: SEE IF DIAZ CAN SHORTEN
THAT SWING UP LIKE COOPER DID.
100, LEFT ON LEFT.
SCOTT: ALSO, THEY ARE WORKING
ALVARADO.
SEASON HIGH 30TH PITCH COMING UP
HIS CAREER-HIGH IS 34 IN 2017.
CLIFF: I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT PITCH CALL RIGHT THERE.
AS FAR AS -- SELECTION, I SHOULD
SAY.
TWO FASTBALLS.
1, 99.
THE SECOND 1, 99.
YOU GET A SWING AND MISS, THE
GUY IS LATE, THEN YOU SAY, I
WILL TRY TO TRICK HIM?
DAN: I AM WITH YOU.
IT IS JUST THE INABILITY TO
COMMAND THE STRIKE ZONE.
THAT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM FOR
ALVARADO.
M, NOT ENOUGH OF
THOSE.
SCOTT: DIAZ GONE FISHING.
THE FISH PICK UP THE RUN THEY
NEED IN THE EIGHTH TO EVEN UP
THE SCORE TWO IN MIAMI.
♪
>> THAT IS NICE.
>> PINSTRIPES, I LIKE IT.
MIAMI.
>> THAT IS WHAT WE NEED.
>> SWAGGY.
>> WOW.
OLD-SCHOOL.
>> NICE.
>> THIS IS WHY I SAY WE ARE THE
SWAGGIEST TEAM IN THE LEAGUE,
FOR REAL.
SCOTT: YOU CAN ACCESS EXCLUSIVE
BEHIND THE SCENES CONTENT ON THE
PHILLIES YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/PHILLIES TO
FOLLOW THE TEAM TODAY.
DAN: COOPER RIGHT HERE, THE
PITCH SEQUENCE FROM ALVARADO.
POWERHOUSE HEATER AT 100.
ANOTHER GOOD FASTBALL AT 98.
A CUTTER UP AT 94.
CENTER-CUT, HE WAS LUCKY TO GET
AWAY WITH THAT.
99.
THIS WAS A BULLET.
YOU CAN SEE, COOPER LOVES IT.
NOT EASY TO HIT A BALL OFF
ALVARADO.
SCOTT: QUIET APRIL, BIG MAY
ESPECIALLY AGAINST THE PHILLIES.
GARRETT COOPER IS IN RIGHT
FIELD.
AND ADAM DUVALL IS GOING TO MOVE
TO CENTER.
HE CAN PLAY ALL THREE FOR THE
MARLINS THIS YEAR.
WE WILL GO THROUGH THE REST OF
THE CHANGES FOR THE MARLINS
DEFENSE IN JUST A MOMENT.
GARCIA IS IN THE GAME.
WE ARE NOT AT THE PARK BUT WE
WILL GET THEM FOR YOU SOON.
1.31 E.R.A. FOR YIMI.
HE HAS BEEN INSERTED INTO THE
CLOSER ROLE.
NOT JUST HIM BUT THE ENTIRE
MARLINS BULLPEN HAS CLICKED
SINCE THAT MOVE WAS MADE.
PICKED UP THE SAVE LAST NIGHT.
CLICK REST.
PROBABLY 5, 6 HOURS, YOU HIT THE
PILLOW AND YOU ARE BACK AT THE
PARK.
CLIFF: EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, I
USED TO SLEEP AT THE PARK.
YOU TALK ABOUT NOON STARTS.
WHAT IS THE SENSE OF GOING TO
THE HOUSE?
GOOD FOOD.
AS LONG AS THERE WAS NOT ANY
RODENTS OR ANYTHING.
SCOTT: IS A PRETTY NEW PARK
HERE.
WHERE DID YOU SLEEP?
CLIFF: DIDN'T MATTER.
COUCH.
SCOTT: UNDOABLE HERRERA IS IN
THE CLEANUP SPOT FOR THE SECOND
TIME IN HIS CAREER.
HE DOUBLED IN THE FOURTH AND
LATER SCORED ON A SAC FLY.
WE WILL SEE IF THE MARLINS
BULLPEN HAS A SHUTDOWN INNING
AFTER A KEY RUN IN THE EIGHTH.
FRESH BALLGAME IN THE NINTH.
DAN: WONDERING IF JOE GIRARDI
WILL GIVE HIM THE GREEN LIGHT.
THIS GUY CAN RUN A LITTLE BIT.
GOOD PART OF THE ORDER COMING
UP.
SCOTT: DO YOU LET HIM SWING?
CLIFF: YES.
SCOTT: HE TOOK IT.
DAN: THIS GUY HAS A PRETTY GOOD
IDEA OF THE STRIKE ZONE WENT HE
IS SWINGING WELL.
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR DEFENSE
NOW.
BERTI BACK TO THIRD.
DEVERS AND DIAZ ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
CLIFF: LOOK AT LEFT FIELD.
SCOTT: JORGE ALFARO.
DAN: THAT IS A PRETTY NASTY
PITCH.
I STILL THINK THAT IS THE BEST
PITCH IN BASEBALL.
95 MILES PER HOUR, KNEE HIGH ON
THE CORNER.
A LITTLE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE THE
WAY THE MARLINS DEFENSIVELY ARE
PLAYING IF HERRERA CAN HIT THAT
THE LEFT SIDE, THERE IS A LOT OF
REAL ESTATE.
PARTICULARLY THE OUTFIELD.
SCOTT: THAT ONE IS STRUCK
SOLIDLY TO RIGHT FIELD AND OFF
OF COOPER'S GLOVE.
HERRERA IS HEADING FOR THREE.
ON HIS HORSE AND IN THERE.
HEADFIRST SLIDE WITH A LEADOFF
TRIPLE IN THE NINTH.
HE POWERS UP BIG BALLPARK, HOLDS
IT, BUT HE ENDS UP AT THIRD.
DAN: ODUBEL HERRERA SLOWLY BUT
SURELY ROUNDING HIMSELF BACK
INTO FORM.
HE TAKES THIS 3-2 CUTTER.
KEEPS HIS HANDS AND, COMES
WITHIN A FEW FEET OF HITTING
THIS ONE OUT OF THE BALLPARK.
RIGHT HERE, HE DOES NOT EVEN
PICK UP THE THIRD BASE COACH.
HE IS JUST READING THAT ONE AND
MAKES IT EASY.
CLIFF: THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE
TAUGHT TO DO.
YOU SEE WHERE THE BALL IS, YOU
SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO THE RIGHT
FIELDER, AND ONCE YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION, THERE IS NO REASON TO
LOOK AT THE THIRD BASE COACH.
HE SAID, I AM MAKING A DECISION,
I AM GETTING TO THIRD BASE.
GOOD BASE RUNNING BY ODUBEL
HERRERA.
SCOTT: A YOUNG HITTER BUT HE
KNOWS HOW TO DRIVE IN A RUN.
ALEC BOHM.
.452 LAST YEAR WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
BEST IN BASEBALL.
DAN: IT IS SO HARD TO DO AT
TIMES AS A YOUNG HITTER.
YOU GET A LITTLE OVERANXIOUS.
YOU HAVE THE COUNT IN YOUR
FAVOR, 1-0, AND HE SWINGS AT A
BREAKING BALL WAY OFF THE PLATE.
PRETTY GOOD PITCH BY GARCIA.
HE THROWS THE 1-0 BREAKING BALL
WAY OFF THE PLATE, GETS BOHM TO
CHASE IT, HE DOUBLES UP WITH A
FASTBALL IN ON THE FISTS.
CLIFF: THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU ARE YOUNG.
YOU SWING AT THAT PITCH AWAY,
NOW I HAVE TO BE MORE RESERVED,
AND YOU ARE MORE TENTATIVE.
DAN: THAT WAS A HACK.
IF YOU ARE GARCIA, BY THAT
READING, THAT SWING WILL TELL
ME, I THINK IT IS TIME TO GO
BACK TO THAT BREAKING BALL.
HE WAS RIGHT ON THAT 96 MILE PER
HOUR HEATER.
THAT MIGHT BE THE LAST HEATER
BOHM WILL SEE FROM ME FOR A
WHILE.
SCOTT: 44% WITH THE FOUR-SEAMER.
OTHERWISE, SLIDER, CHANGEUP.
CURVEBALL IS HIS THIRD MOST
USED, THEN THE CHANGEUP.
SEEING MORE VARIETY THIS YEAR
FROM YIMI GARCIA WITH THE
ARSENAL.
DAN: THIS GUY HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD.
9 FOR 10 IN SAVE OPPS.
ONLY 13 WALKS TO GO WITH THE
20.2.
THAT IS THE KEY.
SCOTT: HE WAS AWESOME LAST YEAR
TOO.
DAN: GOOD EYE.
CLIFF: GOOD TAKE.
DAN: AFTER YOU HAVE CHASED A 1-0
BREAKING BALL, DIGGING YOURSELF
BACK INTO A GOOD, FAVORABLE
COUNT.
SCOTT: DO YOU WASTE ONE MORE OR
GO AFTER HIM?
DAN: BY THAT TAKE, I WOULD
PROBABLY GO BACK WITH THE
FASTBALL INSIDE.
THIS IS WHERE YOU HAVE TO TO PAY
CAP TO -- HAVE TO TIP A CAP TO A
YOUNG HITTER.
THIS IS A TERRIFIC AT-BAT.
CLIFF: WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT BOHM
IN HIS CAREER, HE HAS GOTTEN
THAT CAYENNE FROM THIRD BASE --
FROM THIRD BASE LESS THAN TWO
OUTS 68% OF THE TIME.
LEAGUE AVERAGE IS AROUND 50%.
THAT SHOWS YOU HIS EYE IS REALLY
GOOD.
HE STRIKES OUT.
SCOTT: GARCIA GOES RIGHT AFTER
HIM AND PICKS UP THE PUNCH OUT.
DAN: MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE CHANGE
OF SPEEDS.
THIS WAS INTENDED TO BE DOWN AND
AWAY, AND IT IS CENTER CUT.
JUST A LITTLE BIT OUTFRONT.
YOU CAN SEE THE BAT HEAD
OUTFRONT.
SCOTT: ONE GONE.
HERE IS THE VETERAN, MATT JOYCE.
THEY WILL NOT DEAL WITH HIM.
TORREYES IS ON DECK AND HE IS
0-3.
INTENTIONAL WALK.
DOUBLE PLAY DEPTH FROM THE
INFIELD.
NINTH INNING ACTION, ONE OUT.
MARLINS TIED UP THIS GAME IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH.
DAN: FOR A GUY WHO HAS PITCHED
THE NINTH INNING, IT IS GUYS
LIKE TORREYES AT TIMES THAT ARE
THE HARDEST TO GET.
GUYS WHO JUST WANT TO PUT THE
BALL IN PLAY.
YOU HAVE GUYS UP THERE WHO HAVE
BIG COME ALONG SWINGS AND ARE
TRYING TO DO SOME DAMAGE.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN GO BREAKING
BALLS DOWN AND AWAY, FAST.
AND IN.
GUYS LIKE TEREUS TRYING TO PUT
THE BALL AWAY.
>> A COMEBACKER TO THE PITCHER.
HE TURNS AROUND AND GETS ONE AT
SECOND.
THEY WON'T TURN IT.
THE RUN SCORES AND THE PHILLIES
GRAB THE LEAD.
CLIFF: I WANT TO SEE THAT AGAIN.
DAN: I AM NOT SURE WHY GARCIA
DID NOT GO HOME WITH THAT AT
FIRST.
IT IS GOING TO BE BANG-BANG.
I THINK THE MARLINS WILL WANT TO
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT IT.
SCOTT: OF COURSE YOU WILL
CHALLENGE.
NINTH INNING.
I THOUGHT HE WAS OUT.
SCOTT: THIS IS A REPLAY THAT
COULD DECIDE THE GAME.
GARCIA TURNS AROUND, GOES TO
SECOND FOR THE FORCE.
HERRERA SCURRIES HOME AND
SCORES.
WE WANT TO KNOW IF THE THROW TO
FIRST WAS IN TIME TO GET
TORREYES.
WHAT WAS THE PLAY, DAN?
DO YOU HOLD THE BALL AND LOOKED
BACK THE RUNNER?
DAN: THIS IS A ONE HOPPER RIGHT
BACK TO THE MOUND.
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN A PERFECT
HOME TO FIRST DOUBLE PLAY.
YOU LIKE TO HAVE A LITTLE TOUGH
COMMUNICATION.
SCOTT: SAFE AT FIRST, RUN
SCORES.
HE KIND OF WAITED.
DAN: THAT IS CLOSE.
SCOTT: SAFE.
HERRERA WAITED FOR THE THROW.
DAN: GREAT JOB BY TORREYES.
IT IS REAL EASY TO DO THAT, WHEN
YOU HAVE ONE LIKE THAT, YOU DROP
YOUR HEAD, YOU ARE DISGUSTED,
BUT HE DID A GREAT JOB HUSTLING.
THE PHILLIES ARE BACK IN
BUSINESS.
SCOTT: FIELDER'S CHOICE, R.B.I..
THAT LEADS US TO MARCHAN.
CLIFF: THAT IS JUST GREAT
HUSTLE.
YOU CAN SEE THE BOYS ON THE
BENCH ARE ECSTATIC.
SCOTT: HECTOR NERIS WARMING FOR
PHILADELPHIA, THEIR CLOSER, WITH
A ONE RUN LEAD HERE IN THE
NINTH.
DAN: HERE IS ANOTHER LOOK AT IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT FOR THE
SECOND OR THIRD TIME, YOU WONDER
IF THEY WOULD HAVE A SHOT AT
HERRERA AT THIRD BASE.
YOU CAN ONLY GET OFF THIRD AS
FAR AS THE THIRD BASEMAN WAS
PLAYING.
I THINK GARCIA HAD HIS MIND UP
THAT HE WOULD TURN TWO.
I THINK IT MAY HAVE BEEN BETTER
TO CHECK HIM IT LOOKED LIKE HE
HAD A PLAY AT THIRD.
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR STRIKEOUT
FOR GARCIA.
BUT, ODUBEL HERRERA STARTS OFF
THE NINTH WITH A TRIPLE.
THE PHILLIES HAVE THE LEAD PACK
AS WE HEAD TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
NINTH IN SOUTH FLORIDA.
>> ALL ZEROS.
EIGHT NO-HIT INNINGS.
HIS FIRST SEASON START.
IN THE AIR, CHASE UTLEY.
NOTHING IS ROUTINE AT THIS
POINT.
ODDLY MAKES A CATCH.
ONE GONE.
>> TWO OUTS AWAY FROM A
NO-HITTER.
>> HE HAS NOT BEEN A DOCTOR
TONIGHT.
HE HAS BEEN A SURGEON.
>> VALDEZ WITH ROOM.
TWO OUTS.
THE REDS LAST HOPE, BRANDON
PHILLIPS.
ONE MORE PIECE TO THE PUZZLE FOR
ROY HALLADAY.
THE FIRST POSTSEASON GAME FOR
HE WINDS, THE 0-2.
A DRIBBLER OUT IN FRONT OF THE
PLATE.
>> I FEEL LIKE IT HIT BRANDON
PHILLIPS BAT A COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> MY FIRST THOUGHT, THERE IS NO
WAY WE ARE GETTING HIM OUT.
SOMETHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN
SCREWY.
>> THEY WERE LIKE, I DON'T MAKE
THIS PLAY, IT IS OVER.
>> RUIZ OUT TO GET IT.
IT IS IN TIME AND IT IS A
NO-HITTER!
UNBELIEVABLE.
THE PHILLIES CELEBRATE AROUND
ROY HALLADAY.
SCOTT: BACK IN SOUTH FLORIDA,
STATCAST 3D POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD GIVES US A GREAT LOOK AT
LOANDEPOT PARK.
IT IS SPACIOUS.
ODUBEL HERRERA, IN THE NINTH,
POWERS UP, AND IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN A HOME RUN AT CITIZENS BANK
PARK BUT NOT IN THIS PAINTBALL
YARD.
-- NOT IN THIS BIG BALL YARD.
IT SCORED THE GO-AHEAD RUN AND
NOW HECTOR NERIS IS COMING IN TO
TRY TO SHUT THE DOOR.
DAN: HE HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD.
THIS IS ANOTHER GUY, FOR HOW,
GOOD FASTBALL TO GO WITH IT.
SUAREZ WAS TERRIFIC.
THREE SCORELESS, NO WALKS.
ALVARADO, NOT SO MUCH.
THREE WALKS, GAVE UP A RUN IN
THE EIGHTH INNING TO TIE THINGS.
TURN IT OVER TO HECTOR NERIS, HE
IS THERE GUY.
THE PHILLIES WILL HAVE TO BRIDGE
THE GAP TO GET THE BALL TO HIM.
SCOTT: MAYBE IT IS THE NEW
LIEUTENANT, RANGER SUAREZ.
DAN: MAYBE YOU WILL SEE RANGER
SUAREZ IN A NEW LOCATION, AT A
BALLPARK NEAR YOU.
THREE REALLY GOOD PITCHES, LOW
HEARTBEAT, COMMANDS THE STRIKE
ZONE.
LOTS TO LIKE.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH, LEON
SWINGING.
IT IS A FOUL BALL.
DAN: PHILLIES HAVING RHYS
HOSKINS GUARDING THE LINE.
THE NO DOUBLES DEFENSE.
SOME TEAMS LIKE TO DO THAT, SOME
DON'T.
A GUY LIKE LEON WHO DOES NOT RUN
ALL THAT WELL, THAT IS FAIR,
THAT IS TWO PACES.
THE PHILLIES HAVE DONE A LOT OF
THINGS RIGHT DEFENSIVELY THIS
AFTERNOON.
CLIFF: THAT IS DIRTY.
SCOTT: THAT IS HIS PRIMARY
PITCH.
DAN: IT IS SO GOOD AT TIMES.
IT REMINDS ME OF FORMER CLOSER
BRAD LIDGE.
THIS GUY, HE CAN MAKE IT APPEAR
TO GO DOWN AND AWAY.
AT TIMES, IT WILL GO DOWN AND
IN.
THERE IS THE STRAIGHT DOWNWARD.
THE KEY IS HE THROWS HARD
ENOUGH.
IF HE CAN GET STRIKE ONE, EXPAND
THAT STRIKE ZONE A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: HATERS ARE 6-43 AGAINST
THE SPLITTER THIS YEAR.
140 BATTING CLIP.
DAN: FOR THE PHILLIES, THE PART
OF THE ORDER IS COMING UP THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
6, 7, 8, 9.
IT REALLY HAS NOT BEEN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ORDER THAT HAS
CAUSED THE BALL SOME ISSUES.
SUAREZ WAS TERRIFIC.
CLIFF: WITH ALL THE TALK THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS OF THE
CARDINALS, MIKE SHILDT,
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING ON.
YESTERDAY, GALLEGO HAD HIS HAT
TAKEN AWAY.
I'M JUST SAYING, WITH ALL THE
STUFF GOING ON IN THE GAME,
THERE IS A LOT OF ATTENTION PAID
TO THE BILL OF THESE GUYS HATS
AND WHAT THEY ARE WEARING.
WHAT MIKE WAS SAYING YESTERDAY,
BASICALLY, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
PLEASE HIS GUYS, YOU HAVE TO
PLEASE THE WHOLE SQUAD.
SCOTT: HE WAS NOT FOOLING ANYONE
THERE.
NOW.
NO!
BALL FOUR.
SANDY LEON IS GOING TO LEAD OFF
THE MARLIN'S NINTH WITH A WALK.
DAN: THAT IS THE SEVENTH WALK
FOR THE PHILLIES THIS AFTERNOON.
MAYBE CATCHES A CORNER.
FASTBALL RIGHT OFF THE PLATE.
MARTIAN TRIES TO DO A GOOD JOB
OF FRAMING IT.
HAD SOME ISSUES IN THE EIGHTH
INNING.
ALVARADO WALKED THREE.
IF YOU ARE JOE GIRARDI, THE LAST
THING YOU WANT IS A LEADOFF
WALK.
SCOTT: HOME PLATE UMPIRE MIKE
MUCHLINSKI SAID NO.
AND ON THAT ONE, HE CALLS A
STRIKE.
SIMILAR.
IT IS A TOUGH JOB.
CLIFF: IT IS A TOUGH JOB.
BY NO MEANS WHATEVER WANT TO BE
IN UMPIRE TO CALL THE BALLS AND
STRIKES.
THAT IS JUST THE BACK AND FORTH
YOU HEAR FROM PLAYERS ABOUT
STRIKE ZONE'S, HOW THEY CHANGE
FROM AT-BAT TO AT-BAT.
IT IS TOUGH TO KNOW WHAT THE
STRIKE ZONE IS AND EXPECT YOUR
GUYS AS MANAGERS TO KNOW THE
STRIKE CONSISTENTLY.
SCOTT: LEON ON.
DIAZ, 0-1.
NOW IT WILL BE 0-2.
DIAZ HAS PUT TOGETHER SOME
QUALITY AT-BATS.
THE LAST WEEK OR SO, EVEN TODAY,
A COUPLE OF WALKS, THEY PAUL
SENT TO LEFT FIELD THAT WAS RUN
DOWN BY ROMAN QUINN, WHO IS NOT
YOUR AVERAGE LEFT FIELDER IN THE
SPEED DEPARTMENT.
HE CAN REALLY MOVE.
DAN: THIS IS WHERE IF YOU ARE
NERIS, YOU DON'T WANT TO MESS
AROUND.
ABLE TO GET AHEAD RIGHT AWAY
EARLY.
THE MORE PITCHERS YOU SEE, THE
BETTER OFF YOUR CHANCES OF
PUTTING THE BALL IN PLAY.
THERE IS A GOOD SPLIT.
DAN: I KNOW IT IS FRUSTRATING AS
A PHILLIES FANS AT HOME, YOU SEE
THE STUFF, YOU'RE JUST WONDERING
WHY, YOU CAN GET THE TWO STRIKES
AND NOT PUT HATERS AWAY.
THIS IS A NASTY SPLIT.
YOU CAN SEE THE TUMBLE ACTION.
CLIFF: THAT IS TRUSTING YOUR
CATCHER, KNOWING YOU CAN CALL
THAT PITCH AND NOT LET IT GET
PAST YOU.
THAT IS A GOOD CALL BY THE
YOUNGSTER BEHIND THE DISH.
SCOTT: IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
AN EXCELLENT CATCHER FOR HECTOR
NERIS IN THE NINTH.
JON BERTI.
LEFT SIDE.
BOHM TRYING TO MAKE IT TWO, AND
THEY DO.
GAME OVER!
THE PHILLIES TAKE IT 3-2 AND
GRAB A COUPLE OF GAMES IN A
FOUR-GAME SERIES.
NERIS GETS THE GROUNDBALL HE
NEEDS.
DAN: A LOT HAS BEEN TALKED ABOUT
WITH THE PHILLIES DEFENSIVELY
ALL YEAR.
THIS MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE BEST
DEFENSIVE GAME THEY HAVE PLAYED
ALL YEAR.
ROMAN QUINN MADE A COUPLE OF
REALLY NICE PLACE.
RHYS HOSKINS ON A CUT OFF.
A NICE 5-4-3 DOUBLE PLAY TURNED
BY BOHM.
ANOTHER LOOK AT IT HERE.
TRIES TO BEAT THIS FASTBALL INTO
THE GROUND.
A GOOD TURN AND A NICE PICK BY
RHYS HOSKINS.
BOHM DOES A GOOD JOB OF GETTING
RID OF IT QUICK.
AND I SCOOP AT FIRST.
RHYS HOSKINS MADE THAT LOOK
AWFUL EASY.
SCOTT: BERTI CAN FLY.
IT IS A NICE PLAY.
THAT IS ONE OF THE THEMES FOR
YOU, THE PHILLIES DEFENSE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO PICK AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
SPENCER HOWARD, RANGER SUAREZ,
RHYS HOSKINS, OR ODUBEL HERRERA.
WE WILL GO OVER IT IN THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
HIT IT.
THE POSTGAME SHOW IS PRESENTED
BY GLAD YOU ASKED.
WHAT A GOOD ONE TODAY ON
YOUTUBE.
A GLOBAL STAGE, WATCHING RHYS
HOSKINS AND THE PHILLIES.
THERE IS DIDI GREGORIUS, WHO
SHOULD BE BACK SOON.
THEY PICK UP A W.
3-2.
THEY HAVE QUITE A FEW SUPERSTARS
DOWN AT THE MOMENT.
BRYCE HARPER, JT REALMUTO.
BUT, A WIN FOR THE PHILLIES.
THEY SPLIT THE SERIES AGAINST
THE MARLINS IN MIAMI.
LET'S BRING IN RHYS HOSKINS WITH
THE HOME RUN, HE WAS MIC'D UP
TODAY.
FIRST OFF, BEFORE EVERYTHING,
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO HAVE THE MIC
TODAY?
RHYS: IT IS A BIG WIN FOR US.
I APPRECIATE YOU, SCOTT.
IT IS FUN, ANYTIME WE CAN DO
SOMETHING COOL LIKE THAT ON THE
FIELD, IT KIND OF GIVES THE FANS
A LITTLE BIT OF THE PLAYERS
PERSPECTIVE.
ALL FOR IT.
DAN: I THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT
PLAY, GREAT INSTINCTS ON THAT
CUT OFF.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A DIFFERENCE
IN THE GAME.
RHYS: TOTALLY.
THEY HAD BASES LOADED WITH
NOBODY OUT OR ONE OUT, KIND OF
HAD THE MAKINGS OF A BIG INNING
GOING.
THE RUNNER AT SECOND BASE KIND
OF GAVE HIMSELF UP AND THAT KIND
OF STOPS THE INNING.
THE GAME WENT ON FROM THERE.
IT IS A BEGINNING.
CLIFF: YOU HAVE BEEN MORE VOCAL,
SEEING YOU MORE VOCAL.
TALKED TO YOU A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, YOU WERE A LITTLE QUIET.
YOU HAVE PUT AN EMPHASIS ON
BEING MORE VOCAL AND MAKING SURE
YOUR BOYS KNOW YOU ARE THERE?
RHYS: YEAH, A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK YOU GUYS WERE TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE INJURIES WE
HAVE FAN.
SOMETIMES, PEOPLE GOT TO STEP UP
AND GET INTO SITUATIONS MAYBE
THEY DID NOT FIND THEMSELVES IN
EARLIER.
IT IS TIME FOR PEOPLE TO STEP
UP.
IF THAT MEANS ME BEING A LITTLE
BIT MORE VOCAL TO GET THIS TEAM
A COUPLE MORE W'S, I AM ALL FOR
IT.
DAN: HOW ABOUT THE JOB RANGER
SUAREZ DID TODAY?
RHYS: HUGE.
A COUPLE OF BIG INNINGS TO GET
TO THE BACK OF THE BULLPEN.
A FOUR-GAME SET, ANYTIME YOU
HAVE THOSE, SOME OF THOSE OPEN
ARMS CAN GET TIRED.
FOR RANGER TO COME IN AND GET
SOFT CONTACT, KEEP THOSE GUYS
OFF BALANCE, KEEP THE SCORE 2-1,
IT WAS HUGE FOR US.
SCOTT: YOU RECEIVED SOME CHIN
MUSIC AND THEN YOU DECIDED, I AM
GOING TO HOMER.
IT GOES A LONG WAY.
TAKE US THROUGH THAT ENTIRE
EXPERIENCE.
RHYS: GUYS ARE THROWING HARD
NOW.
ANYTIME YOU SEE SOMETHING UP
THERE, IT KIND OF WAKES YOU UP A
LITTLE BIT.
12:00 GAME IS A LITTLE EARLIER
THAN WE ARE USED TO.
BY THAT TIME, I HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO BE AWAKE.
IT GETS THE ADRENALINE GOING A
LITTLE MORE, I DON'T KNOW IF IT
MADE ME A LITTLE MORE LOCKED IN.
I TOOK SOME GOOD PITCHES,
FINALLY GOT A PITCH IN THE ZONE
AT THE END, BUT A GOOD SWING ON
IT AND DID NOT MISS.
CLIFF: TODAY, IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY WAS READY BECAUSE
DEFENSE WAS ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND IT HELPED YOU GUYS WIN.
RHYS: MILLSY MADE A NICE PLAY
EARLY IN THE GAME.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE CUT OFF.
MARCHAN WITH THE BACKPACK.
HE WAS ALL OVER THAT.
THAT WAS A BIG SPOT IN THE GAME.
WE HAD A PITCHER THAT WAS KIND
OF STRUGGLING TO THROW SOME
STRIKES AND THOUGHT MAYBE WE
COULD STEAL AND OUT.
WE CAN'T -- WE CAUGHT ROJAS
STEALING A LITTLE BIT.
IF WE DON'T GET THAT OUT, WHO
KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS.
WE WERE ON OUR TOES, MADE SOME
GOOD DEFENSIVE PLAYS.
OBVIOUSLY THE BIG DOUBLE PLAY AT
THE END.
SCOTT: CONGRATS ON THE W, GREAT
JOB IN THIS SERIES, AND THANKS
AGAIN FOR THE MICROPHONE AND
TAKING US INSIDE.
IT WAS AWESOME.
RHYS: I APPRECIATE IT.
AWESOME TO SEE I GOT THIS LITTLE
YOUTUBE THING.
THAT IS PRETTY COOL.
SCOTT: HOLD IT UP FOR US.
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY.
THAT WILL COME WITH YOUR NAME ON
IT AS WE WILL SHOW THE POLL
RESULTS.
BREAK THINGS UP DURING THE
REGULAR SEASON, ADD A LITTLE
HARDWARE TO THE ROOM, RIGHT?
RHYS: IT NEVER HURTS.
SCOTT: TAKE THEM WITH YOU, SAFE
TRAVELS, CONGRATS ON THE W.
RHYS: SOUNDS GOOD, APPRECIATE
YOU HAVE ME ON.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS, TROPHY
COMING IN HOT AT THE END.
DAN: GOOD FOR THE LIEUTENANT.
I WAS PULLING FOR RANGER SUAREZ.
HE WAS TERRIFIC.
THE DEFENSE, WHICH HAD BEEN A
PROBLEM ALL YEAR, AIRTIGHT
DEFENSE.
SUAREZ WAS TERRIFIC.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS A WELL PLAYED
GAME.
CLIFF: FIRST AND FOREMOST,
ODUBEL HERRERA.
DAN ALLUDED TO HIM GETTING BACK
INTO THE FLOW OF THINGS.
SPECIAL IN THE SERIES AS FAR AS
DEFENSE.
TODAY, SWUNG THE BAT EXTREMELY
WELL, GOT TO THIRD BASE AND
SCORED THE WINNING RUN.
THIS PHILLIES TEAM, YOU EXPECT A
LOT OUT OF THEM.
YOU HAVE SOME GUYS BEAT UP A
LITTLE BIT, GUYS HAVE TO STEP
UP.
SCOTT: I THINK WE ARE ALSO
SEEING IT EVEN WITH HIS PLAY.
THE OTHER DAY, HITS THE HOME RUN
HE REALLY PROVIDED THE TWO BIG
SHOTS IN THE SERIES.
THE OTHER DAY, HE WAS LIKE I'M A
LET'S GO.
THIS TIME, HE DID NOT NEED TO
SAY MUCH.
THE PITCH ALMOST HIT HIM AND HE
RESPONDS RIGHT AWAY.
HIS ANSWER HAD A LITTLE BIT OFF
OOMPH TO IT
THERE ARE GUYS WHO ARE OUT,
OTHERS NEED TO STEP UP, AND IT
IS TIME.
CLIFF: THERE IS MORE THAN JUST
SHOWING UP AND PLAYING A
BASEBALL GAME.
THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY AMONGST
EVERYBODY IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
YOU HAVE TO BE COMFORTABLE IN
THAT ROLE TO SPEAK UP AND SO
FORTH, BUT THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR GUYS LIKE
RHYS.
HE IS A LEADER.
HE WORKS REALLY HARD TO BE
REALLY GOOD.
I TALKED TO HIM A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO AND HE WAS REALLY
AMPED UP ABOUT BEING THAT GUY.
TO SEE HIM ON THE FIELD WHEN A
GUY MAKES A GREAT PLAY, TO STAY
THERE AND SHOW LOVE, JUST
MATURING AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
BIG HE IS FOR THIS TEAM IF THEY
ARE GOING TO DO ANYTHING.
SCOTT: RHYS HOSKINS, YOUR
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE SAID, I
AM VOTING FOR THE PIGEON.
BUT HE IS NOT AN OPTION, THAT
GUY IS.
DAN: THIS HAD TO FEEL AWFUL
GOOD.
THE COUPLE OF PITCHES BEFORE
THAT SWING.
RHYS HOSKINS TOOK A FASTBALL UP
AND IN.
SIGNALING TO THE BULLPEN, LET'S
DO IT.
SCOTT: 48%, YOUR PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
YOU MADE YOUR CASE, HE CAME
CLOSE.
AT LEAST TO SECOND PLACE.
DAN: THE LIEUTENANT, RANGER
SUAREZ.
SCOTT: THE PHILADELPHIA PHILLIES
CHANNEL SAID, IF THE PHILLIES
THIS, GIVE RANGER SUAREZ THE
PLAYER OF THE GAME AWARD.
HOSKINS TAKES IT.
ALSO I THE NICE PLAY WITH
MARCHAN SETTING HIM UP FOR THE
BACK PICK.
CUSTOM TROPHY FROM YOUTUBE
COMING YOUR WAY.
THE PHILLIES WIL BE HEADING
BACK UP NORTH WITH A W.
3-2, THEY TAKE IT OVER THE
MARLINS.
MORE ON THE POSTGAME SHOW,
COMING UP.
>> ALL ZEROES.
EIGHT NO-HIT INNINGS FOR ROY
HALLADAY.
IN THE AIR, CHASE UTLEY.
NOTHING IS ROUTINE AT THIS
POINT.
ONE GONE.
TWO OUTS AWAY FROM A NO-HITTER
IN GAME ONE OF THE DIVISION
SERIES.
>> HE HAS NOT BEEN A DOCTOR
TONIGHT.
HE HAS BEEN A SURGEON.
>> VALDEZ WITH ROOM.
TWO OUTS.
THE REDS LAST HOPE, BRANDON
PHILLIPS.
ONE MORE PIECE TO THE PUZZLE FOR
ROY HALLADAY.
>> JUST ABOUT A QUARTER TO
EIGHT, OCTOBER 6, 2010, THE
FIRST POSTSEASON GAME.
THE 0-2.
SWING AND A DRIBBLER IN FRONT OF
THE PLATE.
>> I FEEL LIKE IT HIT BRANDON
PHILLIPS BAT A COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> THERE IS NO WAY WE ARE
GETTING HIM OUT.
SOMETHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN
SCREWY.
>> THEY WERE LIKE, NO-HITTER.
IF I DON'T MAKE THIS PLAY, IT IS
OVER.
>> RELEASE OUT TO GET IT.
IT IS A NO-HITTER!
UNBELIEVABLE.
THE PHILLIES CELEBRATE AROUND
ROY HALLADAY.
SCOTT: BACK ON THE POSTGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY GLAD YOU ASKED.
THIS WAS A GOOD ONE.
3-2, PHILLIES TAKE IT OVER THE
MARLINS IN SOUTH FLORIDA.
FANS HIT THE WATER AGAIN FOR A
GORGEOUS DAY AS USUAL IN MIAMI.
WE ARE GOING TO VIEW WHAT WENT
DOWN THIS AFTERNOON.
FIRST ON THE MOUND FOR THE
MARLINS, ROBLES.
DAN: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
STICKS OUT, TREMENDOUS CHANGEUP.
WE TALKED TO DON MATTINGLY
BEFORE THE GAME.
HE LIKES THE USES OF THE
CHANGEUP.
HE JUST DOES NOT WANT HIM TO
FALL IN LOVE WITH IT.
THIS SEASON, THE E.R.A. OF 2.73.
WALKS TO STRIKEOUTS IS GOOD.
>> RIGHT SIDE, FAIR BALL.
DIAZ TOSSING TO LOPEZ.
GOT HIM.
BEAT HIM BY MAYBE A STEP.
ROMAN QUINN NEVER THINKS HE IS
OUT WITH THAT SPEED.
THE OPPOSING PITCHER ON
PHILADELPHIA, SPENCER HOWARD,
MAKING HIS SECOND START OF THE
SEASON.
WEIRD OUTING ON SATURDAY.
DAN: HIS VELO, HE STARTED OUT
THE GAME 95-97.
SCOTT: JAMMED HIM.
A TOUGH PLAY AT SHORT AND THE
THROW IS ON TIME.
DAN: YOU CAN SEE WHY THE
PHILLIES REALLY LIKE SPENCER
HOWARD.
THAT IS A GOOD FASTBALL, ROJAS
CAN TURN ON THE HEATER PRETTY
GOOD.
SCOTT: RHYS HOSKINS GOES DOWN,
THAT ONE AVOIDED HIM, JUST
BARELY.
A CLOSE CALL, SOME CHIN MUSIC.
HOSKINS WITH A DEEP DRIVE, LEFT
CENTER, AND HE GOT IT.
DAN: THAT IS THE ULTIMATE
PAYBACK AS HE IS SALUTING THE
FELLAS IN THE BULLPEN.
GUESS KNOCKED DOWN, 2-2.
GUTSY AT-BAT.
SCOTT: RHYS HOSKINS MUSCLES UP
FOR HIS 11TH OF THE YEAR, EIGHT
OF THEM ON THE ROAD.
HE BREAKS THE ICE FOR THE
PHILLIES.
1-0.
HE HAD THAT ONE WITH A LITTLE
ADDED MOTIVATION.
DAN: TAKES ONE UP ON THE CHIN,
STAYS IN AND HANGS IN AGAINST A
TOUGH FRIDAY.
SCOTT: JOYCE SENDS ONE CENTER.
SIERRA HAS IT.
THIS WILL BE PLENTY DEEP ENOUGH.
IT IS 2-0 PHILLIES ON THE SAC
FLY FROM MATT JOYCE.
LEON AND DIAZ ON.
3-2, UP AND IN.
BAGS FULL OF MARLINS IN THE
FIFTH.
THIS IS RANGER SUAREZ TAKING
OVER.
HE HAS BEEN EXCELLENT THE SEASON
BUT THIS IS NOT A FUN SPOT FOR
HIM.
LOPEZ STRIKES OUT.
THAT IS A BIG FIRST OUT FOR
RANGER SUAREZ.
HERE COMES THE BIG MAN.
DAN: THIS IS WHERE YOU HAVE TO
STAY WITHIN YOURSELF.
SCOTT: AGUILAR LIFTS IT TO
CENTER.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THAT ARM FROM
ODUBEL HERRERA LOOKS LIKE.
THE RUN CAME ACROSS FIRST.
SO, THE MARLINS GET ONE AND THAT
WILL SIT DOWN THE SIDE.
STILL, RANGER SUAREZ ENTERS THIS
GAME BASES-LOADED, NOBODY OUT,
AND ALLOWS JUST A RUN.
MORE RANGER SUAREZ IN THE SIXTH.
THIS IS YOUR GUY.
DAN: HE WAS REALLY GOOD.
THREE POWERHOUSE INNINGS.
GETS THE FIELDER'S CHOICE AT
SECOND BASE.
MOVED THE BALL UP, DOWN, IN AND
OUT.
ULTIMATE STRIKE THROWER.
HE WAS TERRIFIC.
SCOTT: HE GETS A LITTLE HELP IN
THE SEVENTH BY ROMAN QUINN.
CLIFF: GREAT CATCH.
GREAT INSTINCT ON THE CATCH.
SCOTT: GROUNDBALL.
LOOK AT RANGER SUAREZ GO IN THE
MIDDLE INNINGS.
HE KNOWS HE CAME UP TAKE.
RAFAEL MARCHAN PICKS OFF ROJAS.
A VETERAN MOVE.
DAN: THIS IS A GREAT PLAY, AND A
GREAT TAG.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT LOOKS LIKE
ROJAS MAY HAVE HEARD HIMSELF ON
THE TAG GETTING BACK.
SCOTT: ALVARADO LOOKED LIKE HE
MIGHT HAVE ESCAPED THE JAM.
COOPER TO THE RESCUE.
DAN: ALVAREZ, A LITTLE BIT WILD,
THREE WALKS AND AND EARNED RUN.
SCOTT: ODUBEL HERRERA, NOT
ENOUGH TO LEAVE THIS BIG
BALLPARK BUT A TRIPLE AND THEY
WILL TAKE IT.
CLIFF: A LITTLE STUMBLE AROUND
SECOND BASE BUT HE GETS IN TO
THIRD SAFELY.
DAN: IT IS A GAME OF INCHES.
THIS LOOKS LIKE THE POTENTIAL
INNING ENDING DOUBLE PLAY.
TORREYES DOES A GREAT JOB.
SCOTT: HECTOR NERIS TIME IN THE
NINTH.
DAN: IF DOUBLE PLAYS ARE YOUR
THING, YOU HAVE TO LOVE THIS IF
YOU ARE THE PHILLIES.
5-4-3, JUST LIKE THAT.
THE PHILLIES SPLIT THIS
FOUR-GAME SET.
SCOTT: THE PHILLIES IMPROVED TO
25-26 ON THE SEASON.
THE MARLINS DROPPED TO 24-26
.
EVERY TEAM IS SO TIGHT, A
DIVISION THAT IS TRULY UP FOR
GRABS.
THE MARLINS HAVE DEALT WITH
INJURIES THIS WEEK.
NO JAZZ CHISHOLM TODAY, ANKLE
ISSUE.
GARRETT COOPER COMES UP AGAIN A
PINCH-HITS ABOUT TODAY.
THAT IS A GOOD SIGN FOR THE
OBLIQUE.
MIGUEL ROJAS LEFT THE GAME WITH
A FINGER ISSUE.
IS HE OK?
>> WE JUST RECEIVED WORD THAT
MIGUEL ROJAS DISLOCATED THE
INDEX FINGER ON HIS LEFT HAND
SLIDING BACK INTO FIRST BASE ON
THAT PLAY.
AS YOU MENTIONED BEFORE, JAZZ
CHISHOLM SIDELINED.
THIRD BASEMAN BRIAN ANDERSON IS
ON THE INJURED LIST.
HE AND ROJAS ARE GOLD GLOVE
AWARD FINALISTS ON THE LEFT SIDE
OF THE INFIELD.
AS WE SAW LATER, THE MARLINS HAD
TO DO A LOT OF MANEUVERING.
THEY MOVED JON BERTI TO THIRD,
THEY PUT JORGE ALFARO INTO LEFT
FIELD.
A LOT OF MOVING PARTS AND
DOMINOES.
THIS IS THERE AN OFFICIAL
CAPTAIN SO THIS WOULD BE A BIG
LOSS.
SCOTT: THANK YOU.
GREAT WORK TODAY.
YES, MIGUEL ROJAS, WE HOPE TO
HEAR GOOD NEWS FROM THE MARLINS
SIDE TOMORROW.
3-2, PHILLIES TAKE IT IN
GORGEOUS SOUTH FLORIDA.
MUCH MORE TO DO ON THE POSTGAME
SHOW.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> I GOT A HOT MIC ON.
>> I GOT A MIC ON!
ROBERT.
>> ODUBEL HERRERA!
HERRERA!
>> AM I ONE OF THE BEST LOOKING
RELIEVERS IN THE BIG LEAGUES?
>> SURVEY SAYS --
>> YES!
DING, DING, DING.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
I GOT A MIC ON.
JUST TO TELL YOU.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> THE FIRST BASEMAN, DIAZ, DID
HE JUST GET CALLED UP?
HIS DEBUT TODAY?
>> NO, HE GOT CALLED UP LAST
WEEK.
>> HE LOOKS THE PART.
>> LOOKING GOOD.
SI.
>> HELL OF A PLAY.
NICE JOB.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SAY WHAT'S UP
TO CHICKEN?
NEXT HALF INNING.
NEXT TIME HE TAKES HIS HAT OFF,
TAKE A LOOK AT HIS HAIR.
>> 92, OK.
HEY, HOW ARE YOUS?
>> JESUS.
>> GOT A HIT TOO.
THAT HAPPENS ONCE A GAME.
-- YEAH!
THE SEEDS ARE PLANTED.
JUST GOT TO WATER THOSE SEEDS.
BARELY GET OUT?
JUST RIGHT OVER IT?
>> IT IS HARD TO TELL.
SCOTT: LOOK AT BRYCE, NOT FAR
ENOUGH.
DAN: I THINK WHAT HE IS SAYING,
WHEN A GUY KNOCKS YOU DOWN, YOU
WANT TO HIT IT OUT OF THE
BALLPARK.
SCOTT: THAT IS THE GOOD STUFF.
SIX GAME HIT STREAK FOR HOSKINS.
SEVEN FOR HIS LAST 19.
THREE HOMERS PLUS THE MICROPHONE
ALL DAY TODAY.
PROPS TO JESUS AGUILAR AS WELL,
HOOKING US UP WITH SOME SWEET
SOUND ON YOUTUBE BACK ON THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
THAT IS WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE ON
THE FIELD?
CLIFF: I GUESS.
IT IS ALL NEW AND DIFFERENT.
BUT, BRYCE SAYING THAT, I WOULD
HAVE LOOKED UP LIKE, REALLY?
SCOTT: THAT WAS THE STATEMENT
FROM HOSKINS.
SOME STATEMENTS FROM OUR CURIOUS
CREATORS IN THE LIFE GAME
COMMENTARY.
COWBOY JEFF.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
THIS TEAM NEEDS MORE DAYS LIKE
TODAY.
DAN: THAT HAS REALLY PLAGUED THE
PHILLIES.
THEY HAVE HAD SOME INABILITY IN
THE EIGHTH AND NINTH INNING.
FROM BEGINNING TO END, SINCE THE
SEASON STARTED, DEFENSE HAS BEEN
A PROBLEM.
THE DEFENSE WAS AIRTIGHT.
PARTICULARLY THE OUTFIELD
DEFENSE.
RHYS HOSKINS READING A THROW OFF
THE LINE.
GETTING THAT RUNNER FROM THIRD
BASE.
ONE OF THE BETTER GAMES THE
PHILLIES HAVE PLAYED DEFENSIVELY
ALL GAME.
SCOTT: -29 DEFENSIVE RUN SAVED
ON THE SEASON ENTERING TODAY.
I'LL BET THAT NUMBER IMPROVED.
ROMAN QUINN OUT AND LEFT FIELD.
HE IS USUALLY A CENTER FIELDER.
CLIFF: THAT PLAY RIGHT THERE WAS
ALL ABOUT INSTINCTS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT, IF HE MISSES
THAT, THAT IS AN EASY TRIPLE.
I THINK JOE GIRARDI PUSHED THE
RIGHT BUTTONS TODAY.
SCOTT: HE EVEN PRESSED THE
CORRECT BUTTON WITH SOME HELP
FROM MOTHER NATURE.
SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE IS LIKE,
I AM VOTING FOR THE PIGEON.
THIS PIGEON WAS UNFAZED.
DAN: HE WAS NOT BUDGING.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET INTO THE
BALLPARK, SITUATED IN THAT GAP,
AND HE WAS NOT MOVING.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE TOP LEFT PART
OF YOUR SCREEN.
YOU ARE NOW ENTERING THE BIRD
SANCTUARY.
SCOTT: I DON'T THINK THAT WAS A
PIGEON.
DAN: IT IS]= INDOOR BIRDS THAT
NEEDS TO BE OUTSIDE.
SCOTT: NO FANS IN THE STANDS
LAST YEAR, I AM PUMPED BUT NOW
THEY ARE TAKING MY SEATS.
DAN: WHOEVER WAS IN RIGHT FIELD,
A GOOD SUPPLY OF SUNFLOWER SEEDS
ON THE ASTROTURF AND HE WAS NOT
MOVING.
SCOTT: WE ARE ABOUT TO HOP TO
RIGHT FIELD TO GRAB SOME OF
THOSE.
GREAT JOB BY CHRISTINA AS WELL
ON THE POSTGAME SHOW AS THE
PHILLIES TAKE IT 3-2.
WE DO THIS JUST ABOUT EVERY WEEK
ON YOUTUBE.
NEXT WEEK, WEDNESDAY, SIX DAYS
FROM NOW, THE METS VISIT THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
WE WILL HAVE IT EXCLUSIVELY ON
MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THE WEEK AFTER THAT,
DODGERS-PIRATES.
THE A'S PLAYING GREAT BASEBALL
IN THE WEST, TAKING ON A DELISE
GARCIA AND THE RANGERS.
SO MUCH MORE TO GO ON YOUTUBE.
YES, I KNOW, PRODUCTION STAFF
HAD TO THROW THIS IN OUR FACE.
THEIR INJURIES FOR THIS METS
TEAM BUT THEY ARE IN FIRST PLACE
IN THE DIVISION.
LOOK AT HOW MANY TRADES ARE
GOING TO BE PUT IN PLACE FOR
THIS TEAM.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRADE PLAYERS
ON THE INJURED LIST FOR PLAYERS
CURRENTLY ON THE ROSTER AND GO
MUCH BETTER THE REST OF THE WAY.
DAN: TAIJUAN WALKER THE OTHER
DAY IN AN INTRASQUAD GAME, AND A
SIMULATED GAME, HE THREW THE
BALL WELL.
THIS WAS A BUNCHED UP DIVISION.
THE PHILLIES NEED TO GET BRYCE
HARPER BACK INTO THE MIX.
AS FAR AS PITCHING, THE MARLINS
MIGHT BE IN A BETTER SITUATION
PITCHING-WISE THAN ANYONE ELSE
IN THAT DIVISION.
SCOTT: THAT IS A YOUNG MARLIN
STAFF AND THEY HAVE
REINFORCEMENTS ON THE WAY.
SIXTO SANCHEZ, HIS FIRST BULLPEN
SESSION YESTERDAY.
EDWARD CABRERA, A TOP 10
RIGHT-HANDED PITCHING PROSPECT.
WE TALKED TO TREVOR ROGERS
TODAY.
WE HAVE SEEN THE WORK HE IS
DOING SO FAR THIS YEAR.
HE IS NASTY.
DAN: THE KEY IS TO GET ROJAS
BACK IN THE LINEUP.
THEY CAN ILL AFFORD TO HAVE HIM
OUT FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
SCOTT: YOU'VE GOT TO WEATHER THE
STORM.
I AM EXCITED FOR THE METS, TO
SEE THIS TEAM ON YOUTUBE YES, WE
DID RECEIVE SOME TOUGH NEWS,
NOAH SYNDERGAARD COMING BACK
FROM TOMMY JOHN SURGERY AND THEY
WILL SHUT HIM DOWN FOR AT LEAST
A FEW WEEKS BEFORE HE RAMPS UP
AGAIN.
MAYBE IT IS SEPTEMBER BASEBALL
FROM THOR AND THE POWERFUL
FASTBALL.
JACOB DEGROM, WE DON'T KNOW THE
PITCHER IS YET.
IT COULD BE JACOB.
IF IT IS, HE IS SOMETHING ELSE
TO WATCH.
CLIFF: WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WEATHERING THE STORM, YOU HAVE
TO DO THAT IN THIS GAME.
NEXT MAN UP MENTALITY SOMETIMES
FORCES A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
YOU WOULD LIKE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, GUYS STEP
UP.
HOWEVER IS GETTING OPPORTUNITIES
TO PLAY, YOU JUST HAVE TO GET IN
THERE AND DO YOUR THING.
ONE OTHER GUYS COME BACK, YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
IT IS ALWAYS MORE THAN THE 25
MAN ROSTER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS NL EAST,
THAT IS WHY IT IS SO CLOSE.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY INJURIES,
MANAGERS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO YOU CAN GET FIVE INNINGS
FROM, GO TO THE BULLPEN, AND SO
FORTH.
DAN: EDWIN DIAZ HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD IN SAVE SITUATIONS.
MAY HAS BEEN REALLY GOOD.
THEY GET HEALTHY, LOOK OUT.
SCOTT: THEY ARE IN FIRST PLACE
NOW.
LOOK AT WHAT IS COMING BACK.
CLIFF, YOU ARE AWESOME.
AIR HIGH-FIVE.
DAN: LET'S GO BACK THERE.
SCOTT: THAT IS CLIFF'S SPOT.
THE GAME OF THE WEEK IS BACK
NEXT WEEK, JUNE 2.
A LITTLE MORE NL EAST.
THE METS MATCHING UP AGAINST THE
DIAMONDBACKS, 3:00 EASTERN
PREGAME SHOW.
COME HANG OUT WITH US AGAIN.
FOR DAN PLESAC AND CLIFF FLOYD,
THE GREAT CHRISTINA DEKE -- THE
GREAT CHRISTINA DENA: IN MIAMI,
I AM SCOTT BRAUN.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK FOR MORE
BASEBALL ON YOUTUBE.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]